MUCH WELCOME THE TO THE
REGULARLY SCHEDULED MEETING FOR
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS MEETING
A COUPLE OF HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
HAVE BEEN POLLS -- BY THE
AUTHORS OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINETY
THREE BY PATTERSON PULLED BY
AUTHOR FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
NINETY TWO BONTA PULLED BY
AUTHOR.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY QUIRK PULLED BY A
AUTHOR.
FOLLOW ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE
PULLED BY AUTHOR FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY NINE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK PAUL BY AUTHOR.
AND FINALLY FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN AT TWENTY FIVE BY JONES
SAWYER PULLED BY AUTHOR OF THOSE
ARE THE BILLS THAT HAVEBEEN
PULLED.
AND THEN WE WILL HEAD INTO
SPECIAL ORDER -- WE NOTICED THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM SO WILL BE
STARTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
WILL BEGIN THEN WITH THE FIRST
AUTHOR THAT WE HAVE PRESENT WITH
US.
IN FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE BY A DOCTOR EGGMAN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU CHAIR AND AN MEMBER.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE TODAY WHICH
Y. BELIEVES A SIMPLE BILL TO
PROTECT VETERANS AND TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
AND ALSO A PRICING I ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS -- DENOUNCES ALSO
PROVIDES A ROBUST HISTORY OF THE
ISSUE BUT I'LL START WITH A
BRIEF LITTLE RECAP IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES CONGRESS TO
ACTION TO PROVIDE FOR THE
REGULATION OF FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
TO ENSURE.
POSITIVE STUDENT OUTCOMES AND
THE PROTECTION OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THAT WILL FUND THEM.
WHEN THE PRIMARY PIECES OF THIS
WAS EIGHTY FIVE FIFTEEN ROLE
WHICH MAKE CLEAR THAT NO MORE
THAN 85% OF THE FOR PROFITS
TUITION REVENUE COULD COME FROM
FEDERAL AID AND FEDERALLY BACKED
LOANS?
WITHOUT THIS PROTECTION FOR FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES ARE ABLE TO
ESSENTIALLY ACT AS FULLY
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIZED
CONTRACTORS WITHOUT ANY COST
CONTROLS IT TYPICALLY COME ALONG
WITH THAT RELATIONSHIP.
THE RULE IS TO CONTROL COSTS FOR
PROFITS BY ENSURING THAT THE
PROGRAM HAS VALUE ON THE OPEN
MARKET AND THAT SOMEONE OTHER
THAN GOV THE GOVERNMENT.
IS WILLING TO PAY AT LEAST 15%
OF THE STUDENT'S TUITION.
THE RATIO WAS EVENTUALLY
WEAKENED TO THE NINETY TEN FOR
TITLE FOR FEDERAL AID -- WE AND
WE HAVE A SEPARATE EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTEEN RULE FOR THE GI BILL AND
VETERANS ENROLLMENT BUT THESE
RATIOS DON'T AVERAGE UP TOGETHER
THERE'S NO WAY THAT THEY
INTERSECT.
SO.
SAY THAT THEN THAT IT BECOMES A
100% GOVERNMENT GETS BECOMES
LEGAL FOR TO BE A 100%
GOVERNMENT FUNDED WITHOUT A
MANDATE A PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
TO PROTECT THE GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS.
THAT'S NOT THE ROLES FOR PROFITS
ARE ROLLED MEMBERS AS POLICY
MAKERS -- WE KNOW FROM -- FROM
THE STAFF REPORT -- AND THE NEW
YORK FEDERAL RESERVE IN THE IT
NINETEEN FORTY TWENTY FOURTEEN
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THAT LINK
BETWEEN FEDERALLY FUNDED
AVAILABLE EIGHT AND TUITION
COSTS A FOR PROFIT INSTANT
INSTITUTIONS.
IN FACT THESE HAVE DEFINITE
CORRELATIONS THE HIGHER THAT
THERE IS MUCH TO BE REIMBURSED
THE HIGHER THE COST GOES --
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW FOR FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS IT'S NOT
ANYTHING TO JUDGE.
BUT THEIR OBLIGATION IS TO THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS AND BOARD MEMBERS
AND NOT TO THE STUDENTS THEY'RE
DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO FOR FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
IT'S UP.
TO US TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT.
OR THE PEOPLE AS WELL AS TAX
PAYER DOLLARS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CONTAIN COSTS
TO A BLANKET EIGHTY FIVE FIFTEEN
ROLE ON TAXPAYER FUNDING.
IF SCHOOLS CAN'T MAKE THAT
THRESHOLD THEY CAN STILL ENROLL
STUDENTS AND THEN JUST SPEND AS
LITTLE AS 50% OF WHAT THEY BRING
IN -- BACK ON STUDENT
INSTRUCTION MONEY INTENDED FOR
STUDENTS SHOULD BE GOING. FOR
THOSE STUDENTS NOT JUST FOR
SHAREHOLDER PROFITS -- THIS IS
NOT A BILL TO CLOSE DOWN STOCKS
SCHOOLS BUT BUT IT WILL WILL
THEIR BUSINESS PRACTICE AND TO
EVALUATE.
WITH THE PRICES THEY ARE REALLY
CHARGING IS FAIR TO STUDENTS AND
TAXPAYERS -- IF THE THEY FORFEIT
THE STUDENTS ARE STILL
RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE VERY HIGH
LOANS THAT THEY TOOK OUT -- AND
OFTENTIMES WALK AWAY WITHOUT A
DEGREE AND AGAIN MEMBERS THIS IS
JUST TO SAY EIGHTY FIVE TO
FIFTEEN OR 50% OF WHAT YOU BRING
AND GOING TOWARD STUDENT
INSTRUCTION -- WITH ME TODAY AT
GREG HAYES AND SETH REAP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP TO TWO
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ABOUT IT.
GOOD MORNING GREG HAYES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES I CABS WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE IT'S A
CONSORTIUM OF SIX AGENCIES
AROUND CALIFORNIA THAT SERVES --
VETERANS IN TERMS OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL HEALTH.
I CABS IS -- MISSION IS TO SERVE
THOSE VETERANS SO THEY CAN --
THRIVE AND INTEGRATE BACK INTO
SOCIETY.
THE PURPOSE OF THE NINETY TEN
ROLE AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER A
WELL ARTICULATED WAS TO ENSURE
ACCURATE PRICING.
WHEN TAXPAYER DOLLARS USED TO
PURCHASE ITEMS OR SERVICES THE
US GOVERNMENT HAS WAYS OF
ENSURING WE ARE NOT OVER CHARGED
PRICE MEETING IS USED WHEN
CONTRACTING FOR HIGHWAYS WEAPONS
ETCETERA?
THE GOVERNMENT DICTATES WHAT
IT'LL PAY FOR MEDICAL PROCEDURES
COVERED BY MEDICARE AND MEDICAID --
MEDICAID SO TO ENSURE FOR PROFIT
PRICE SCHOOLS -- PRIVATE SCHOOLS
PRICE TUITION AT THE MARKET
VALUE RATHER THAN THE MAXIMUM
AMOUNT AMOUNT -- OFFERED BY THE
GOVERNMENT THE NINETY TEN ROLE
WAS CREATED REQUIRING THAT AT
LEAST 10% COME FROM A PRIVATE
SOURCE IN ORDER TO RECEIVE TITLE
FOR FUNDING.
THE NINETY TEN RULE DEFINES
PRIVATE -- AS TO WHICH IS NOT
RECEIVED FROM TITLE FOR AND WHEN
AT THE TIME TOTAL FOR WAS THE
ONLY SOURCE OF FEDERAL AID WHEN
THAT NINETY TEN ROLE WAS
ESTABLISHED WHEN LATER CREATED
THE POST NINE ELEVEN GI BILL.
AND DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
STUDENT AID WE'RE NOT CREATED
UNDER TITLE FOR SO THEREFORE
LEGALLY COUNTED AS PRIVATE MONEY.
VETERANS ARE TARGETED FOR THEIR
OWN BENEFITS BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH
VETERANS USE THEM AS THE SAME IN
IN THE SAME MANNER STUDENTS DO
WITH PELL GRANTS.
THEY ARE COUNTED AS PRIVATE
DOLLARS FOR EACH POST NINE
ELEVEN GI BILL AND DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE DOLLAR THEY RECEIVE. FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS CAN LEGALLY
TAKE IN NINE MORE DOLLARS IN
TOTAL FOR DOLLARS.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE CLOSES
THE LOOPHOLE BY INCLUDING
VETERAN BENEFITS AS FEDERAL
STUDENT AID REQUIRES THAT 15% OF
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
REVENUE FROM TUITION COME FROM
AN ACTUAL PRIVATE SOURCE.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES
PROTECTIONS IS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARTICULATED AND WE'D
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
SO VETERANS ARE NO LONGER
TARGETED FOR THEIR DOLLARS IN AN
UNFAIR MANNER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK N SUPPORT AT THE PODIUM
PLEASE THE NAME INSULATION
FEWEST OR DO YOU PLACE -- JUST
THEM AND ME TOO AS WELL WE'VE
EXCEEDED OUR TWO MINUTES SUPPORT
OKAY SIT IN SUPPORT AND WITH A
NAME FILIATION CAPTAIN CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS.
REPRESENT MEREKA LEGION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WHAT IS THIS IS FOR
JUST NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WOULD GET ON A CAN ON
IN ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING.
THE AMITY FOUNDATION AS WELL AS
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA PERRY ON BEHALF OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUPPORT AND SUCCESS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BRENDA ARIANNA ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHT
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
MAUREEN MAHONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS IN SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CAN OCCUR BECAUSE OUR
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION AND
ALL OF ITS LEGAL AID SUPPORT
GROUPS IN SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
IN IRAN **** ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY WE ON SUPPORT.
LUCY A MATIX ON BEHALF OF CENTER
FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING IN
SUPPORT.
AT OUR ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INTO TO THE
VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW.
ERIN AUGUSTA'S VETERANS CANNABIS
GROUP OPERATION IRAQI FREEDOM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN NONE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU CAN KINDLY
COME UP TO THE ROSTRUM HERE.
AND AGAIN UP TO TWO MINUTES FOR
TESTIMONY IN TOTAL.
ORDER MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MAP
BACK REPRESENTING CAPS
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS
REPRESENT ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
TO TWO HUNDRED SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THERE IN
ALL OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
THEY TEACH EVERYTHING FROM TRUCK
DRIVING COSMETOLOGY NURSING L.
B. AND YOU NAME IT.
ANYTHING YOU DID LAST WEEK
DURING SPRING BREAK BUT HE WENT
TO THE VETERINARIAN YOU WENT TO
THE DENTIST YOU WENT TO THE
STORE.
YOU MET ONE OF OUR STUDENTS THEY
WILL ALL BE AFFECTED BY THIS
BILL I AGREE WITH THE MEMBER OF
THE BILL IS VERY SIMPLE IT
CREATES AN ARBITRARY FORMULA.
THAT SAYS YOU HAVE TO TAKE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF REVENUE FROM
CERTAIN BUCKETS OF MONEY IT DOES
NOTHING IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH SCHOOL PERFORMANCE HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH GRADUATION
RATES HAS NOTHING DO WITH
PLACEMENT RATES IT'S SIMPLY IS
AN ARBITRARY FORMULA THAT SAYS.
WHERE YOUR TUITION COMES FROM
HAS TO BE THESE POTS OF MONEY --
FOR INSTANCE IS SCHOOL COULD
HAVE LOW TUITION AND HIGH
GRADUATION RATE.
SAME PROGRAM NEXT DOOR COULD
HAVE HI TUITION AND LOW
GRADUATION RATE THE HIGH TUITION
SCHOOL WILL QUALIFY UNDER THE
BILL BECAUSE THEY'LL HAVE THE
MARGIN OF ERROR -- TO MEET THE
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTEEN WHERE THE
LOW TUITION SCHOOL WILL NOT
BECAUSE WE CAN'T CONTROL HOW
MUCH DEBT STUDENTS COME TO OUR
SCHOOL WITH WE CAN CONTROL THE
TUITION.
BUT IF THEY HAVE THE MAXIMUM
ALLOWED UNDER FEDERAL LAW THEY
COULD ACTUALLY PAY FOR A 100% OF
THE PROGRAM.
OR 90% -- AND AGAIN WE CAN'T
CONTROL THAT BUT WE CAN CONTROL
OUR STUDENT OUTCOMES.
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING WITHOUT
COPS ON SO WE DID A SURVEY OF
OUR MEMBERSHIP APPROXIMATELY 70%
OF OUR SCHOOLS WOULD FAIL THIS
FORMULA.
LA -- NUMBER SAY WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA AT OUR
SO WELL OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS WOULD NO
LONGER HAVE A PROGRAM AGAIN
THESE STUDENTS ARE CHOOSING OUR
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES CSU
YOU SEE THEY DON'T ACCOMMODATE
WITH THE STUDENTS ARE LOOKING.
FOR THERE'S A REASON THEY COME
TO OUR SCHOOL SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED.
MISTER CHAIR SCOTT GOVERNOR
AFTER UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX
CERTAINLY WE CONCUR WITH MISTER
BACK I WOULD LIKE TO SAYS SPOKE
TO THE AUTHOR AND I NOTED YOUR
STAFF MEMBER THERE IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT DRAFTING ERROR.
WHICH YOU WOULD LIKE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER -- RIGHT
NOW THE BILL SUPPOSED TO BE
PROSPECTIVE BUT AS DRAFT THAT
IT'S HALF PERSPECTIVE AND HALF
ATTRACTIVE AND HOPE YOU FIX THAT.
THE OTHER THING IS THE CURRENT
LAW THE FEDERAL LEVEL IS NINETY
TEND TO SAY THIS IS CLOSING THE
LOOPHOLE WOULD SUGGEST KEEPING
THOSE NUMBERS INSTEAD WE ARE
CREATING AN ENTIRELY.
NEW NUMBER THAT IS NOT A
LOOPHOLE SO WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONALWITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH
TO DO SO.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FRED JONES
ON BEHALF OF THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LIVE IN ALL
TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY COLLEGES AND
KAREN TO COLLEGES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN.
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
DOCTOR EGGMAN DO YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU IN AN
THANK YOU FOR EVERYBODY WHO CAN
PROTEST BY TODAY I WILL SAY IT
IT IN RESPONSE. TO TO THE TO
MISTER BACK THAT.
OVER 62% OF THE SCHOOLS HE'S
TALKING ABOUT DON'T.
IF YOU KNOW MAKE ONE A TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION IN PROFITS THIS
WON'T APPLY TO YOU SO IT'S ONLY
THE ONES WHO ARE MAKING A WHOLE
LOT OF MONEY THAT THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY AFFECT IN A WAY.
THAT MIGHT BE -- HAVE SOME TO
GET TO GET THE BALL BACK TO THEM
BUT AGAIN ALL WE'RE SAYING IS
YOU CAN'T JUST HAVE AS MUCH AS
THE GOVERNMENT WILL PAY.
CHARGE THAT MUCH WITHOUT HAVING
SOME KIND OF PRIVATE INVESTMENT
COMING IN WE KNOW VETERANS ARE
TARGETED BECAUSE PEOPLE KNOW
THEY COME OUT WITH MONEY AND
THAT MONEY IS GONE AFTER IN VERY
AGGRESSIVE WAYS -- AND IF YOU IF
YOU DO MEET THAT THRESHOLD THEN
JUST PUT ARE YOU CAN'T MEET THEN
JUST PUT 50% RIGHT BACK INTO
TEACHING STUDENTS AND NOT JUST
GOING OUT TO RECRUIT MORE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
EGGMAN AND WE WILL.
TAKE UP THIS BILL WHEN WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW LOOKING AT ANY OTHER ITEMS
FOR ONE MOMENT
.
OKAY NEXT UP WE WILL GO.
TO LET'S SEE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN TWENTY IS A
SIMPLE BILL.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR EMPOWERED
STATE LICENSING AT AGENCIES TO
ESTABLISH FEES FOR THE
CULTIVATION AND SALE OF CANNABIS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CODIFIES THOSE
FEES INTO STATE LAW ESTABLISHES
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THOSE
FEES WHICH IS THE SAME THING
THAT WE HAVE DONE WITH NEARLY
EVERY FEE ESTABLISHED UNDERNEATH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS.
MISTER CHAIR LIKE TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THE BILL WE'RE CERTAINLY
COMMITTED TO LOOKING AT A SUNSET
REVIEW OF THOSE FEES AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
HI WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEE NINE ANY
WITNESSES IT.
IS IT IN SUPPORT.
HEY FRANK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
MINISTERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM CAN MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME.
A SUMMER ONLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE AND FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THESE OUTSTANDING ISSUES AND
WHEN WE HAVE A STEPS A QUORUM
WILL TAKE UP THIS ITEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
WHEN THEN MOVE BACK TO A FILE
ITEM NUMBER?
FOUR WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
CHOOSE HERE.
AND AGAIN WE WILL ALLOW UP TO
THREE MINUTES WHERE WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
NO MORE THAN THREE MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SOMEWHERE PLEASE PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
HI I'M HERE THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE IN HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT ON A. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR WHICH PROVIDE CRITICAL
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO
SAFEGUARD NEARLY HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THAT ARE ENROLLED ONLINE A FOR
PROFIT IN OUT OF STATE ONLINE
INSTITUTIONS.
THE LARGEST SHARE CALIFORNIANS
ENROLLED ONLINE AT SCHOOLS AND
OTHER STATES ARE ENROLLED IN FOR
THESE FOR PROFIT COLLEGES IT'S
ONE OF THE MOST TROUBLE BUSINESS
SECTORS IN MODERN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
AND WE HAVE A U. NEATLY TRAGIC
HISTORY WITH SUCH BUSINESSES.
OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS
FEDERAL CALIFORNIANS HAVE WORSE
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT OUT COMES
THEN CALIFORNIA BASED DISTANCE
EDUCATION PROVIDERS.
THE SHARE BORROWERS WHO END UP
IN DEFAULT IS ALSO HIGHER AT OUT
OF STATE DISTANCE EDUCATION
PROVIDERS THAN IN STATE
PROVIDERS.
SO WE I AM BRINGING THIS BILL TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS TO OUR
STUDENTS THAT SEEK THESE
[inaudible]
ONLINE. FOR PROFIT DEGREES FROM
THESE OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS
TODAY TO SPEAK ON MY BILL I HAVE
ANGELA PERRY A POLICY ANALYST
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
AND BRENDA OR RIANA FROM ERA WHO
READ TAROT WHO READ A STATEMENT
FROM A STUDENT WHO WORKED WHO
WENT TO SCHOOL KAPLAN ONLINE.
EVERY MUCH WELCOME.
COME MORNING ARE ANGELA PERRY
WITH TI GUESS THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS --
WELL SOME HOPE THAT ONLINE
EDUCATION CAN HELP MORE STUDENTS
EARN COLLEGE DEGREES THE PROMISE
OF DISTANCE EDUCATION ALSO HAS
PERILS.
THE CHALLENGES IN ASSESSING
ACADEMIC RIGOR AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES FOR ONLINE PROGRAMS CAN
BE EVEN GREATER THAN IN
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMS AND THERE'S
A LONG HISTORY OF OVER PRICED
AND POOR QUALITY PROGRAMS
LEAVING STUDENTS WITH DEBTS THEY
CANNOT AFFORD.
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WITH
PREDATORY FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
HAS LED TO THE CREATION OF MANY
LAWS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA
FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
HOWEVER THESE LAWS HAVE
TRADITIONALLY ONLY APPLIED TO
SCHOOLS LOCATED WITH IN
CALIFORNIA NOT SCHOOLS IN
ROLLING CALIFORNIANS BUT BASED
ELSEWHERE.
CALIFORNIA TOOK AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BY
REQUIRING OUT OF STATE COLLEGES
TO REGISTER WITH THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
AND TO PROVIDE GREATER
ASSURANCES OF FINANCIAL RELIEF
TO THOSE STUDENTS WHOSE PROGRAMS
WERE CLOSED.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
REGISTRATION SYSTEM THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS SUFFERS FROM
THREE CAN'T FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS.
FIRST THE STATE LACKS THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO IDENTIFY
RESTING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
SECOND THE STATE LACKS THE
AUTHORITY TO REVOKE A SCHOOLS
REGISTRATION IF THE WRIST TO A
STUDENT IS IDENTIFIED.
AND THIRD THE SYSTEM LACKS A
COMPLAINT PROCESS MEANING THAT
STUDENTS HAVE NO WAY TO IDENTIFY
THE ISSUES. TO THE BUREAU
DIRECTLY.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR ADDRESSES
THESE ISSUES BY REQUIRING OUT OF
STATE INSTITUTIONS TO REPORT
WHEN KEY OCCURRENCES TAKE PLACE
THAT MIGHT SIGNAL REST TO
STUDENTS.
EMPOWERS THE BEER TO TAKE ACTION
IF THEY DETERMINE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE AT RISK AND CREATES
A COMPLAINT PROCESS FOR STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN ONLINE PROGRAMS.
THESE ARE ESSENTIAL ESSENTIAL
STEPS FORWARD FOR THE STUDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE URGE AND
SECOND LEVEL HI.
I WANTED TO DO FOR THE REST OF
THE TIME TO BRENDA -- SURRENDER
JANA READING FOR SUSAN CURTIS MY
NAME IS SUSAN KURT CURTIS AND I
ATTENDED KAPLAN UNIVERSITY FROM
200-042-2000 NINE PURSUING AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE IN PARALEGAL
STUDIES.
IT WAS ALWAYS MY GOAL TO BE A
COLLEGE GRADUATE AND MOVE
FORWARD IN LIFE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF MY SON I BECAME INTERESTED IN
PARALEGAL STUDIES.
WHILE I SERVED AS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT IN
INSURANCE CLAIMS DEPARTMENT
WHERE IT EXPOSURE TO CLAIMS
LITIGATION.
KATHLEEN UNIVERSITIES XCELERATED
ONLINE EDUCATION WAS A BROAD
STROKE APPROACH TO THE ELEMENTS
OF BASIC LAW I WAS NOT AWARE OF
THE NECESSARY SKILLS AND
KNOWLEDGE THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PART OF THE CURRICULUM TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN CALIFORNIA'S.
MOST ENTRY LEVEL JOBS OR JUNIOR
PARALEGAL OR LEGAL SECRETARIAL
POSITION MY EDUCATION DID NOT
MEET MOST OF THE KNOWLEDGE
SKILLS AND ABILITIES REQUIRED
FOR ENTRY LEVEL PARALEGAL
POSITION IN CALIFORNIA.
KAPLAN UNIVERSITY DID NOT
PERFORM ANY READING ASSESSMENT
OF A STUDENT'S ABILITY TO WRITE
A CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL WHICH I THOUGHT SHOULD BE
HELD TO A HIGHER STANDARD IN THE
PARALEGAL PROFESSION.
ALTHOUGH I PREVIOUS COLLEGE
COURSEWORK I HAD NEVER COMPLETED
IN ENGLISH COMPOSITION AT A
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL I NEVER RECEIVED ANY
EVALUATIONS ON ANY LEGAL WRITING.
AN ANALYSIS SO I NEVER KNEW HOW
STRONG I WAS IN LEGAL WRITING
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD
YOU KINDLY WRAP OF YOUR COMMENTS --
AFTER TEN YEARS MY EDUCATION A
CAP ON YOUR IS IT IS NOT BEEN
VERY PRODUCTIVE TO ITS COST
LOCAL TO YOUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TEACHERS STUDENTS THE NECESSARY
SKILLS FOR EMPLOYMENT AT A LEGAL
PROFESSION.
SPECIAL FOR A FRACTION OF THE
COST.
I AM WITHOUT RECOURSE FOR THE
PRICE I PAID FOR THIS EDUCATION
IS PRODUCED LITTLE BENEFIT TO MY
LIFE THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW ANY
WHEN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
PODIUM.
SIMPLY NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
MORE MONEY ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER
REPORTS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD GET
DOWNEY WITH COULD ON IN
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CENTURY FOUNDATION AND THE AMITY
FOUNDATION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
SEE A MATIX WITH THE
REPRESENTING THE CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING IN SUPPORT.
IMAN MAJID ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE CHANCE
OAKLEY IN SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CAN -- BECAUSE OUR
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND ITS
THIRTEEN LEGAL AID PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GREG HAYES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JIMMY FROM JAN FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
JANUARY TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THERE ARE SO MANY OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN ON ANYONE
ELSE'S IN OPPOSITION.
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM KERN
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THIS TIME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DO YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
PRIVATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAD STILL ACTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE UP THIS ITEM
OF A SUBSEQUENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM.
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
HELLO SO GOES ON I CAN'T
REMEMBER.
YEAH HE'S STILL PRETTY IS
PRESENT REPAIR OVER YOU ARE
READY UP TO THREE MINUTES IN
TOTAL FIVE PART MINI SUPPORT OF
COURSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
I PRESENT YOU AB. THREE ONE
THREE FOUR FIVE IT WOULD SIMPLY
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES IN CURRENT
LAW RELATED TO RECRUITERS -- FOR
THESE FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
RELATED THEY'RE KICK BACKS
INCENTIVES FOR SIGNING UP
STUDENTS -- CURRENT LAW ONLY
PREVENTS KICKBACKS BY EMPLOYEES
AND DOESN'T INCLUDE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS.
ALSO CURRENT LAW DOESN'T
EXPRESSLY PREVENT KICKBACKS
BASED UPON AWARDS OF FINANCIAL
AID.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES BOTH THESE
ISSUES WE KNOW THAT ALMOST EVERY
MAJOR SCANDAL RELATE TO A FOR
PROFIT COLLEGE.
STARTS WITH THEIR SO CALLED OUR
RECRUITERS AT THESE RECRUITERS
ARE REALLY JUST HIGH PRESSURE
SALES PEOPLE -- PAY TO GET
BODIES INTO SEATS AND WHAT'S THE
IMPACT ON OUR FAMILIES OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR TAXPAYERS.
THE PEOPLE TARGETED BY THESE THE
RECRUITERS AS WE NOW ARE LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS TEENAGERS
VETERANS FIRST THEIR FAMILY TO
GO TO COLLEGE.
AND STUDENTS AND FORCE THEY'RE
BEING SCAMMED OUT OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS MONEY
THAT'S REPEAT THAT IT'S REQUIRED
TO BEING PAID BACK.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THEY FINISH THEIR PROGRAMS.
WORSE IS THE IMPACT ON TAXPAYERS --
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE NEW
YORK TIMES REPORTED THAT OF THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO SCHOOLS
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
THEY RECEIVED A COMBINED EIGHT
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
BILLION IN FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN --
AND GRANT PROGRAMS THE
OPPOSITION WILL TELL YOU HEY
THIS CAN BE ADDRESSED BY FEDERAL
LAW.
BUT CAN ONLY BE ADDRESSED
LITERALLY BY ONE PERSON THE
UNITED STATES SECRETARY OF
EDUCATION CURRENTLY HELD BY
BETSY TO BOSS.
AND WE CAN'T CALIFORNIA COUNT ON
THEM TO ENFORCE THESE AGREEMENTS
AND PROTECT OUR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS -- BY CODIFYING THIS
MEASURE IN STATE LAW WILL
STRENGTHEN OUR PROTECTIONS FOR
OUR STUDENTS AND GO AFTER
MALICIOUS INSTITUTIONS.
THAT -- TARGET OUR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS -- THIS BILL SUPPORTED
BY A BROAD COALITION OF VETERAN
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS LABOR
STUDENTS AND CONSUMER.
WILL HELP PUT A STOP TO THE
FRAUD AND ABUSE BEHIND BEING
DONE BY THE FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
THROUGH THEIR RECRUITING
PRACTICES I WITH ME AS A STUDENT.
AT OF A OF AN DEFUNCT COLLEGE IN
SACRAMENTO AND AND HOWARD SENIOR
COUNSEL WITH THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY.
GROUP KIND THE POSSIBLE MOMENT
WE'VE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
LOW HERE BRO BLOOM CHEN.
CHIU CUNNINGHAM DALY EGGMAN FONG.
GIPSON.
GLORIA
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA.
TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH THE SAP
IS GOING AND AGAIN JUST A
REMINDER UP TO THREE MINUTES IN
TOTAL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AT
HOWARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY AND TO THE
VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW.
I'M I WANT TO SPEAK BRIEFLY
ABOUT ONE VERY IMPORTANT
AMENDMENT THAT WAS TAKEN IN THE
LAST COMMITTEE MICHIGAN BEFORE
BEFORE I DO THOUGH I DO WANT TO
THANK -- THE COMMITTEE -- FOR
ALL OF THE EXCELLENT STAFF
ANALYSES ON ON ALL OF THESE
BILLS ARE THEY WERE JUST SUPER
BY THE WAY.
AND WHILE I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
ONE PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
MEMBER THAT WAS TAKEN IN THE
LAST COMMITTEE IN RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE POSSIBLE
OVER BROUGHT THE BILL.
THE COMMITTEE.
AND THEN CHANGED THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL TO PROHIBIT
COMPENSATION QUOTE RELATED TO TO
RECRUITMENT ENROLLMENT AND
CONTINUED ENROLLMENT. TO INSTEAD
SAY CONTINGENT UPON RECRUITMENT
ENROLLMENT AND CONTINUE TO GROW.
THAT MEANS THE BILL NOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ONLY
APPLIES TO THOSE KINDS OF
COMPENSATION SITUATIONS WHERE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE DEFINITION OF
WHAT CONTINGENT MEANS.
OR CAR OR EXIST ONLY BECAUSE OF
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES ABOUT US.
THIS BILL AS AMENDED ON APRIL
NINTH IN THE LAST COMMITTEE.
ONLY TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION SAYS THAT UNLESS
A SALES PERSON WE'LL BE PAID
CERTAINLY IS TOLD UP FRONT THAT
THEY WILL BE PAID.
BASED ON A PARTICULAR -- A
BENCHMARK.
THAT'S WHEN THE BILL APPLY.
CONVERSELY IF SOMEONE AFTER THE
FACT A SALES PERSON AFTER THE
FACT.
SIMPLY IS REWARDED FOR DOING A
GOOD JOB WITH THE EMPLOYER
RETAINS DISCRETION FOR GIVING
THAT PERSON A GOOD JOB THIS BILL
DOES NOT APPLY.
AN EXTREMELY SIGNIFICANT MOMENT
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT ADDRESSES
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT THE POSSIBLE OVER BREADTH
OF THE BILL AND CERTAINLY IF
THERE.
ARE ISSUES THAT REMAIN IN THE
DRAFTING I DO KNOW THAT THE
AUTHORS OFFICES CERTAINLY
WILLING TO LISTEN TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOAT
ON THIS ABSOLUTE CRITICAL
MEASURE. TO PROTECT TEENAGERS
CHILDREN OF COLOR VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S ANGELA
PERRY WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS I'LL
BE READING AN EXCERPT OF JENNY
MORRIS'S TESTIMONY UNFORTUNATELY
SHE HAS HAD SOME TRANSPORTATION
DELAYS AND WAS NOT ABLE TO BE
WITH US THIS MORNING -- I NAME
IS JENNY MORRIS I WENT TO THE
NOW DEFUNCT MARSHMALLOW SCHOOL
OF BEAUTY HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE PROGRAM
WAS A TEN SHORT MONTHS NOTHING
TO GLAMOROUS THE SCHOOL WAS A
SMALL.
HOLE IN THE WALL KIND OF PLACE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE
ENROLLED AT LEAST WHILE I
ATTENDED WAS EITHER ON SOME SORT
OF GOVERNMENTAL ASSISTANCE OR
HAVE THEIR PARENTS COSIGN FOR
THEIR LOANS.
AND MARIN ELLO EVERYONE KNEW
THAT THE SCHOOL IS NOT BEING
TRUTHFUL ABOUT THE FUNDS
RECEIVED ON THEIR LOANS BUT WE
COULDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THE SCHOOL PREYED UPON PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND PEOPLE WITH LIMITED
INCOME BECAUSE OF THOSE PEOPLE
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM AND
WANTED SURE THAT THE SCHOOL
WOULD CONTINUE TO RECEIVE TITLE
FOREIGN LOAN PAYOUTS.
THE SCHOOL IN SO FAR AS TO
ENROLL STUDENTS KNOWING THEY HAD
NO HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR GED
AND HAD FRAUDULENT ATP PASSING
TEST SCORES.
PUT ON TO APPLICATIONS FOR
FEDERAL LOANS JUST TO SECURE
THAT TOTAL FOR A LOAN.
I WAS PROMISED LIFETIME JOB
PLACEMENT ASSISTANCE THAT I
WOULD AND THAT WHAT I WOULD MAKE
TEN TIMES MORE MONEY WITH MY
COSMETOLOGY LICENSE.
I'M REALISTIC I KNEW I WOULDN'T
BE SOME SUPER GLAMOROUS STYLIST.
ART BUT MY EXPERIENCE IS NOTHING
UNUSUAL TO ANYONE THAT IS
ATTENDED A FOR PROFIT POST
SECONDARY COLLEGE THANK YOU VERY%
MUCH I DIDN'T ADDITIONAL BONUSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO
AT THE MIKE.
GREG HAYES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION VETERANS
SERVICE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
I WOULD GET ON A ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION AND THE
AMITY FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CAN A CLOSER TO HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
MORNING HONEY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA OREGON ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
PRESS CLR UP ON THE TIAS THE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IRAN **** ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY IN SUPPORT.
JANUARY TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
OUT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE TABLE HERE.
AND AGAIN UP TO THREE MINUTES
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAP BACK REPRESENTING
CAPS SO FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AMENDMENTS WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN THAT MISTER HOWARD
REFERENCED.
AND ALSO HAVE STARTED A
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE WHICH HAS BEEN
CONSTRUCTIVE IN AND WE DO THINK
THAT WE CAN.
WORK TO NARROW THE BILL -- GIVEN
EVEN MISTER AVERAGE COMMENTS I
DO THINK THERE ARE FLAWS IN THE
BILL FOR INSTANCE THE BILL HAS A
STATEMENT THAT SAYS YOU CANNOT
CONDITION THE EMPLOYMENT IF
ANYBODY.
SO WE CAN HAVE EMPLOYEES THAT
ARE NOT DOING THEIR JOB BUT WE
COULDN'T FIRED THEM.
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T CONDITION
THE EMPLOYMENT ON THE ON THE
PORTIONS OF THIS PARAGRAPH IN
THE AUTHORS OFFICE ACTUALLY --
AGAIN AND I WANT TO SAY THEY
AGREED WITH THAT BUT THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT MIGHT BE
AN ISSUE -- THAT THE BILL SAYS
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY SAYS ANY
EMPLOYEE ANY COMPENSATION VERY
BROAD TERMS SO WE FULLY AGREE
THAT EMPLOYEES SHOULD NOT BE
GETTING QUOTAS OR COMMISSIONS AS
RECRUITERS.
OUR SCHOOL DON'T DO IT -- AND
AND THE LAW ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA
ALLOWS REGULATORS TO GO AFTER
YOU IF YOU DO BUT IF THEY WANT
TO MAKE THE BILL STRONGER MAKE
THE LOS STRONGER WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT AGAIN
BECAUSE OUR SCHOOLS DON'T DO IT --
SO WE LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH YOU
AND AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN NARROW
THE THEIR LANGUAGE.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS FRED JONES ON
BEHALF OF THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA --
MOSTLY ALMOST ALL MONPA SMALL
SCHOOLS -- MANY OF THEM ARE
MEMBERS OF CAPS.
I WOULD LIKE SAY JUST GLOBALLY
ON ALL THESE BILLS THE BPP COULD
SHUT DOWN BAD SCHOOLS WITH WHAT
LEGAL RIGHTS THEY HAVE RIGHT NOW
OUR STATE BORDER BARRING
COSMETOLOGY FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
HAD -- FACTUAL EVIDENCE ABOUT
SOME BAD BEAUTY SCHOOLS WHICH
PPP DID NOTHING ABOUT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS UNTIL THEY HAD A
RECENT CHANGE IN THEIR BUREAU
CHIEF.
THERE BUREAU CHIEF FINALLY NEW
BUREAU CHIEF WORKED WITH OUR
STATE BOARD OF ARMING
COSMETOLOGY.
PUT A TEMPORARY HOLD ON THREE OF
OUR BAD BEAUTY SCHOOLS.
THOSE THREE IMMEDIATELY SHUT
DOWN AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT SHUT
DOWN THE VERY NEXT WEEK ALL OF
THAT HAPPENED UNDER EXISTING LAW
ALL OF THAT WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
BECAUSE THE GOOD BEAUTY SCHOOLS
ARE THE ONLY ONES THAT WILL
COMPLY WITH THESE NEW LAWS AND
THESE NEW LAWS WILL BE
INCREDIBLY CUMBERSOME. TO COMPLY
WITH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION NAY
MANIPULATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'VE
IN ALL TOMORROW AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY COLLEGE IN
CARRINGTON COLLEGE ALIGNING
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS
MISTER BACK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS LAURA BROWN NOT IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL I'M
REPRESENTING TO YOU WHICH IS AN
ONLINE.
A LEADING ONLINE PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT COMPANY AND WE
REPRESENT TWENTY EIGHT NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE GLOBE
INCLUDING FOR HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE JUST PRIMARILY SEEKING
CLARIFICATION GIVEN THE
TESTIMONY IN THE PRIOR POLICY
COMMITTEE.
COUPLED WITH THE OBVIOUSLY WHICH
HAS BEEN MENTIONED THE EXIT THE
NEGATING OF THE FEDERAL RULE
EXCEPTION THAT OUR PARTNERSHIP
SCHOOLS LOCATED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT.
CAPTURED WITHIN THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL SO WE'RE SEEKING
CLARIFICATION FROM THE AUTHOR
THAT THE NONPROFIT NON MáS
SCHOOLS ARE EXEMPT AND STILL
HAVE THE ABILITY CHAIR -- TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FEDERAL ROLE
EXCEPTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SAYING
NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
YEAH.
KATE DISSIDENT MOTION A SECOND --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARD IF YOU WISH
TO CLOSE.
SB I'VE GOT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS BILL THAT I WILL
NOT TO I'M SORRY INTERRUPT.
IS THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO TO
WORK WITH THE WITH THE PARTIES
AND AND I I TAKE A HEART WHAT
THEY SAID IS THEY DON'T LIKE
THIS PRACTICE.
THEY DON'T DO IT IN IN THERE I
INSTITUTION SO I DON'T SEE WHY
THERE'S A PROBLEM WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION AS THIS --
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD HAD
THIS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE MOTIONS
TO PAST APPROPRIATIONS LOW
THOUGH I BROKE BLOOM.
GEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM
DALY.
DON OFFERING EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG.
PHONE UP DURING GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAY AYE GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
THAT THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THEN MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE BY SIMPLY MEMBER BERMAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN THIS DOES
JOY AND TO PASS RECOMMENDATION
ON BOTH SIDES IF YOU'RE PAYING
ATTENTION.
THIS FIRM DID YOU HEAR WHAT I
STATED.
JUST HAD A CURIOSITY.
I DID NOT -- DON'T KNOW
CONVERSES YOUR CALL OR YOU'RE
WORKING AT YOUR BILL OVER THAN
OTHER VIP MEMBER THIS DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES AL JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU
THAT -- COURTESY ARRIVE
APPRECIATE THAT SO.
IS THAT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU SIR.
AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ADVOCATES RESPONSIBILITY TO
PRACTICE TUNES CALIFORNIA'S ROLE
BECOMES EVEN MORE CRITICAL.
GOING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT I CAN
CUT OUT.
THEY BE THIRTY FORTY ONE WILL
PREVENT COVERT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES FROM OF EATING STATE
OVERSIGHT BY REQUIRING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN INSTITUTION THAT
CLAIMS TO BE NONPROFIT COLLEGE.
FOR PUBLIC COLLEGE ACTUALLY
MEETS THE DEFINITION OF A
NONPROFIT CORPORATION A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION
I RESPECT AFTER I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
VOICES IN.
NO MORE THAN THREE MINUTES.
FROM THE CENTURY FOUNDATION
COURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE BELL
TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD GET ON A
REPRESENTING THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS THE AMITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MORE MONNING ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA OREGON ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
AT OUR CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
SCHOOL OF LAW IN SUPPORT.
ANGEL PERRY AND STEVE COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS AND TRANSPORT.
GREG HAYES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEE NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS IT
COMES FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
SEE NONE.
IS ALREADY BEEN IN MOTION AND A
SECOND TWENTY SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE MOTIONS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS LOW LOW
AYE BRO BLOOM.
JOHN GEN I TO TO AYE CUNNINGHAM
DALY DALY AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA GLORIA AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
ABILITY AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS A TEN VOTES WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS FAMOUS JR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THEN BACK TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
BY SEPTEMBER.
TWO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB --
THIRTEEN FORTY LET ME START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBER
AND SOMEONE ELSE THANK THE CHAIR
AND STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THAT.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS FROM OVER
PRICED INEFFECTIVE CAREER
TRAINING PROGRAMS BY REINSTATING
A STATE VERSION OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT RULE RECENTLY SCRAP
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THIS RULE WAS IMPLEMENTED TO
ADDRESS THE ALL TOO COMMON STORY
OF A STUDENT PROMISED BY
RECRUITER THAT HERE SHE WILL
FIND A JOB IN AN INDUSTRY.
WHO TAKES OUT TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN DEBT ONLY TO FIND
UPON GRADUATING THAT NO JOBS
EXIST IN THAT SPACE -- THEY FACE
ASTRONOMICAL DEBT PAYMENTS OR
EVEN LOAN DEFAULT.
THE GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT RULE
APPLIED TO CAREER TRAINING
PROGRAMS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID.
UNDER THE RULE A PROGRAM AND
I'LL MENTION NOT AN ENTIRE
SCHOOL BUT AN INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM.
DIDN'T PASS MUSTER IF MORE THAN
HALF OF ITS GRADUATES HAD AN
EXCESSIVE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
BURDEN WHEN WEIGHED AGAINST
INCOME AFTER COLLEGE.
BASED ON INITIAL DATA FROM THE
FEDERAL EDUCATION DEPARTMENT
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA DID NOT
PASS THIS TEST.
THE SHODDY PROGRAMS GRADUATED
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
LEFT SCHOOL WITH NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
LAST YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION
MOVE TO SCRAP THE GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT RULE FUELING THE
GROWTH THE PREDATORY SCHOOLS IN
ABANDONING SAFEGUARDS THAT
PROTECTED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS.
THIS BILL WOULD REINSTATE THE
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT RULE THAT WAS
RECENTLY SCRAPS OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE BETTER AND WE NEED TO
PROTECT THEM.
WITH ME IS BOB SHERMAN FROM THE
CENTURY FOUNDATION AS WELL AS
THERESA WAS A FORMER STUDENT
FROM A FOR PROFIT COLLEGE MISTER
SHERMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO MORE THAN
THREE MINUTES PLEASE GOOD
MORNING -- ON APRIL NINTH THEY
SHARE MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH THE I'D COMMITTEE ABOUT
ATTENDING A FOR PROFIT TRADE
SCHOOL.
CALLED THE BROOKS INSTITUTE --
OWNED BY CAREER EDUCATION
CORPORATION.
I'M SORRY CAREER EDUCATION
CORPORATION EXPLAIN HOW THE
SCHOOL AND THEIR PREDATORY
MISLEADING MARKETING PRACTICES
LED TO A STUDENT LOAN BALANCE
THAT HAS SINCE BALLOONED TO OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND HOW IT HAS AFFECTED MY LIFE.
TODAY I'D LIKE TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT I'M FAR FROM BEING AN OUT
LIAR.
THE SAME THING HAPPENED TO
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS THAT
ATTENDED BROOKS AS WELL AS OTHER
CC SCHOOLS.
IN A RECENT SURVEY OF JUST THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE FORMER
BROOKS STUDENTS THEIR COMBINED
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE STUDENT LOAN
DEBT WAS OVER FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
AGAIN THAT'S FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE STUDENTS.
IN ALL OF THESE SITUATIONS THE
COMMON THEME IS THAT BROOKS IN
THEIR ADMISSIONS REPRESENTATIVE.
LIE TO STUDENTS ABOUT JOB%
PLACEMENT RATES DEBT LEVELS POST
GRAD SALARIES THE TYPES OF LOANS
TO STUDENTS WERE TAKING OUT.
AND THE TRANSFER ABILITY OF THE
CREDITS THEY AREN'T.
AND THEY GOT AWAY WITH IT PARTLY
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT RULE FOR THIS TYPE OF
SCHOOL AT THAT TIME SO STUDENTS
CAN FACT CHECK THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY WERE GIVEN.
I'VE GOTTEN PERMISSION FROM A
FEW STUDENTS TO SHARE THEIR
STORIES AND TO TELL YOU HOW IT
AFFECTED THEM.
HI DIAN TYSON STAFFORD A COUPLE
WHO ATTENDED BROOKS TOGETHER
ENDED UP WITH A COMBINED TOTAL
STUDENT LOAN DEBT OF NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
FORTUNATELY THEY WERE LATER ABLE
TO SETTLE FOR APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
JACQUELINE HUBBARD ANDHER
HUSBAND ALSO ATTENDED TOGETHER
THEIR COMBINED A IS OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MINUTES THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THEY BOTH WORK IN FULL TIME IN
FIELDS UNRELATED TO THEIR COURSE
OF STUDY. TWO OF THEIR THREE
CHILDREN HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS AND
I CANNOT FOR THE THERAPY AND THE
TUTORING THAT THEIR CHILDREN
NEED.
SHE'S BEEN IN UNABLE TO TRANSFER
ANY OF THE CREDITS THAT SHE
EARNED.
LASTLY DIRTY GRAY MADE HER
DECISION TO ATTEND BROOKS BASED
ON INFORMATION GIVEN TO HER IN
BAD FAITH BY THE SCHOOL.
THAT HAS BALLOONED FROM ONE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SHE TOLD ME
THAT HER APPLICATION TO BECOME A
FOSTER PARENT WAS DENIED
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF THIS
DIRE.
I COULD GO ON BUT I THINK YOU
GET THE POINT WELL HUNDREDS OF
FORMER BURKE STUDENTS HAVE
APPLIED FOR BORROWERS DEFENSE TO
REPAYMENT.
DEVICE IN HER DEPARTMENT OF ED
ACTIVELY SEEK TO PREVENT US FROM
GAINING REDRESSED GOING SO FAR
AS TO STRIP SCHOOLS LIKE BOOKS
FROM THE GAME FOR EMPLOYMENT
ROLE.
I HOPE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL AGAIN TAKE THE
LEAD AND HELP TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO TRUTHFUL
RELIABLE INFORMATION WHEN THEY
ARE CHOOSING THEIR SCHOOLS.
OPTION SENIOR FELLOW AT THE
CENTURY FOUNDATION WHILE MANY
FOR PROFIT ST STUDENTS
RESPONSIBLY UNFORTUNATELY
STORIES LIKE TRIPLE -- LIKE TO
RACES ARE FAR TOO COMMON -- THEY
USE THE HOPES OF A WELL PAYING
JOB TO RECRUIT STUDENTS TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT OPTIMISM USE
GOVERNMENT LOANS TO ENROLL THEM
AND THEN THE STUDENTS AND UP
STOCK WOULD WITH DEBTS THEY
CANNOT REPAY.
AND DEBTS THAT ARE NOT
DISCHARGED BOWL IN BANKRUPTCY
COMMONSENSE POLICY THE GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT ROLE WE TRACK STUDENT
DEBT YOU TRACK INCOMES AND IF
MORE THAN HALF OF THE STUDENTS
ARE FOR OUR HAVE UNAFFORDABLE
THAT GIVEN THEIR EARNINGS.
THAN THE PROGRAM HAS TO STOP IN
ROLLING NEW CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
I ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD GET ON A
REPRESENTING THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS THE AMITY
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JANUARY TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANGEL PERRY INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIN COUNTY ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA OREGON ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
IN MY IMAGES ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCE OAKLEY IN SUPPORT.
RESCUE Là AB ON THE DS THE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GREG HAYES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
AT OUR CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE AND VETERANS LEGAL
CLINIC AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN
DIEGO SCHOOL OF LAW IN SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CAN A KAISER BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA AT LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND ITS
THIRTEEN LEGAL AID PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEE NINE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
TABLE HERE.
AND NO MORE THAN THREE MINUTES
FOR TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER MEMBER SCOTT GOVERNOR
HERE BEHALF AT UNIVERSITY OF
PHOENIX FIRST THE UNIVERSITY HAS
NO PROGRAMS THAT WE PUT IN
JEOPARDY PURSUANT TO THIS BILL.
NONETHELESS I'VE WORKED WITH THE
BUREAU AND ITS SUCCESSORS FOR
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS THERE'S
GOING TO BE A HOT SUNSET REVIEW
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY THERE'S A HEARING
IN THE SENATE A FEW WEEKS AGO
CONCERNING ONGOING COMPLAINT
ISSUES THE BUREAU.
I CAN SAY FOR MY CLIENT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE RECEIVE
COMPLAINTS IN THE BUREAU WE
RESPOND WE GET NOTHING IN RETURN
THERE ARE NO CLEAR COMPLAINT
PROCESS SEES IN PLACE. TO THE
EXTENT THIS MEASURE WILL ADD
EXPONENTIALLY TO THE BUREAU'S
WORKLOAD WE SEE NO BENEFIT TO
STUDENTS.
IN FACT THE ANALYSIS WHAT VERY
COMPREHENSIVE REFERS TO THIS AS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT'S
NOT WHAT GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT IS
YOU ARE CREATING COMPLETE --
LISTS YOU ARE COMPARING DATA
WITH EDT YOUR DOING ITS
UNIFICATION IN FACT IN THE
FEDERAL REGISTER WHEN THEY
ELIMINATED THIS ASPECT OF G. E..
THEY WERE PORTED SAVINGS OF
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS SO
YOU KNOW WE THINK THE BUREAU
COULD ULTIMATELY BE ABLE TO DO
THIS HOWEVER LET'S WAIT FOR THE
SUNSET REVIEW LET'S SEE HOW
THOSE REFORMS HAVE WORKED.
BEFORE WE EFFECTIVELY DOUBLE
THEIR WORKLOAD WE SHOULD PUT
STUDENT COMPLAINTS IN FURTHER
RISK THANK YOU.
BACK UP SYNC OFFERED ASSOCIATION
PURPOSE SECONDARY SCHOOLS WE
ALSO WERE OPPOSED -- THE DATA
MATTERS AND AND WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE DATA SO THE BILL SINCE
THE MAYOR'S FEDERAL LAW
COSMETOLOGY SCHOOL SUED THE
FEDERAL LAW AND THE COURTS FOUND
THAT THE ORIGINAL GAME PLAN
POINT LAW HAD FLAWS.
AND AND THEY BASICALLY FORCE THE
GOVERNMENT TO CHANGE IT THIS
BILL DOES NOT RECOGNIZE THOSE
CHANGES IT IT ADOPTS THE VERSION
BEFORE THE LAWSUITS.
THE EDT ONLY HAS W. TO
INFORMATION IT DOES NOT HAVE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
INFORMATION SO ANYBODY MASSAGE
THERAPY PARKS COSMETOLOGY EXCEPT
FOR THEIR INFORMATION WILL NOT
BE AT DD THERE FOR THE BUREAU
CANNOT CALCULATED -- ALSO OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS SO WE DO HAVE
GRADUATES ARE OUT OF STATE OR
MAYBE MOVE OUT OF STATE HE DOES
NOT HAVE INFORMATION ON THEM
THEREFORE OUR PROGRAMS CANNOT
PASS.
ALSO REGIONAL DIFFERENCES
SOMEONE WORKING IN SAN FRANCISCO
CERTAINLY MAKES MORE THAN
SOMEONE IN BAKERSFIELD THIS
DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
JOHN FRED JONES ON BEHALF
PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION THANK.
I RURAL TOMORROW WE HAVE THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY COLLEGE IN
CARRINGTON COLLEGE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND EDITION --
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION IN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COUNTY MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME?
SEEING NONE.
THE SUMMER TO DO WAS TO CLOSE.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANNA MENTION
A FEW THINGS I IT HI I RESPECT
THE OPPOSITION'S PERSPECTIVE
THAT THEY HOPE THAT THIS IS
DELAYED.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS --
BASED ON THE MOST RECENT DATA
WE'VE SEEN OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT DID NOT PASS THIS TEST
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
WERE VICTIMIZED IN THE WAY THAT
THERESA.
WHO JUST TESTIFIED WAS
VICTIMIZED AND WE NEED TO ENSURE?
THAT WE REINSTATE THE ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS IN PLACE SO
THAT WE PROTECT FUTURE STUDENTS
WITH THE REST OF DATA AGAIN VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO MAKE
SURE THE DATA IS PUT IN PLACE I
WANT JUST NOTE THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PRESIDENT TRUMP
HIMSELF PUT OUT AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER REQUIRING THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. TO MAKE
THE PROGRAM LEVEL DATA THAT THEY
HAVE ABOUT EARNINGS AND
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND SO
OUR HOPE IS THE DATA WILL
CONTINUE TO EXIST BUT IF IT
DOESN'T -- THIS BILL -- AND
ENVISIONS WHAT WE NEED TO DO AT
THE STATE LEVEL -- TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT THE SLOTS SO WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS DOESN'T
REALLY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION IS
THERE A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
MOTION BY.
MR GLORIA SIR SECOND.
SECOND BY ATTACHMENT CONSIDER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY MOTIONS TO
PASS ADMITTED TO APPROPRIATIONS
LOW HIGH LOW AYE BRO.
BLOOM GEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM
DALY.
DON OPERATING EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG FUNG UPLOADING
GIPSON?
GLORIA KALRA AYE GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NOW
[inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
THE BILL HAS THE SIX AYE VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THEM AGO. TO FROM SPECIAL ORDER
BUSINESS TO BILLS HEARD AND
FOLLOW ORDER BUT LET'S FIRST OFF
AGO WITH AT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS THERE A MOTION FOR CONSENT.
AND AGAIN FOR CONSENT WE HAVE
TEN BILLS ON CONSENT COUNTER
TODAY WHICH IS AB.
THREE MISTER COOPER.
A. B. FIVE FORTY FOUR MR BRO AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY SUMMER
SALAS.
A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE BY
SOMEONE ARE FONG.
ASSEMBLY BILL AT SEVENTEEN
TWENTY THREE BY DR WOODSAND
THEN THE SUNSET EXTENSION BILLS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN TWENTY SOME BILL FIFTEEN
TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWO ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRET PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB THREE DEPOSIT APPROPRIATIONS
A. B. FIVE FOUR FORTY PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS A. B. FOURTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS A. B. FIFTEEN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN
TWENTY ONE FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO
FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE ALL THE
PAST OPERATIONS A. B. FIFTEEN
FIFTY THREE TO PASS.
A REFIT SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE
THE PASTOR RATIONS SLOUGH.
HI Là LIBRO.
BLOOM [inaudible]
JOHN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DOLLY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA.
HI GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE QUIRK
SILVA?
TING.
DEAD THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES.
I READ THE CONSENT AS IT DOESN'T
LEAVE THE WILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THE MOVING ON TO FOLLOW ORDER.
SEE FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWO FORTY ONE BY SELLER COME
LONGER DOES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWO FORTY ONE AB TWO FOUR ONE
WOULD REDUCE DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE BY REQUIRING
CONTINUED MEDICAL EDUCATION
COURSES TO INCLUDE.
CURRICULUM ON IMPLICIT BIAS FOR
LICENSEES UNDER THE MEDICAL
BOARD PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOARD
AND THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING.
IMPLICIT BIAS THE ATTITUDES OR
INTERNALIZE STEREO TYPES THAT
SUB CONSCIOUSLY AFFECT OUR
PERCEPTION PERCEPTIONS ACTIONS
AND DECISIONS.
EXISTING OFTEN CONTRIBUTE TO
UNEQUAL TREATMENT OF PEOPLE
BASED ON RACE ETHNICITY GENDER
IDENTITY SEXUAL ORIENTATION
DISABILITY AND OTHER
CHARACTERISTICS [inaudible]
RACISM SEXISM ISMS DO NOT EQUAL
BIAS WE ALL HAVE UNINTENDED BY A
SEIZE WITHOUT REALIZING EVEN
WHEN WE WISH TO TREAT PEOPLE
EQUALLY.
INGRAINED A STEREO TYPES CAN
AFFECT OUR PERCEPTION OUR MEMORY
AND OUR BEHAVIOR.
IN HEALTH CARE IMPLICIT BIAS
PARTICULARLY CAN THREATEN THE
LIVES OF PATIENTS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS CONSTANTLY MAKE
RAPID DECISIONS UNDER STRESSFUL
CONDITIONS THAT MAY ALTER THE
LIVES OF THEIR PATIENTS. FOR
EXAMPLE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THE
FOLLOWING.
WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY TO SURVIVE
A HEART ATTACK WHEN TREATED BY A
FEMALE PHYSICIAN.
BLACK PATIENTS OFTEN ARE
PRESCRIBED LESS PAIN MEDICATION
THAN WHITE PATIENTS WHO
EXPRESSED THE SAME COMPLAINTS.
18% OF PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFY AS
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL TRANS OR
QUEER AVOID DOCTORS OFFICES FOR
FEAR OF DISCRIMINATION IN
PROVIDER BIAS.
LATINO MEANING CALIFORNIA ARE
21% LESS LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE
BEST TREATMENT FOR HIGH RISK
LOCALIZED PROSTATE CANCER THAN
WHITE MEN.
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN ARE
TWO HUNDRED AND 43% MORE LIKELY
TO DIE FROM PREGNANCY OR
CHILDBIRTH RELATED CAUSES THAN
WHITE WOMEN.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE MANY
STATISTICS THAT DEMONSTRATE HOW
BIAS WHETHER EXPLICIT OR NOT
AFFECT THE WAY HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TREAT PATIENTS
DIFFERENT FROM THEMSELVES.
WE CANNOT JUST WAIT AND HOPE
THAT THESE NUMBERS CAN IMPROVE
ESPECIALLY WHEN LIVES ARE ON THE
LINE.
LEADERS IN MEDICINE INCLUDING
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS THE MAYO CLINIC
KAISER PERMANENTE AND VANDERBILT
UNIVERSITY MEDICAL CENTER
INCREASINGLY ARE URGING MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO LEARN ABOUT
PERSONAL BIAS AND STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS BIAS THESE.
IN AN EFFORT TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT OFFERS EQUAL
TREATMENT TO EVERYONE.
OUR MEDICAL COMMUNITY RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE AT THE
FOREFRONT TO IMPROVE TREATMENT
AND OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN UNDER SERVED BY THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS.
AB TWO FOUR ONE TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTATIVE
APPROACH TO REDUCE DISPARITIES
IN HEALTH CARE.
I HAVE TWO SPEAKERS HERE TO
TESTIFY DR PEARY ACKERMAN BARGER
ASSISTANT CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT
UC DAVIS IS BETTY IRENE MOORE
SCHOOL OF NURSING AND KIMBERLY
PAPPY ON ATTORNEY AND NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED EXPERT ON MEDICAL
LEGAL AND JUDICIAL DECISION
MAKING.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP TO
THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
Q..
HEALTH DISPARITIES ARE VERY WELL
DOCUMENTED IN THE HEALTH CARE
LITERATURE THEIR PERNICIOUS AN
ON GOING.
SOME FURTHER EXAMPLES ARE THAT
BLACK AND HISPANIC PATIENTS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO RECEIVE ANALGESIA
THAN WHITE PATIENTS WHEN
PRESENTING WITH THE SAME
SYMPTOMS.
AND THIS WAS TRUE FOR BLACK AND
HISPANIC CHILDREN AS WELL.
LGBT PATIENTS ARE UNDER ASSESSED
UNDER RESEARCH AND HEALTH CARE
TOPICS RELATED TO THIS COMMUNITY
ARE OFTEN AVOIDED BY HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS.
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS AND HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS CAN LEAD TO HEALTH
DISPARITIES SUCH AS IN ADEQUATE
TREATMENT OF CONDITIONS LIKE
PAIN.
OBESITY CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
ASTHMA AND MENTAL HEALTH.
NOT ONLY DOES UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
CONTRIBUTE TO UNDER TREATMENT
BUT STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
PROVIDERS WITH MORE IMPLICIT
BIASES.
ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE NEGATIVE
INTERACTIONS WITH PATIENTS.
THIS IMPACTS THE TRUST THAT
PATIENTS HAVE AN HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT PATIENTS WILL SEE CARE
HEALTH CARE.
THE PARADOX WITH UNCONSCIOUS
BIAS IS THAT THE THINGS THAT
DWELL IN OUR UNCONSCIOUS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY IN ALIGNMENT WITH
OUR PERSONAL VALUES.
THIS MEANS IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
A GROUP OF BAD PROVIDERS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HEALTH
DISPARITIES.
RATHER IT IS LIKELY THAT IT IS A
COLLECTIVE ISSUE THAT INCLUDES
CARING WELL INTENTIONED
PROVIDERS WHO AT TIMES.
ARE MAKING HEALTHCARE DECISION
BASED ON BY US RATHER THAN
STANDARDIZE CARE.
THIS MOST LIKELY HAPPENS WHEN
PROVIDERS ARE TIRED ON CERTAIN
OVERBURDENED OR HAVE MULTIPLE
DEMANDS TO THEIR ATTENTION
HOWEVER UNCONSCIOUS BIAS CAN BE
MITIGATED [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING A CHAIR IN HIS TEAM
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME -- MY NAME IS A KIMBERLY
POPPY ON AND I AM A JUDICIAL
PROFESSOR WHO TEACHES ON THE
NARROW SENSE OF DECISION MAKING
TO JUDGES AND PHYSICIANS
PRIMARILY -- WHAT WE FOUND OF
THE ON TO THE CONVERSATION
AROUND SIMPLY DOES IMPLICIT BIAS
EXIST -- IT IS THIS.
ABSOLUTELYEXTRAORDINARY
DISCOVERY THAT THERE ARE NARAL
SCIENTIFIC COR LET'S THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLYIDENTIFY THAT DETERMINE
HOW DECISIONS WILL BE MADE --
AND WHAT IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
IS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC INTERVENTIONS
THEY CAN BE COMMUNICATED THROUGH
TRAINING THAT WILL LOWER ONCE
LEVEL OF IMPLICIT BIAS
SPECIFICALLY.
IT WILL CHANGE THE KNURLED
PHYSIOLOGICAL REACTIONS OF THE
BRAIN SO THAT PEOPLE CAN MAKE
THEIR DECISIONS IN THE FACE OF
BIAS.
AND THAT WILL LOWER SPECIFIC OF
NEURAL PHYSIOLOGIC REACTIONS
THAT WE HAVE PARTICULAR CONCERN
ABOUT WITH POSITIONS -- IF YOU
HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OF IMPLICIT
BIAS FOR INSTANCE TOWARDS
AFRICAN AMERICANS THE PART OF
YOUR BRAIN THAT ACTIVATES WHEN
YOU SEE A SPIDER OR SNAKE WILL
BE MORE LIKELY TO ACT THE WHEN
YOU SEE SOMEONE WHO LOOKS FAR
MORE LIKE SHAQUILLE O'NEAL.
THEN MET DAMON IMAGINE YOURSELF
AS A POSITION WALKING INTO AN
EXAMINATION ROOM AND FEELING AS
IF YOU'VE JUST SEEN A SPIDER OR
SNAKE WHEN YOU INTERACT WITH
YOUR PATIENT.
ALSO IMPORTANT IS THAT THE LEVEL
OF IMPLICIT BIAS CAN PREDICT THE
LEVEL OF PAIN EMPATHY
PHYSIOLOGIC PAIN EMPATHY.
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT YOUR
POSITIONS ABILITY A. R.
INSTABILITY?
APA'S OR IN PEAS ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY AFFECTED FLEA TREAT AND
EMPATHIZE WITH PATIENTS IN THEIR
TIME OF NEED THANK YOU TENS
AGREEMENT -- THAT THAT TRAINING
CAN SPECIFICALLY ALTER THESE
BRAIN REACTIONS EFFECTIVELY AND
THEREFORE INCREASE THE LEVEL OF
EQUITY IN HEALTH CARE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SIMPLY NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
MR TURN MEMBERS BUT TERRACE FROM
THE HAVE THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES IN ORDER SUPPORT.
JIMMY FROM IN DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
BACK AYE KRAMER MATTER ACLU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CRISTINA BUS HAMILTON WITH YOU
W. ASKS ME IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YEAH A GUY GOES WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION TRANSPORT.
MOLLY ROBESON WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
WARNING CARVAJAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
THE AUTHOR IS DONE ON THIS BILL
AND FEEL LIKE IT'S A BALANCED
APPROACH FOR PHYSICIANS WERE
NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
THREE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME --
FIRST OFF -- DOC EGGMAN FOLLOWED
BY MYSTICAL.
AS THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD TODAY AND I KNOW THERE
ARE STILL SOME THINGS THAT ARE
STILL.
BEING WORKED OUT BUT I I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL -- I THINK
THIS IMPORTANT THING AS SOMEBODY
WHO TAUGHT.
I KNOW IT NEVER HURTS TO BE ABLE
TO LOOK AT OURSELVES A LITTLE
BIT MORE TO BE ABLE TO AND NOT
JUST IN OUR PRACTICE BUT I THINK
IN OUR PERSONAL LIVES AND JUST
HOW WE HOW WE INTERACT WITH THE
WORLD.
IN GENERAL TO BE ABLE TO DIG
DEEP AND LOOK AT ALL OUR
IMPLICIT BIAS HE'S IS IMPORTANT
I JUST THINK.
FOR AND HUMANITY AND FOR US TO
KEEP GOING FORWARD SO I'D LIKE
TO MOVE YOUR BILL.
IT'S COURT THE COMMISSION AND
I'M JUST ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
WELL FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD OUT OF YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE CUSTODY WITNESSES RESONATE
FOR ME.
I AM MY OWN LIVED EXPERIENCE --
I RECOGNIZE MAY NOT BE EVERY
MEMBERS EXPERIENCE IN THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE -- BUT MANY OF
US KNOW EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING EDUCATION
TO MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS -- I
THINK IS SO IMPORTANT SO THANK
YOU FOR IN THIS FORM HAVE TO
SECOND THE MOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS IT COMES
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU VERY SEEN AND FROM
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- AS
SUMMIT WHEN I COULD JUST HAVE A
FEW.
QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
SINCE THE THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION AND MOVING
FORWARD ON SORT OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES AND YOUR
COMMITMENT IN TRYING TO
ACCOMMODATE AN ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES -- UNDERSTANDING
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO THE
ESSENCE OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET OUT BUT OFTENTIMES IN THE
BUREAUCRATIC NATURE THAT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT THAT SO MIGHT
YOU BE ABLE TO HELP ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE.
ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO THE
ISSUES AND THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
FOR THE GREAT WORK OF YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF --
IMPLEMENTATION IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT I AM RUNNING AS OF
THEIR THREE BILLS AS A COMPANION --
THEIR COMPANION BILLS TO THIS
THAT TALK ABOUT IMPLICIT BIAS IN
AREAS WHERE ONE'S LIFE AND DEATH
ARE AT STAKE -- AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH ALL PARTIES TO TALK
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION AND AND IN
FACT I THINK THE FACT THAT -- IT
TOO OUT OF THE THREE GROUPS THAT
ARE -- TOUCHED BY THIS BILL HAVE
WORKED WITH US TO ADDRESS AND
WHEN TAKE IMPLEMENTATION
CONCERNS ANY EITHER HAVE NOT HAD
OPPOSITION OR HAVE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION.
THEIR OPPOSITION FROM THIS BILL
SHOWS THAT WE ARE COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT THIS IS NOT A
SUGAR COATED KUN BY YA BILL BUT
SOMETHING THAT IS SUBSTANTIVE --
AND THAT WILL HELP US AS A STATE
A KNOWLEDGE IMPLICIT BIAS IN
AREAS LIKE I SAID WHERE ONE'S
LIFE OR DEATH ARE AT STAKE --
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
ONE THING TO KIND OF TALK ABOUT
POLICY AND THEN IT'S ANOTHER TO
WORK WITH THE TECHNOCRATS TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
AN AM AND LIMITATION IN A
PROCESS THAT IS MEANINGFUL --
BUT IS ALSO A FREQUENT -- AND
BENEFICIAL.
WONDERFUL AT THE VERY MUCH FOR
FOR ADDRESSING THAT AS YOU KNOW
I HAVE SPOKEN THERE WERE SOME OF
THOSE INITIAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
BUT YET.
UNDERSTAND THE KEY ESSENCE OF
THE INTENT AND ADDRESSING THIS
VERY PERVASIVE ISSUE SO I
COMMEND YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HELPING TO ACCOMMODATE AND
ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
IN A DELIBERATE FASHION AND SO
WITH THAT COMMITMENT THAT YOU'VE
MADE HERE TODAY THIS DOES NOW
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
AS WELL THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND COMMITTEE SECTOR
WHICH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
KOREAN.
AB TWO FORTY ONE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HI THOUGH I BRO BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN NOT VOTING.
JILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DOES NOT VOTING [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
AND MY PHONE NUMBER IN GIPSON.
GLORIA.
CURRENT AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN BERMAN I MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA
TING.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NUMBER VENTURA FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER. NINE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX BY SOMEWHERE
BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWO
EIGHTY SIX I FIRST WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR.
AND STAFF FOR OUR NEGOTIATIONS
AND DISCUSSION ABOUT THE BILL WE
AFTER THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
WE ARE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE.
WHICH WILL NARROW THE BILL TO
ONLY SUSPEND THE CULTIVATION TAX
AND LEAVE THE EXCISE TAX AT ITS
CURRENT LEVEL UNTIL UNDER PROP
SIXTY FOUR WE ALSO COMMIT.
TO INCLUDING INTENT LANGUAGE TO
INDICATE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL RESTORE THE CULTIVATION TAX
IF OVERALL REVENUES HAVE NOT
INCREASED WITHIN A YEAR.
OF THE TAX MAN SUSPENDED.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE OUT.
WE ARE -- I WAS THE FIRST TIME A
MEMBER LACKEY WHO HAS COVERED IN
IT WITH ME IN THE PAST THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT -- WE'RE HAPPY
TO SAY AND I'M WORKING WITH HIM
IN MEMBERS COOLEY JONES SAWYER
AS WELL TO HELP CONTINUE.
WHAT WE STARTED A COUPLE YEARS
BACK BY CREATING A REGULATED?
MARKET PLACE FOR CANNABIS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
PROTECTS THE PUBLIC IN CHILDREN
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT ENSURE
SAFE PRODUCTS.
AND COMBATS THE ILLICIT MARKET
AND IT'S IN RESPONSE TO THE LIST
AT MARKET THAT WE NEED TO PASS A
BE.
TWO EIGHTY SIX THIS WILL CREATE
A TWO AND A HALF YOUR WINDOW TO
ACCELERATE AND ENCOURAGE
CONSUMERS TO TRANSITION FROM THE
GRAY MARKET TO THE LAWFULLY
REGULATED MARKET PLACE.
WITH A MARKET THAT IN ITS
NASCENT STAGES WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN.
I IN OUR POWER TO HELP AT THOSE
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE GRAY AND
IT WAS A MARKET PLACES.
TRANSITION TO THE REGULATED
MARKET PLACE AND THIS WILL HELP
BECAUSE OUR TAXES HAVE BECOME A
BARRIER FOR SOME OF THOSE --
BUSINESSES WHO WANT TO EMBRACE
THE REGULATED MARKET BUT HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU WE ALSO THINK IT'S
WHEN CHRIS REVENUES -- AND WE
ARE PUTTING OUR OUR BILL
LANGUAGE WHERE OUR BELIEF IS AN
INDICATING THAT IF IT DOESN'T
INCREASE REVENUES WE WILL --
MOVE AWAY FROM FROM THE STEP
THAT WERE TAKING HERE TO REMOVE
THE CULTIVATION TAX WITHOUT -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I HAVE WITH ME BUT JOHNSON
LEGISLATIVE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
STATE TREASURER FEE ON A MOCK.
AS HAVE MATT ROBERTS CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
AND LINDSAY ROBINSON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO MORE THAN
THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL.
I'LL BE BRIEF.
HELLO TO OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHEN I WAS LIKE JOHNSON HERE
ABOUT FIFTY EACH -- FIONA.
I LIKE TO THINK A SLIMMER BONTA
FOR THE CHIFFONS PORN ISSUE AND
TO THE CHAIR WHERE HAVE YOU TAKE
A MOMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THIS.
AS STATED EARLIER AB -- TWO
EIGHTY SIX TEMPORARILY SUSPEND
THE CULTIVATION TAX ALTOGETHER --
TO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO BY
PASSING AB TWO EIGHTY SIX WE CAN
HELP THE LEGAL CANVAS BUSINESS
WITH THE TRANSITION TO THE
MARKETPLACE.
JUST LIKE WITH ANY SORT OF
INDUSTRY TO ENSURE THEY HAVE A
FAIR CHANCE TO SUCCEED IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS ESTIMATED THAT LEGAL CANNABIS
CAN GENERATE A TO TWENTY BILLION
IN ANNUAL REVENUE AND AB TWENTY
SIX A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO MEET THOSE
ESTIMATES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ARE
STRICTLY US WHEN I VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP RIGHT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS --
WE SUPPORTED THAT VERSION OF
THIS BILL LAST YEAR WE'RE HERE
AGAIN IN SUPPORT -- WE THINK
THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED MORE
PEOPLE TO ENTER THE LEGAL MARKET
AND THIS IS BEEN SORT OF AYE AYE
BURDEN INTO ENTRY AND YOU KNOW
WE WANT. TO ENCOURAGE MORE LEGAL
PLAYERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINDSAY ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN LOW IN
MEMBERS -- CCA REPRESENTS OVER
FIVE HUNDRED BUSINESSES AND OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STREET WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OF AB TWO EIGHTY SIX AND WE
BELIEVE IT'S A SENSUAL FOR
INSURING THE COMPLAIN INDUSTRY
CAN SURVIVE IN THESE FUSED FIRST
FEW YEARS OF REGULATIONS -- THIS
PAST FEBRUARY -- THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION REPORTED TAX
REVENUE COLLECTION OF JUST OVER
THIRTY FOUR MILLION -- AND THEY
HAD ESTIMATED THAT THEY WOULD BE
ON CLOSE TO SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION SO WE'RE SEEING A
SHORTFALL THERE WE BELIEVE ON
THAT THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
REMEDY THAT IT WILL HELP
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO BUY
COMPLIANT ILLEGAL CANNABIS IT
WILL HELP.
BUSINESSES AND THE COMPLIANCE
SIDE -- AND HAD TAXES IS THE
NUMBER ONE REASONS WE HEAR THAT
CONSUMERS ARE NOT BUYING
COMPLAIN CANNABIS -- WE THINK
THE AUTHORS FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO SUPPORTING THE LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAME
INFORMATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
HERE ON BEHALF OF CMG -- KHALIFA
IN SUPPORT OF THIS VERY
EFFECTIVE AND VERY HELPFUL
COMPROMISED THANK YOU.
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF EASE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AIR NOTED ON BEHALF OF THE
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF CANDY
CRAFT AND TEAR TECH CORPORATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AMBER MORRIS ON BEHALF OF NOR
CAL CANNABIS COMPANY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS WORK ON MOST.
SABRINA FANDRICH ON BEHALF OF
BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MAX NICHOLAS ON BEHALF OF FLOW
CON AND SILICON VALLEY CAMPUS
LANCE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ERIN ADDRESSES ON BEHALF OF
VETERANS CANNABIS GROUP ON
STRONG SUPPORT.
JEREMY FREIGHTERS VETERAN
CANDACE GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT REALLY WITH
YOU W. IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
FAMILY BOND WITH THE SCHEDULE
DOT ORG.
I SUPPORT THE AMENDMENTS BUT
VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT WE'RE NOT
ADJUSTING 15%. 15% IS
DETRIMENTAL TO VIA ORGANISED TO
THE INDUSTRY.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT SEE OFTEN
IN THE ROOM.
AND HOPEFULLY SUNDAY WHEN THE
FED GETS INVOLVED.
WE'LL GO DOWN TO SEVEN AND A
HALF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS COME UP.
ANY QUESTIONS COMES FROM COULD
MEMBERS I SEE IF YOU BUT A
BECAUSE YOUR CO AUTHOR SOME
LACKEY IS ALSO JOINED US IN IS
IN LACKEY JEWISH TO REPLACE MAKE
ANY COMMENTS AT ALL.
OF YOUR RESPECT FOR YOUR TIME
AND BE VERY BRIEF.
FIRST OF ALL THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTED THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS MATTER. TO
ARRIVE AT A SOLUTION I CAN TELL
YOU THAT -- THIS IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED RIGHT NOW -- THE INDUSTRY.
IS HAVING A REMARKABLE CHALLENGE
AND WE'RE UNIQUE TO ALL THE
OTHER STATES IN THIS COUNTRY IN
THAT -- ARE A LIST OF MARKET HAS
BECOME VERY WELL REHEARSED VERY
WELL ESTABLISHED OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS.
AND THEY ARE POUNDING.
THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO COME
THROUGH HERE AND COMPLIANCE AND
SO THEY NEED EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE
TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE WITH THIS
VERY VERY.
ROBUST ILLICIT MARKET.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND THIS IS REALLY
DESPERATELY NEEDED SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIRST OFF -- TO QUESTIONS BYE
BYE SURE PRO.
THANK YOU MISTER JUST A
STATEMENT I'VE -- I'VE ALWAYS
SUPPORTED THIS ALWAYS SUPPORT
TAX CUTS WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF
THEM BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
STATEMENT THAT YOU COULD INSERT
ANY CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND A
PROPONENT SEATS RIGHT THERE IN
THE FACING THE SAME ISSUE HIGH
TAXES I REGULATIONS NOT CAN'T
COMPETE.
SO I JUST WANT TO BE MINDFUL AS
THESE BILLS COME THROUGH IN THE
FUTURE THAT.
A LOT OF CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
AND FACING THE SAME ISSUE.
AN ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS GOT --
COMMENTS.
SOMEWHERE DOWN THE MEASURE BOTH
THE THE AUTHORED A CO AUTHOR
ENJOYED TWO OR THREE YEARS OF
WORKING SIDE BY SIDE WITH YOU ON
THIS ISSUE -- BUT IT'S A TOUGH
ONE FOR ME TODAY YOU KNOW I HAVE
BLACK MARKET RUNNING CRAZE I
WANTED I WANT THOSE PEOPLE OUT
OF BUSINESS AND I WANT
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES IN
BUSINESS AND WE'RE BACK WHICH
WE'RE NOT GOING AFTER IN ANY
OTHER BUSINESS.
IN MY BUSINESS WHEN I DON'T
COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
THEY DON'T REDUCE MY TAXES THEY
FIND ME AND THEY COME AFTER ME.
IN THE IN THIS CASE IF THEY'RE
NOT COMBINED WITH A LOT WERE
BASICALLY NOT DOING MUCH ABOUT
THAT AND THAT'S WHAT'S BECAUSE
THIS SITUATION SO.
I'M ONLY OFF YOUR BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
THAT'S WE'RE TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE TO BECOME LEGAL THAT'S
BASICALLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
AND THIS BY BY DOING THIS BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING OUT FOR THOSE
FOLKS OUT THERE AS ARE ALL OVER
MY DISTRICT.
DESTROYED MY ENVIRONMENT
[inaudible]
BLACK MARKETING.
AND IT'S IT DOESN'T WORK AND IT
ANY OTHER BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
I CAN PUT MY BUSINESS ON RIGHT
WHERE YOU'RE AT THE TALK ABOUT
THE REGULATIONS IN THE TAXES
THAT I HAVE THAT I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE.
SO I CAN GIVE YOU TO GET THE
GUYS IN OREGON WHO WERE SELLING
PRODUCTS TO MY CUSTOMERS FOR
LESSER PRICE.
SO JUST I I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO I WANNA BE RESPECTFUL OF
FOR THAT BUT IT'S REAL.
REAL DIFFICULT TO SIT HERE AS A
BUSINESS OWNER CALIFORNIA'S
GETTING HAMMERED EVERY DAY.
AND WE'RE DOWN WE LOSING
SOMETHING ELEVEN THE PERSON THAT
IS CAUSING THE PROBLEM WE'RE NOT
REALLY GOING AFTER THEM SO.
I'M GONNA LAY OFF YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I HOPE WE COME UP WITH
SOME MEAT WAY TO GO AFTER THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BLACK MARKETING
AND SELLING FOR CASH.
AND OUR BUSINESS OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND NOT PAY THE TAXES
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THE
OUTCOMES OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS IN THE THINGS THAT
THEY'RE FACED WITH IS WHERE THAT
TAX IS SUPPOSED TO GO.
THANK YOU MISTER DYFI POINT IT'S
IT'S A IT'S AN EXCELLENT ONE AND
ONE THAT WERE VERY SENSITIVE TO
AND WE ARE WORKING ON THAT ALSO
WE ARE.
SEEKING A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
REVENUES TO HELP WITH
ENFORCEMENT TO HELP CRACK DOWN.
ON THE PLAYERS IN THE ILLICIT
MARKET AND THE GRAY MARKET --
WHO ARE WE AB ALSO AGREED THAT
SHOULD BE -- CONTINUING TO
OPERATE SO WE HAVE A CARROT AND
A STICK IT'S IT'S SORT OF A A TO
TO DO ALL EFFORT -- THERE WE
THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME --
MANY BUSINESSES WITH GOOD
INTENTIONS WHO JUST CAN'T GET
THROUGH THE ECONOMIC BEAR WHO
WANT TO ADOPT AND EMBRACE THE
REGULAR MARKET PLACE BUT NEED
SOME ASSISTANCE TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE IT'S NOT PERMANENT
LOWERING TAXES.
IT'S JUST THAT FOR THE THE
BEGINNING OF A UNIQUE MARKET
WHERE IT WAS ILLEGAL FOR A LONG
TIME AND HAS RECENTLY BECOME
LEGAL AND SO HOW DO WE HELP
PEOPLE ADOPTING CHANGE -- AND
TAKE ON THOSE NEW COST AT THAT
COME WITH A REGULATED MARKET
PLACE BUT WE WE ARE WE ARE NOT
BLIND. TO THE NEED FOR
ENFORCEMENT -- WE HAVE A BUDGET
ASK IN THAT AREA IF YOU WANT TO
JOIN US ON THAT GIVEN HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO YOU IN YOUR
DISTRICT WE LOVE TO HAVE YOU ON
BOARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
AMERICAN HIM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE OF
ONE QUESTION AND A COMMENT.
AND MY QUESTION IS CAL --
COLORADO OREGON AND WASHINGTON I
BELIEVE HAVE LOWER RATES THAN WE
CURRENTLY DO A D. AND I
APOLOGIZE IF I MISSED THIS
BECAUSE I CAME IN HALFWAY
THROUGH THE PRESENTATION BUT
WELL WHAT ARE THEIR TAX RATES ON
A LEGAL CANNABIS RIGHT NOW.
AND MAYBE ONE THE WITNESSES
COULD ANSWER.
THEY ARE LOWER -- IT BUT NOT
SIGNIFICANTLY I THINK COLORADO
IS AROUND -- TWELVE AT THEIR ALL
OVER 10% AND SO ON AT LEAST WITH
THAT THE REDUCTION OF THE
CULTIVATION TAX THAT WOULD ONLY
BE A TEMPORARY.
ON SO THAT WOULD BE A COMPLETE
REDUCTION FROM MY UNDERSTANDING
OKAY BUT THEY ARE THOSE THREE
STATES ARE PRESENTLY HAVE LOWER
RATES THAN WE HAVE.
ABSENT THIS BILL.
IS THAT CORRECT.
OKAY.
YES IT'S DEFINITELY TO RECOGNIZE
THE INFORMATION.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW COMMENT WAS.
WE HAVE A BLACK MARKET PROBLEM
IN THIS INDUSTRY I MEAN THAT'S
ON UNDENIABLE I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS ON THAT --
I DO BELIEVE LOWERING THE TAX
RATE ON A TEMPORARY BASIS -- TO
AND AND STUDYING IT AND I LIKE
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE STUDY
PROVISIONS LET'S LET'S WHICH WE
SHOULD DO THAT MORE IN THIS
BUILDING LET'S DO SOMETHING
TEMPORARILY.
ON A PILOT OUR TESTER TRIAL
BASIS GO DO SOME RESEARCH AND
FIGURE FIGURE OUT WHETHER IT'S
WORKING TO THE BEST OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE AND THAT'S THE
APPROACH THIS BILL TAKES I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S VERY WISE I THINK
TAXATION IS PART OF THE BLACK
MARKET PROBLEM.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ALL OF IT I
THINK THE LICENSING AND
REGULATION.
THE REGULATORY SCHEME IF YOU
WILL -- NEEDS.
TO PERHAPS BE ANALYZED TO SEE
WHETHER WE'RE MAKING THAT
OPTIMALLY EFFICIENT.
AND I KNOW THAT'S OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE
BUT YOU -- TOO NUMBERS ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS SHOWN
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND IT'S A POLITICALLY
DICEY AND CONTROVERSIAL AREAS SO
I I COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE.
AND AS YOU MOVE FORWARD AND
CARRY MORE BILLS TO TRY TO SOLVE
THIS BLACK MARKET PROBLEM.
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF ALSO YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO HAVE REGULATORY
SCHEME.
AT PROP SIXTY FOUR REQUIRES AND
SETS FOR CERTAIN PARAMETERS ON
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A LICENSE
OR SCHEME.
BUT LET'S MAKE IT AS SIMPLE AS
POSSIBLE FOR THE MOM AND POPS
AND FOR THE START UPS -- SO THAT
THEY CAN COME INTO THIS MARKET
PLACE AND THEY'RE NOT IN ADVERT
LEADER -- OR UNINTENTIONALLY
PUSHED INTO INTO BLACK MARKET SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
AND KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM JUST
TO TO YOUR YOUR EARLIER QUESTION
JUST COMPARING WASHINGTON TO
CALIFORNIA WASHINGTON DID HAVE A
25% TAX AT EACH LEVEL OF
COMMERCE CULTIVATION
MANUFACTURING AND RETAIL
RECENTLY.
SIMPLIFIED IT TO A STREET 37%
EXCISE TAX AT THE POINT OF
RETAIL SALE.
IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT WITH ALL
THE TAXES -- CUMULATIVELY LOCAL
TAXES STATE EXCISE TAX
CULTIVATION TAX IT'S ABOUT 45%
SO AGREE THAT SOME -- STUDIES
THAT CAN GUIDE US TOWARDS WHAT
THAT SORT OF SWEET SPOT IS FOR
THE APPROPRIATE.
A TAX RATE THAT GENERATES
REVENUE -- AS PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
PROMISED A PROP SIXTY FOUR BUT
ALLOWS THOSE BUSINESSES WITH
GOOD INTENTIONS WHO WANT TO COME
OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND INTO THE
LIGHT AND EMBRACE THE REGULAR
MARKET PLACE TO BE ABLE TO DO SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING NONE A SIMILAR BONTA DO
WISH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SUMMER
BONTA AND AS MORE LACKEY AS YOU
RECALL FROM LAST YEAR OF BE
PASSED THIS SIMILAR INTEGRATION
OF THIS BILL.
OUT OF COMMITTEE AT THE SAME
TIME I DID SHARE A NUMBER OF%
RESERVATIONS WITH RESPECT TO THE
INTENT OF THE BILL ITSELF AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT.
THE LOWERING THE TAX WOULD HELP
ENSURE THAT WE WE GET MORE INTO
THE REGULATED MARKET PLACE AS
GOOD ACTORS AND STAMP OUT THAT
OF THE BLACK MARKET.
AS OF TWO AS OF MONDAY.
AS THE BILL WAS BEING PRESENTED
I STILL DO NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT REGARD THE DISTINCTION
WAS THAT LAST YEAR WE GIVE THE
COURTESY OF THE SUPPORT -- IN
THAT INTEGRATION AND AS OF
MONDAY THEN I'D ARTICULATED TO
YOU THAT I WAS NOT CONFIDENT
THAT THIS WOULD ACCOMPLISH THE
INTENT OF THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE.
HAVING SAID THAT -- SINCE THEN
AS WE SIT HERE TODAY I GIVE
GRACIOUSLY ACCEPTED A NUMBER OF
KEY PROVISIONS AND AMENDMENTS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE INTENT TO TRY TO
MOVE FORWARD.
PART OF THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
FACE AS A COMMITTEE WAS THAT OF
WHETHER OR NOT THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY YOU'LL THE RESULTS OF
THAT YOU'VE SUGGESTED WHICH WAS
THAT YOU SUGGESTED THAT THIS
BILL WOULD -- COUNTER
INTUITIVELY ACTUALLY PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE BECAUSE WE
WOULD HAVE MORE COMING FROM THE
GRAY AND BLACK MARKET INTO THE
REGULATED MARKET PLACE.
AND OTHER PROVISIONS THAT YOU'VE
AGREED TO AND COMMITTED TO IN
COMMITTEE OUTLINED THAT WE WANT
TO PROVIDE SOME -- TIMELINE TO
BEST ASSESS WHAT NOT THAT IN
FACT IS THE CASE IN ANY CASE IN
FACT IF THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
THAT THIS PROVISION WOULD BE
SUNSET IT ADDITIONALLY THERE'S A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THAT OF THE
CULTIVATION AN EXCISE TAX WE ARE
JUST A DRESSING THAT OF
CULTIVATION.
AND NOT ABOUT OF THE EXCISE --
AND SO THAT IS WHAT -- YOU'VE
COMMITTED -- TO IN THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY A WHICH IS A
DIFFERENCE IS TO ALLOW THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS WILL NOT THIS IS
ACTUALLY WORKING.
AND THAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT THAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE -- THIS DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I
JUST WANT TO REMIND ONLY THE
AUTHOR'S BUT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT UNFORTUNATELY JUST GIVEN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE SEE
PIECEMEAL APPROACHES TO SOLVING
THIS WIDE ISSUE.
WITH THE REGULATED MARKET PLACE
AND I ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
OUR VICE CHAIR -- SUMMERS --
CUNNINGHAM AND DOLLY WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN
A COMPREHENSIVE FASHION THIS
COMMITTEE SOL PROPOSALS TO BAN
DELIVERY OF OF CANNABIS TO THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
SIMILE TODAY WE HAVE ENOUGH A
COMPETING A MEASURE TO FOR
CITIES TO ALLOW DISPENSARIES WE
HAVE A PROVISION HERE WITH
RESPECT TO TAXATION -- SO I
WOULD JUST STATES THAT I THINK
WOULD BE PRUDENT THAT WE
COLLECTIVELY TAKE A LOOK AT A
COMPREHENSIVE CONVERSATION. FOR
EXAMPLE IF WE WOULD HAVE A
SUNSET IN THE BUREAU OF CANVAS
CONTROL TO LOOK AT A
COMPREHENSIVE FASHION OF MANY OF
THESE DIFFERENT ISSUE SO -- WITH
THAT I APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
EFFORTS IN THIS AND I HOPE THAT
WILL TAKE A COMPREHENSIVE LOOK
AT HOW WE CAN SUPPORT ARE
REGULATED MARKET AND ALSO ARE
GOOD ACTORS WHILE ALSO STEPPING
OUT THE BLACK MARKET AS WELL TOO
SO.
I WITH THAT -- THIS DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH THE
COMMITMENTS THAT YOU'VE MADE IN
COMMITTEE AS THIS CONTINUES TO
MOVE FORWARD -- SO WITH THAT
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB TWO EIGHTY SIX MOTIONS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI THE
LIBRO BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
I CAN CHEN AYE CHIU CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY.
DOES NOT VOTING EGGMAN
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
WHERE I AM GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE QUIRK SILVA TING.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK THANK YOU HOLLY THANK YOU
STAFF THANK YOU.
WE NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR ZERO SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO.
ASSEMBLY MAY CENTER THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE WITH A
CHAIR APPRECIATE BREVITY.
AB -- FOUR SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVE TO THE CURRENT STATE
FULL OF FOR OSCAR V.
CERTIFICATION BY ALLOWS SURGEONS
AND PODIATRISTS TO GO THROUGH
INDIVIDUAL FACILITIES COMPLYING
WITH CMS RADIATION STANDARDS
REQUIRED BY THE JOINT COMMISSION --
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I WOULDN'T HAVE SOME.
WITNESSES WILL ALSO BE BRIEF
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH BUT THIS ISN'T SUPPORT
KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION JUST
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW -- WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF YOUR
STAFF -- WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF AMENDMENTS
THAT WE EXPECT TO TAKE IN FUTURE
COMMITTEE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE I AM DOCTOR ADAM
HOW OUR PRESIDENT ELECT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUT OUT YOUR MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE THE CO SPONSORS OF A. B.
FOUR OH SEVEN WHICH WOULD
IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF QUALIFIED
PRACTITIONERS TO PERFORM FOR
OSCAR P. AND IMPROVE PATIENT
SAFETY. FOR HER HISORICAL
PERSPECTIVE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
RESOLUTION THAT CHARGE THE NOW
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
DEVELOP EXAMINATIONS AS
APPROPRIATE TO THE PARTICULAR
PROFESSIONAL DISCIPLINE WHEN YOU
SOME FLORA SKIPPY.
HOWEVER A QUICK REVIEW OF THE
TESTAMENT CHARLES WILL SHOW YOU
THAT NOT TO BE THE CASE.
MORE CONCERNING HOWEVER IS A
PROCESS THAT EVEN TAKES TO TAKE
THE STATE MANDATED CERTIFICATION
EXAM.
THE TEST ITSELF MUST BE
SCHEDULED A THIRD PARTY TO SIT
TESTING FACILITY.
YOU MUST FIRST APPLY WAIT TO
RECEIVE THE STUDY GUIDE
MATERIALS AND PREPARE FOR THE
EXAM AND WAIT UP TO TWO MONTHS
FOR THE RESULTS.
ALL THE WHILE UNABLE TO USE THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE NEED TO
PERFORM THE SURGERIES WE WERE
TRYING TO DO.
THIS PUTS PATIENT SAFETY IN
JEOPARDY.
ASSEMBLY I IS FOR US TO BE FOR
THE FOLLOWING PROCEDURES
FREQUENTLY IN THE OPERATING ROOM.
REDUCING FRACTURED BONES FUSION
OF JOINTS IN CERTAIN AN IMPLANT
INTO THE FOOT OR ANKLE REMOVING
FORM BODIES AND MORE.
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ARE LIKELY REDUCE A FRACTURED
BONE OR REALIGN A JOINT.
IS THE IMPLANT CORRECT IS IT
EVEN THE RIGHT SIZE.
MAKING A STAB INCISION TO REMOVE
A FOREIGN BODY IS ALSO MUCH
EASIER IF YOU KNOW WHERE TO MAKE
THE INCISION IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF
HOW AND WHY FOR OSCAR P. IS
CRUCIAL FOR THE OPERATING ROOM.
COINCIDENTLY AS OF JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FACILITIES
A CREDIT BY THE JOINT COMMISSION
MUST ENSURE THAT ALL SURGEONS
AND ALL PERSONNEL.
PERFORM FLORA SKIPPY UNDERGO
ANNUAL EDUCATION AND TRAINING
THEM FOR OSCAR PIECE RADIATION
SAFETY.
AS A CONDITION OF THE
ACCREDITATION.
THIS TRAINING.
WE'LL BE MORE GERMANE TO THE
RADIATION SAFETY AND APPROPRIATE
TO THE PROVIDER IN THE CLINICAL
SETTING UNLIKE A KERN EXAM WHICH
IS NOT SPECIALLY SPECIFIC.
BUT RATHER ANTIQUATED AND QUITE
FRANKLY REDUNDANT.
AB FOR A SEVEN IMPROVES THIS
PROCESS ALLOWS THE POSITION AND
SURGEON OR DOCTOR PUT ACTOR
MEDICINE TO PROVIDE FOR US COULD
BE SERVICES IN A SETTING THAT IS
COMPLIANT WITH THE CENTER FOR
MEDICARE.
AND MEDICAID SERVICES RELATED TO
RADIATION SAFETY WITHOUT A
PERMIT.
SINCE SURGEONS ARE NOW RECEIVING
THIS ADDITIONAL RADIATION SAFETY
TRAINING ANNUALLY THE BILL ALSO
ALLOWS SURGEONS TO USE THAT
TRAIN IT TO SATISFY.
CURRENT EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
REGARDING FOR OSCAR P. AND
RADIATION SAFETY IN FRONT OF YOU
YOU SHOULD HAVE A FOR US COULD
BE IMAGE OF A RECENT SURGERY I
DID.
ON A SEVENTY SIX YEAR OLD.
FEMALE DIABETIC PATIENT.
THANK YOU KINDLY A RAPPER.
WE HAVE THE SORRY I DIDN'T GET
THAT YEAH NO NO NO NO NO NO
PROBLEM WE HAVE THE PACKAGE
BEFORE STICK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PROVIDING THAT IS THOSE TO US.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEM NO ADDITIONAL ONCE ISN'T
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
WHAT IS IN OPPOSITION AT PLEASE
COME UP?
DIANNE SHIP YOU TO SKI
REPRESENTING ORTHOPEDIC SURGEONS
ORTHOPEDIC SURGEONS ALSO USEFUL
ROSCO P. AND SURGERY IT'S AN
INTERNAL PART.
LIKE A LIVE VIDEO SO THAT YOU
CAN MAKE SURE THE PLACEMENT OF
THE PLATES AND SCREWS ARE
CORRECT WELL WE'RE CO SPONSORS
AND WE URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WELL WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU CAN KINDLY
STATE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND WILL PROVIDE UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BOB BACK
IN ABOUT HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY OF
RADIOLOGISTS ARE POSITIONED
SPECIALIZE IN.
DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING RADIATION
SAFETY.
WE APPRECIATE.
THE SUMMONS EFFORT HERE TO
MODERNIZE THE PROGRAM IN TERMS
THE EFFICIENCY OF OBTAINING A
PERMIT BUT WE BELIEVE IN THE
PERMIT AND THE PROCESS ITSELF --
IT DOES.
EMPHASIZE RADIATION DOSE
FEDERATION SAFETY WAS DEVELOPED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AFTER A
REVIEW BY THE RELIGION HEALTH
BRANCH OF THE TRAIN THAT WAS
GOING ON THE FIELD IT
STANDARDIZES IT.
MAKES THE PERMIT PORTABLE SO THE
POSITIONAL PAINS THAT PERMIT CAN
WORK IN MULTIPLE HOSPITALS -- WE
THINK THE TEST IS A AFFECTED AND
HAS BEEN UPDATED -- SEVERAL
YEARS AGO THE PASS RATE IS 83%
SO CERTAIN CERTAINLY THE TEST IS
NOT AN IMPEDIMENT IN ITSELF TO
OBTAIN A PERMIT.
SO WE'D LIKE TO WORK ON
MODERNIZING HOW YOU OBTAIN A
PERMIT NOT ELIMINATING ALL
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME'S RACHEL CAMPBELL I'M
A RADIOLOGIC TECHNOLOGIST
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGISTS.
I AM THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
THE FOOTBALL COLLEGE RADIOLOGIC
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM AT THE
RADIATION PHYSICS AND EXPOSURE.
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES CD PH
THROUGH THE RADIOLOGICAL
BRANCHES FOR ALL PERSONS USING
RADIATION ON THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA EDUCATED AND
QUALIFIED.
OUR REGULATIONS CURRENTLY DO
JUST THAT THEY REQUIRE EVIDENCE
RADIATION KNOWLEDGE TO TESTING
CMS AND JOINT COMMISSION DO NOT
REQUIRE INITIAL EDUCATION OR
PROOF OF KNOWLEDGE.
THOSE CMS NOW FOCUSING ON HIGH
DO SITUATIONS EDUCATION
KNOWLEDGE CAN HELP US AVOID HIGH
DOSES IN THE FIRST PLACE THERE
BY PROTECT YOUR PATIENTS AS WELL
AS HEALTH CARE WORKERS LIKE
MYSELF.
CMS REQUIRES ONLY THAT A
LICENSEE WHO BILLS PERFORM THE
PROCEDURE NATIONALLY FEW NON
RADIOLOGIST PHYSICIANS HAVE
CURRICULUM IN THEIR COURSE WORK
TO THE PASS RATE FOR LICENSE
IT'S AS LOW PROVING THE POINT
THAT MORE EDUCATION IS NEEDED
NOT LESS.
THE FACT IS THAT AN OPERATOR WHO
DOES NOT KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING
WILL INCREASE THE PATIENT GOES
BEYOND WHAT IS REASONABLE EVEN
WITH LOTUS EQUIPMENT. FOR OSCAR
B. AS A DOUBLE EDGED SWORD THE
TOOL THAT CAN HELP DO AMAZING
THINGS BUT IN THE HANDS OF AN
EDUCATED CAN DO GREAT HARM SUCH
AS RADIATION BURNS SEEN IN OTHER
STATES.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA DESERVE
TO BE PROTECTED BY MAINTAINING
THE STRICTEST RADIATION
PROTECTION LAWS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THIS BILL WOULD UNDO ALL OF THE
GOOD THAT IS DONE BEEN DONE IN
CALIFORNIA BY REMOVING THE
SAFEGUARDS EDUCATION PROVIDES.
THE DOCTORS IN CHARGING -- ARE
MUCH LIKE THE PILOT FLYING THE
PLANE THEIR KNOWLEDGE IS
ESSENTIAL REGARDING THE SAFE
UTILIZATION OF THE EQUIPMENT AND
PROVIDING KNOWLEDGEABLE
DIRECTION TO HEALTHCARE TEAM.
IT WAS YOU OR A LOVED ONE IS A
PATIENT ON THE TABLE WE WANT THE
MOST EDUCATED AND MOST QUALIFIED
PHYSICIANS OPERATING THE
EQUIPMENT.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON A
BEFORE SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD YOU MEMBERS.
SIGNAL QUESTIONS COMES FROM CAN
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO JEWISH TO CLOSE.
BUT MR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MASAKO THIS DOES ENJOYS SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES THAT RESPECT.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OF VICE CHAIR BROKE.
MOOSE AT SORT OF SECOND BY
MISTER OBERNOLTE CHRIS ACTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOR US SEVEN MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI SO
I BROKE.
BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DON'T AYE EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA WHERE I GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE REALTY
AYE QUIRK SILVA TING.
THE BILL HAS A BOTH WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHEN I MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL?
SEVEN EIGHTY BY VICE CHAIR BRO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK ON THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
I'LL BE SENDING THESE AMENDMENTS.
LISTEN THE HOUSES.
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS THE
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ON A POSSIBLE
AGREEMENT ON THIS BILL IN THE
CONTEXT OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HELP INSURE THIS BILL AS
SUCCESSFUL.
AS WE MEET MOVE FORWARD AS
AMENDED AB SEVEN EIGHTY WILL
PROVE THE ACCESS OF CARE FOR
HEARING IMPAIRED CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS AND TO ENHANCE THE
KNOWLEDGE AND COMPETENCY.
OF THE PROFESSIONAL HEARING
INSTRUMENT PRAC PRACTITIONERS IN
CALIFORNIA AB SEVENTY EIGHTY SIX
TO PROMOTE SCREENING TOOLS WHICH
WILL BE SOLELY AIMED AT ENSURING
A HIGH LEVEL OF CUSTOMER CARE
PROTECTION.
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION WILL
GROW TO MORE THAN FOUR MILLION --
BY THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY AND
WILL BE ETHICALLY MORE DIVERSE
AND FACE MORE CHALLENGING CARE
NEEDS THE INDUSTRY INFORMED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AS PART
OF AB SEVEN EIGHTY WILL PROVIDE
INCREASE SUPER SUPER BIZARRE
STANDARDS AND EDUCATIONAL
CONTENT. TO BETTER TRAIN NEW
HEARING AID DISPENSERS TO MEET
THESE GROWING NEEDS.
THE PRESIDENT HEARING HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS A CALIFORNIA
MISTER JOE BARTLETT IS HERE WITH
ME TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THESE
TOOLS OF THE USEFUL.
WITHIN A HEARING AIDS THE
SPENCER CURRENT SPOKE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECT THAT SHADOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH UP TO THREE
MINUTES.
OF I TELL YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS PRICE DOUGHERTY KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
HEARING HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO READ
IT REITERATE WHAT.
MISTER BREAUX SAID IN THANKS TO
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
COMMENCEMENT OF WORKED ON THIS
BILL AND WITH THAT I'D RESERVE
THE REST THE TIME FOR MISTER JOE
BARTLETT PRESENTLY ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS JOE
BARTLETT AND I'M THE PRESIDENT
AND OF HEARING HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M A THIRD GENERATION LICENSED
HEARING A DISPENSER AND I ACTIVE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- OUT OF
CHICO CALIFORNIA OTHER
PRACTICING FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS
OF MY LICENSE.
IN ADDITION A TRAINING ON MY
FATHER USING THE INTERNATIONAL
HEARING SOCIETY DISTANCE
LEARNING PROGRAM AVAILABLE
SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO.
AT THE TIME AND PASSING THE
STATE EXAM TO BECOME A LICENSE
HEARING A DISPENSER I'VE ALSO
EARNED MY NATIONAL BOARD
CERTIFICATION FROM THE NATIONAL
BOARD FOR CERTIFICATION HEARING
INSTRUMENT SCIENCES.
AND THE TITLE OF CERTIFIED AUDIO
PROSELYTIZE FROM THE AMERICAN
CONFERENCE OF AUDIO
PROCELLARIIDAE A WHICH IS A
PROGRAM DEVELOPED IN RESPONSE
THE NEED FOR ADVANCED TRAINING
IN HEARING AID -- SPECIALISTS.
AC IS A BACCALAUREATE LEVEL
COURSE PACIFIC WE DESIGNED FOR
HEARING INSTRUMENTS DISPENSERS
WITH TWO OR MORE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE.
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS I'VE ALSO
COMPLETED HUNDREDS OF ADDITIONAL
CONTINUING EDUCATION HOURS BY
TRAIN NUMEROUS HEARING AID
DISPENSERS. THIRTY DISPENSERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE HAMPERED BY THE
RESTRICTION OF PERFORMING SERMON
MANAGEMENT TO PUT ON THE TREE.
SERVER MANAGEMENT IS THE REMOVAL
OF WAX FROM THE EAR.
WHEN MAKING HEARING AIDS WE
OFTEN NEED TO MAKE SILICON CAST
OF OUR CLIENTS HERE'S EVEN THE
SLIGHTEST WAX CAN COLOR CAST TO
BE MISSHAPEN?
CURRENTLY MUST REFER CLIENT OUT
TO THEIR DOCTOR PHYSICIAN IN
ORDER TO REMOVE EXCESS EAR WAX.
MANY COME BACK WITH THE SAME
AMOUNT THAT WE SENT THEM AWAY
WITH.
WE FEEL THAT BECAUSE OUR LICENSE
IN TRAINING REQUIRES THAT WE
SPEND THE BULK OF OUR TIME IN
THE EAR CANAL WE CAN DEMONSTRATE
CORE COMPETENCIES TO BE TRAINED
TO PERFORM SORT OF A MANAGEMENT.
TO PUT ON THE TREE IS AN
OBJECTIVE REFLEXIVE SHOULD A
SCREENING TEST OF THE MIDDLE
YEAR THAT IS NON INVASIVE AND IS
NOT IS OFTEN PART OF BATTERY OF
HEARING TESTS TO ASSESS THREE
LOSS IN THE NEED FOR HEARING AID.
WHEN OTHER HEARING TESTS FAILED
TO YIELD CONSECUTIVAS CONCLUSIVE
RESULTS TO PUT ON A TREE CAN USE
A SERVICE A TIE BREAKER?
UNDER THIS BILL TO BUT I'M SHE
WOULD ONLY BE USED AS A
SCREENING TOOL FOR PURPOSES OF
REFERRING PATIENTS TO SPECIFIC
YOUR NOSE AND THROAT PHYSICIANS
AND SURGEONS.
AND IN FACT HELP DETERMINE IF A
CLIENT SHOULD NOT RECEIVE A
HEARING AID BECAUSE ADDITIONAL
MEDICAL ATTENTION COULD HELP
THEIR HEARING LOSS.
WE ALSO SEEK TO CODIFY FEDERALLY
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP PATHWAY
TO BOLSTER OUR EDUCATION
STANDARDS PEOPLE WHO INTER
PROFESSION MUST MOSTLY UNDERGO
SOME SORT OF ON THE JOB TRAINING.
THIS PROVIDE A CLEAR STANDARD
FOR WHAT IS INCLUDED IN THAT
TRAINING WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB SEVENTY
EIGHTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEING NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THIS FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE TABLE HERE AND UP.
TO THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GIVE ME GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DOCTOR ANY
WHITE I'M AN AUDIOLOGIST
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF AUDIOLOGY.
WE'RE HERE TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL TODAY AS WRITTEN.
ON CA -- HAS HEARD THAT THIS
BILL WAS COMING IN FEBRUARY --
THROUGH THE AUTHORS OFFICE HAD
REACHED OUT ON AN INVITATION TO
TO THAT BILL AUTHORS AND THE
SUPPORTERS TO HAVE A STAKEHOLDER
MEETING TO DISCUSS OUR CONCERNS.
ABOUT HAS NOT COME TO FRUITION
WE HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF THAT
PROCESS.
THERE ARE KEY COMPONENTS HERE
THAT JUST DON'T MAKE SENSE TO
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY TEMP AN
ALMOND TREE IS NOT A SCREENING
TOOL.
IT IS A DIAGNOSTIC EXAM IT'S A
TEST THAT IS MEETING LAST
WITHOUT BEING IN COMBINATION
WITH OTHER TESTS BATTERIES THAT
WE PERFORM.
AND IS NOT PURPOSEFUL IN TERMS
OF SCREENING HEARING AID
DISPENSERS ARE HEARING A DEALERS
AS MOST STATES WOULD CALL THEM
ARE.
NON EDUCATED PROVIDERS OF CARE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO HAVE ANY
FORMAL EDUCATION THERE ARE QUITE
A GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL THEY ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO HAVE ANY FORMAL
CLOCK HOURS ARE TRAINING.
THEIR REQUIRED TO GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL AND PASSED THE STATE EXAM.
WITH THIS THEY HEARING AID
DISPENSERS ACCOUNT FOR OVER 80%
OF ALL CONSUMER COMPLAINTS WITH
REGARDS TO HEARING AIDS THEY
MAKE UP ONLY 40% OF ALL LICENSE
TYPES THAT ARE ALLOWED TO FIT
HEARING AIDS.
THEY ARE AT RISK YOU ARE PUTTING
THE CONSUMERS AT RISK
PARTICULARLY THE ELDERLY
POPULATION WHO PRIMARILY COME TO
GET HEARING AIDS.
BY OPENING UP DIAGNOSTIC TESTING
TO PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE THE
EDUCATION TO DO SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO OPPOSE.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RODNEY
DHEAS I AM A PROFESSOR OF
OTOLARYNGOLOGY HEAD NECK SURGERY
AT UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER HAPPENED A
PROFESSOR THERE FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS -- I AM ALSO PUBLIC MEMBER --
AND OR LEARN COLLEGES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY AUDIO
AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING AID
DISPENSERS BOARD HAVE SERVED FOR
THE BOARD FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS --
I'M COMING TO YOU -- AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE BOARD
TODAY BUT ALSO AS A CONCERNED
CITIZEN AS A CONCERNED OR LEARN
COLLEGES HEAD NECK SURGEON -- MY
CONCERNS -- REGARDING -- AB --
SEVEN EIGHTY SOME WITH THE THREE
BASIC POINTS THE FIRST POINT IS
THAT THE TYMPANUM A TREE -- IS A
DIAGNOSTIC TESTS DOES NOT SERVE
ANY PURPOSE FOR FITTING IN
SELLING OF HEARING AIDS AND THE
SUCH AS SERVES NO PURPOSE FOR A
HEARING AID DISPENSERS TO BE
USED IN THE FINANCE -- SELLING
OF HEARING AIDS -- IN ADDITION --
THROUGHOUT RESTAURANT MANAGEMENT --
IS NOT NECESSARY -- IN THE
FITTING AND SELLING OF HEARING
AIDS A MINIMAL AMOUNT OF SARUMAN --
WHICH IS ENCOUNTERED BY HEARING
AID DISPENSERS DOES NOT NEED TO
BE REMOVED IN THE FINANCING OF
HEARING AIDS A LARGE AMOUNT OF
CEMENT WHICH IS -- WHICH WOULD --
BE A SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH TO CAUSE
OBSTRUCTION OF THAT YOUR CANAL
INABILITY TO COMPLETELY
VISUALIZE TYMPANIC MEMBRANE OR
INABILITY TO COMPETE FITTING OF
THE HEARING AID -- WOULD BE -- A
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH -- TO REQUIRE
REFERRAL TO A PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN OR REFERRAL TO A
SPECIALIST OR LEARN COLLEGES --
FOR SPECIALTY REMOVAL AND SHOULD
NOT BE -- MANAGED BY -- IN -- ON
EDGED AREA.
EXCUSE ME AND A A HEARING AID --
DISPENSER -- THE A THIRD ISSUE --
IS -- THE A BILL LANGUAGE --
WHICH PRESCRIBES THE HEARING A
DISPENSER APPRENTICE LICENSE
PATHWAY WHICH DUPLICATES --
LICENSE -- CURRENTLY -- IN PLACE --
THROUGH THE BOARD FOR HEARING
AID -- HI EIGHT HEARING A
DISPENSER -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RAINY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE THREE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
HI YES I MONEY NOVA CAM THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF AUDIOLOGY
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEING NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM CREE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME AS A MEMBER BROKE YOU WISH
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AS I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION IRON
OUT ALL THE WRINKLES IN THIS
LEGISLATION AND I YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT. TO DO THAT MOVING
FORWARD I RESPECT LAST
THROUGHOUT THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FRESHER BROKE IT AGAIN IF.
AS WE HEARD IN TESTIMONY EARLIER
TODAY IF YOU MIGHT BE A
CONTINUALLY RE FROM THE
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION IN TRYING TO WORK OUT
SOME OF THESE ISSUES I SHOULD
THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD -- SO
WITH THAT WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AT THIS BEEN IN MOTION AND
SECOND COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY MOTIONS YOU PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HI THOUGH I BRO.
BRO I BLOOM.
CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DALY NOW EGGMAN.
FONG.
OKAY GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE ABILITY AYE QUIRK
SILVA TING?
THAT BILL HAS SEVEN BOTH BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
A SIMILAR FRAZIER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN EIGHTEEN AND OF COURSE YOUR
BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE SIMILAR FRAZIER.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M GONNA KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND HAVE MY WITNESS I
TESTIFY IN A VERY SHORT MANNER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
IMMIGRATION.
THIS RETURN MEMBERS MIKE
BILLOWED ON BEHALF THE APPRAISAL
INSTITUTE THE LINE BETWEEN
APPRAISAL AND HOME INSPECTION
CAN BE A LITTLE TRICKY LITTLE
GRAY -- WE SUPPORT -- MISTER
FRASIER'S ATTEMPT TO BRING
CLARITY TO THIS APPRAISERS ARE
NOT INTERESTED IN BEING HOME
INSPECTORS THEY DON'T WANT THE
LIABILITY THEY'RE NOT.
THAT'S NOT THEIR JOB -- SO WE
APPRECIATED AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEE NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND ALSO --
SECOND BY SOMEONE OR ONE THREE
SIX EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN EIGHTEEN MOTIONS YOU
BUSTER PREPARATIONS LOW HI WELL
I PRO FOR AYE BLOOM.
CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN.
FONG PHONE NINE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA.
LLIN AYE OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
CRYSTAL I TING.
THE BILL HAS NINE THOSE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH MISTER FRAZIER.
NOW YOU ON TO THE NEXT ITEMS TO
BE HEARD.
WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR WHEN.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB EIGHT TWO
TWO WOULD ALLOW HEALTH
FACILITIES AND HOSPITALS THAT
AUTHORIZED THE TO AUTHORIZE THE
USE OF NEW BLOOD COLLECTION
METHODS AND DEVICES.
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT REQUIRES FULL BOTTOM IS TO
USE NEEDLES TO DRAW BLOOD EVEN
THOUGH NEW NEED ON THIS.
NEED A LESS BLOOD COLLECTION
METHODS EXIST CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS DESERVE GREATER ACCESS
TO NEW MEDICAL PRACTICES THAT
ARE SAFE AND COMFORTABLE.
I'M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THAT A FULL
BOTTOM IS CANNOT INSERT OR
REMOVE AN IV AND CANNOT STOP OR
START AN INFUSION.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
DOCTOR P..
TO THE DEAD GONE OF A LOT OF
VASCULAR AND DOCTOR FRED BROWN
OF GROWTH AND HEALTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DOCTOR P.
TO DUB DONE ON THE CO FOUNDER
AND CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF A
LOT OF VASCULAR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BASED MEDICAL DEVICE
COMPANY.
I'M ALSO THE INVENTOR OF ARE FDA
CLEARED NEEDLE FREE BLOOD DRAW
TECHNOLOGY CALLED PPO.
THE SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE DEVICE
THE TEMPORARILY CONNECTS TO A
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS PREFER Là
AB CATHETER LIKE THE ONE I HAVE
DEMO TO MY HAND.
NOW TO ENABLE A VIRTUALLY
PAINLESS A RELIABLE BLOOD DRAW.
HOSTELS AROUND THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA --
ADOPTING IV CATHETER BLOOD
COLLECTION WITH PEOPLE TO
IMPROVE THEIR PATIENTS
EXPERIENCE AND ELIMINATE PAINFUL
NEEDLE STICKS. TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF ACCIDENTAL EXPOSURE TO
THE PROVIDERS AND STAFF AND TO
IMPROVE THEIR IMPROVE THEIR
LABORATORY EFFICIENCY.
THERE'S ROBUST CLINICAL EVIDENCE
SUPPORTING BLOOD DRAWS WITH IV
CATHETER ARE FROM I. B.
CATHETERS WITH PEOPLE.
WHICH I WON'T GO INTO ALL TODAY.
IN ADDITION THE CLINICAL
EVIDENCE DOES BEEN IS ABOUT TO
CROSS ROUGHLY ABOUT A MILLION
PROCEDURES PERFORMED TO DATE.
THE MAJORITY OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED BY TRAIN PHLEBOTOMY US
IN OTHER STATES.
THERE BEEN ZERO ADVERSE EVENTS
OVER ALL OF THOSE DROSS.
AS A REAL WORLD EXAMPLE I LIKE
TO SHARE -- WERE CONDUCTED BY
INTERMOUNTAIN HEALTHCARE -- WHO
MEASURE PEOPLE'S IMPACT ON THEIR
CARE THE LARGEST HEALTH SYSTEM
IN UTAH NEARBY?
LIKE MOST LARGE HEALTH SYSTEM
THEY RELY ON THE FULL BOTTOM IS
TO COLLECT THE MAJORITY OF THEIR
IMPATIENCE SAMPLES.
THE ADOPTED PEOPLE SYSTEM WIDE
ROUGHLY ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO.
THEY TRACKED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE DRAWS ON
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS CREATING
THE LARGEST VASCULAR DATA SET AS
FAR AS WE KNOW IN THE COUNTRY.
THE FINDINGS FROM THIS DATA SAID
INCLUDE NO CHANGE AN IV CATHETER
REPLACEMENT RATES.
OF FROM THE FULL BOTTOM STE
USING PICO A 40% REDUCTION IN
REJECTED SAMPLES.
WHEN THEY'RE COLLECTED WITH PECO
AND THEY REMOVE ROUGHLY ABOUT A
QUARTER OF A MILLION IN PATIENT
NEEDLES FROM THE HOSPITAL
ENVIRONMENT?
PATIENT SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT IN
THIS NEW PROCEDURE STILL HAS
NURSING CONTROL THE PATIENTS IV
THERAPY.
EVEN FUSION IS RUNNING THROUGH
AN IV CAPITAL IN THE BLOOD IS
DRAWN.
BUT THE WHEN A BLOOD DRAWS
REQUIRED THE PATIENT'S NURSE AND
ONLY THE NURSES CAN DECIDED
BRIEFLY PAUSING THAT INFUSION IS
APPROPRIATE.
AND IF SO THE NURSE WILL FLUSH
THE IV LINE BEFORE THE
PHLEBOTOMY STRAWS THE BLOOD
SAMPLE WITH PEOPLE.
THIS COORDINATION BETWEEN
NURSING AND PHLEBOTOMY IS NOT
ACTUALLY NEW AND ACTUALLY IS
PRETTY STANDARD TODAY AROUND THE
HOSPITAL EVEN WITH BEING A
PUNCTURE.
THE BOTTOM IS TO BE CLEAR WILL
NEVER START STOP OR PAUSE ANY
RUNNING IV INFUSION.
LAST LEAVE OFF THE BOTTOM OF THE
NURSES COMPLETE IN PERSON
TRAINING AND DEMONSTRATE
COMPETENCY TO PERFORM THE
PROCEDURE SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY.
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY THE MAJORITY
BLOOD DRAWS ARE CONDUCTED BY
FULL BOTTOM THIS AND HOSPITALS.
AND THIS BILL ENABLE THEM TO
UTILIZE SAFER TECHNOLOGIES AND
PROCEDURES MOVING FORWARD I URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIRTY SECONDS
LEFT.
HI I'M DOCTOR FRED BROWN I'M
CURRENTLY THE CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER VICE PRESIDENT MEDICAL
AFFAIRS AND A PRACTICING
INFECTIOUS DISEASE PHYSICIAN AT
GRIFFIN HOSPITAL -- I'M HERE TO
TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE --
WE ACTUALLY ARE THE FIRST AND
LONGEST RUNNING HOSPITAL THAT'S
USE PEOPLE AS WELL AS ONE OF THE
HOSPITALS THAT ACTUALLY USED AND
TALK TO OUR NURSES BEFORE WE
EVEN IMPLEMENTED IT.
IT STARTED OFF WITH OUR NURSES
IN OUR I SEE YOU AND THEN
THROUGHOUT THAT THE TIME FRAME
WE'RE ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THEIR
SUPPORT. TO TRANSITION TO HAVE
FULL BY MISS AND TECHNICIANS
CONTROL THE USE OF DRUG BLOOD
DRAWS -- SO AGAIN I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT AND AND AS A SUCCESSFUL
USER OF ABOUT.
THANK YOU I URGE YOU TO VOTE HI
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US HERE TODAY IN OUR STATE
CAPITOL ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WIN ASSISTANCE
PART I LIKE TO CALL UP WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION WHEN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP HERE TO THE TABLE.
AND UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RANT MARTIN
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION.
I'D LIKE TO STIPULATED AT FIRST
WE THINK THIS IS A GREAT DEVICE
I'M AND IT'S BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE
AND THE DEBTORS OF I HAVE GIVEN
YOU A GOOD OVERVIEW OF HOW
EFFECTIVE IT'S MAN.
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT THE
DEVICE THIS IS ABOUT WHO IS
GOING TO BE USING THE DEVICE ON
THE PATIENT -- OUR CONCERN
DEALING WITH THE POPULATION WHEN
THEY'RE ACUITY OF THEIR DISEASE
CAN BE ON THAT THE CHANGE IN IN
DELIVERY OF CARE CAN BE.
HARMFUL TO THEM -- WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHO'S ACTUALLY
USING THE DEVICE AT THE TIME THE
PATIENTS BEING CARED FOR THERE
ARE CONCERNS ABOUT HAVING A FULL
BOTTOM MUST HAVE TO DEAL WITH --
RUPTURES AN ARTERY RUPTURES IN
THE CATHETER ITSELF -- AIR IN
THE CATHARINE SELF IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A NURSE STANDING RIGHT
THERE ARE DOING IT THEN YOU RUN
THE RISK OF THAT PATIENT HAVING
A AN ACUTE EPISODE -- AND NOBODY
THERE IN THE MOMENTS AFTER TO
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WITH HIV
THIS IS A BIG ISSUE FOR OUR
FOLKS WHO ARE ARE IN HOSPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TERROR
MEMBER OF THE OF THE COMMITTEE.
OF THIS COURSE PLAYING G. WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENT OVER
WONDER THOUSAND REGISTERED
NURSES WHO ARE OPPOSED TO AB.
EIGHT TWENTY TO ASK MR RAN JUST
STATED I MUST STATE THAT AS A
PATIENT ADVOCATE CNA IS NOT.
OPPOSED TO THIS ADVANCEMENT IN
TECHNOLOGY WHICH MINIMIZES
PATIENT NEEDLE STICKS HOWEVER WE
DO OPPOSE THE USE OF UNLICENSED
IN AND KLAY TRAINED THE BOTTOM
IS TO ACCESS.
INDWELLING IVY'S FOR THE PURPOSE
OF WITHDRAWING BLOOD FROM
PATIENTS RECEIVING INFUSION
THERAPY.
THIS PROCEDURE IS BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF A THE BOTTOM ES EMPEZAR
POSES A THREAT TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS.
KERN EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS TO
BOB PREPARE FOR BOTTOM IS FOR
THE CARE AND MANAGEMENT OF
PERIPHERALLY INSERTED
INTRAVENOUS CATHETERS.
AS THE PROPONENTS -- MENTIONED
THE STARTING STOPPING FLUSHING
EVALUATING AND RESTORING A BY
VIS IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
DIRECT CARE REGISTERED NURSE SO
WHY DO WE NEED THIS LEGISLATION.
NURSES ALREADY USING THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO MINIMIZE PATIENT
NEEDLE STICKS.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO HAVE A
REGISTERED NURSE START AND I'D
BE LYING TO EVALUATE THE IV
LINES STOP AND PLUS THE WIND IN
HALF A MILE UP THE BOTTOM IS.
ATTACHED TO CAP THEIR TO THE
LINE DRAW THE BLOOD THEN HAVE
THE REGISTERED NURSE FLUSTERED
WE START THE LINE IF NEEDED.
THIS IS A DISRUPTION A WORK FLOW.
WHICH PULLS THE NURSE AWAY FROM
OTHER PATIENTS THAT NEED NURSING
CARE WHEN THE NURSE CAN JUST USE
INTO THE NEW DEVICE HER OR
HIMSELF.
THIS IS A SINGLE SOURCE BILL
SPONSORED BY COMPANY THAT WANTS
TO PUT THESE DEVICES IN THE
HANDS OF MORE HOSPITAL PERSONNEL.
FOR INCREASED SALES AND PROFIT
THESE DEVICES SHOULD BE USED BY
LICENSE AN ATTIC LEE ADEQUATELY
EDUCATED PROFESSIONALS PATIENT
SAFETY IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
INCREASE PROFITS. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NOBLE ON AB.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN YOUR FILIATION AGAIN.
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MAP ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
AND THE ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS
IN OPPOSITION WE REPRESENT
NURSES AND SHARE.
MISTER MISTER LINKS CONCERNS
THANK YOU.
TELL MY HAIR IS CHEAPER
LEGISLATION FOR CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING WE
REPRESENT OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND REGISTERED NURSES
AND WE DO A PULSE.
THE MESSAGE OUR MEMBERS MITCH
DYER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEE NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND SECOND COMMITTEES
AGREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
I WILL AYE BRO.
BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
JOHN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY AYE EGGMAN I MEAN I FONG.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN [inaudible]
HI MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE NOW MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES THAT HELL WELCOME
MOVE THE BAND TASTIC -- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HE BEAT FIFTY
WILL PROVIDE TO TECHNICAL FIXES
IN THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE FOR CANNABIS CULTIVATION
AND LABELING WITH ME IS LOUIS
BROWN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
THE COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON
BEHALF THE INTERNATIONAL
CANNABIS FARMERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE
THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ANY FRANK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IT
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEEING THAT THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT MOTIONS
YOU **** PREPARATIONS LOW HIGH
LOW I BROKE.
MY BLOOM GEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA TING QUIRK SILVA AYE.
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS A TEN VOTES BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE LIVING.
THEN MOVING ON TO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS AND AUTHORS WHO ARE
PRESENT AND THEREFORE WE WILL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY TWO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FIRST
THOUGHT I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE YOURSELF. FOR REALLY
WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS AND OF COURSE WE'RE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND JUST TO SUMMARIZE THE
AMENDMENTS FOR THE COMMITTEE
THEY EMPHASIZE THAT MEDICAL
LICENSING WITHOUT ACTUALLY --
TAKING AWAY THE RATIO AND THE
EXAM LOCALITIES THAT HAD A POST
PROP SIXTY FOUR A BALLOT MEASURE
THAT EITHER.
ONE REJECTED A RETAIL LICENSEE
ORDINANCE OR TO APPROVED AN
ORANGE PROHIBITING RETAIL
LICENSING -- AGAIN -- WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
THAT THE VOTERS WHO VOTED FOR
PROP SIXTY FOUR HAVE ACCESS TO
CANNABIS ESPECIALLY THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT APPROVED IT?
IF YOU LIVE IN A JURISDICTION
THAT DID NOT APPROVE IT THIS
WILL NOT IMPACT YOU AT ALL.
RASKIN THE JURISDICTIONS THAT
DID APPROVE IT TO ISSUE -- UP
225% OF THE LIQUOR LICENSES.
PERMITS FOR CANNABIS SO THAT
THEY SHOULD NEVER PERMITS THOUGH
EQUAL UP 225% THE LIQUOR
LICENSES WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
SENSIBLE SOLUTION TO ENSURE THAT
THE VOTERS.
THE VOTERS WILL GETS IMPLEMENTED
ON PROP SIXTY FOUR AN ON CAMPUS
WITH THAT HAVE A FEW --
WITNESSES TESTIFY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL ALLOW UP TO THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS ERIN AUGUSTA SOME
THE FOUNDER OF THE VETERANS
CANNABIS GROUP.
NOW WE SEE GROUP MADE UP OF
VETERANS USE MEDICAL CANNABIS WE
ARE CO SPONSORING THIS BILL.
AFTER RETURNING HOME FROM IRAQ
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE I
UNDERSTOOD ME TO THE TRANSITION
FROM MILITARY LIFE TO CIVILIAN
LIFE IN CANNABIS HELPED CALM ME
DOWN AND BRING MY MIND INTO THE
PRESENT.
CANNABIS IS CRITICAL FOR
VETERANS BATTLING PTSD AND
CHRONIC PHYSICAL PAIN AS PART OF
A HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT WE
ADVOCATE FOR AND IT'S CRITICAL
FOR HELPING US TRANSITION OFF OF
OPIATES.
UNFORTUNATELY ALTHOUGH VOTERS
PASSED PROP SIXTY FOUR IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN MORE THAN 76%
OF THE CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE
CANNABIS RETAIL BANDS.
THIS IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO
OBTAIN CANNABIS ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE SOME
VETERANS CANNOT EVEN GET
CANNABIS BECAUSE THE NEAREST
DELIVERY SHOP IS MORE IS TOO FAR
AWAY.
SEASONING FOR DRIVING.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL
EXPAND BETTER ACCESS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHO RELY ON THESE
TREATMENTS.
THE GOVERNMENT RELIED ON THIS
FOR INTELLIGENCE WHEN WE ARE
ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY AND NOW
WE'RE ENCOURAGING YOU AS
LEGISLATORS TO LISTEN TO US NOW.
ON THE FRONT OF THE BATTLE FRONT
FOR PTSD AND FOR OTHER --
MEDICAL ISSUES THAT WERE
FIGHTING.
SO PLEASE I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS FLORENCE
PERSON AND I'M AND I JUST SAYS
PROVIDER FROM MERCED COUNTY.
I PROVIDE HOME CARE FOR TO
CLIENTS THROUGH THE STATE'S IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM.
I CARE FOR MY MOTHER WHO LIVES
WITH SEVERE SEVERE COPD AND
DIABETES AND I ALSO CARE FOR
ANOTHER CLIENT WHO HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
MY UNION UT W. REPRESENTS OVER A
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND I JUST
AS PROVIDERS LIKE MYSELF.
WHO CARE FOR SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE?
MANY OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE FOUND
RELIEF THROUGH THE USE OF LEGAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
WE ARE SPONSORING THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE AND OUR CLIENTS
DESERVE ACCESS TO GET CANNABIS.
IF IT INSURES THE HIGHEST
QUALITY OF CARE.
MANY OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE
CONDITIONS FOR WHICH CANNABIS
HAS A DEMONSTRATED AND EFFECTIVE
MEDICAL APPLICATION.
ENSURING SAFE AND CONVENIENT
ACCESS FOR THEM IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT EVERYONE HAS
EASY ACCESS TO CANNABIS ALMOST
77% OF THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
DO NOT ALLOW FOR EVEN ONE
CANNABIS DISPENSARIES. FOR CARE
GIVER SEEKING THE HIGHEST DEGREE
OF COMFORT AND DIGNITY. FOR
THEIR CLIENTS THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY.
I'M SORRY ONE OF MY FELLOW CAR
GIVERS IN PLASTER COUNTY HAS TO
CLIENTS HER FATHER IS A VET WITH
PTSD AND HER UNCLE LIVES WITH.
SEVERE ANXIETY AND PSYCHOTIC
EPISODES.
THEY BOTH HAVE EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS IN
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE THROUGH
THE USE OF CANNABIS.
THE PLASTIC COUNTY HAS NO
DISPENSARIES.
THIS IS NOT ONLY THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN OF HAVING TO DRIVE FOR
WAY TO OBTAIN CANNABIS.
BUT ALSO THE DANGER OF LEAVING
HER CLIENTS ALONE WHILE SHE IS
GONE WOULD YOU CAN THE WRAP UP
AND REST.
IF YOU COULD KINDLY WRAP UP FOR
US OKAY SO.
NO ONE SHOULD BE BURDENED BY THE
LACK OF ACCESS AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX MEANS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
WHO NEED CANNABIS WILL BE
TREATED EQUALLY REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY LIVE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP THE
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION
SIMPLY IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THANK YOU AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THE
INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS FARMERS
ASSOCIATION.
CANNOT CRAFT AND TEAR TECH COURT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SAM RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF ALL PULLED VALLEY
CANNABIS FORMER SENATOR RICK
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ERIN NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MAX WITH A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF FLOW CON IN THE
SILICON VALLEY CAMPUS ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT.
SABRINA FREDERICK BERKELEY
PATIENTS GROUP IN SUPPORT.
GUN BECAUSE ANGELES ON THE
FATHER AND PARENT.
OR CAREGIVER.
OF MY THIRTY FIVE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER WHO SUFFERS FROM
PARANOID SCHIZOPHRENIA -- AND
IT'S ESTABLISHED.
TO CANNABS WOULD HELP HER AND
RELIEVER OF ALL THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING THAT ALL OF US HAVE
EXPERIENCED.
HELLO I AM A ME DAY UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
JEREMY FREIGHTERS YOUR BETTER IN
CAMPUS GROUPS SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY AND WHAT I KNOW WITH YOU W.
IN SUPPORT.
BALLABAN CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GEORGE MILLER ON BEHALF OF WITH
MAPS AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK.
MY THE MARQUEZ I WORK FOR YOU D.
W. I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS OF
FOR PARKINSON'S PATIENTS THANK
YOU.
GABRIELLE AROMA WITH YOU W. IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THIS VIDEO.
OWN WORK FOR UT W. AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
ANNALYNNE MATHIS WITH UT W.
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DEVELOPER ALICE HOME CARE
PROVIDER STANISLAUS COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
I WAS KESSLER BEHALF OF A
QUALITY CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE TABLE HERE AND
WILL PROVIDE UP TO THREE MINUTES.
FOR TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHARLES
HARVEY ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES --
TESTIFYING TO HERE IN OPPOSITION
THE BILL IN SHORT -- IS IS VERY
TROUBLING -- IT WOULD COMPLETELY
A ROW THE LOCAL CONTROL OF
CITIES AND COUNTIES REGULATE
BRICK AND MORTAR.
RETAIL CAñADA SHOPS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES -- FROM THE LEAST
POINT OF VIEW THIS MEASURE IF
PASSED WOULD SERVE AS YET
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A BROKEN
PROMISE -- TO THOSE WHO PASSED
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR TO THE
BELIEF THAT LOCAL REGULATORY
AUTHORITY WOULD BE PRESERVED --
YOU KNOW MANY ALERT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SPENT SIGNIFICANT
TIME DEVELOPING DETAILED
REGULATORY SCHEMES THAT PERMIT
THE OPERATION OF CERTAIN
COMMERCIAL CANVAS BUSINESSES
WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT INCLUDE
RETAIL OPERATIONS -- AND
MOREOVER SOMEONE NOTED
SKEPTICISM ABOUT THE ARBITRARILY
SELECTED BENCHMARK OF USING THE
NUMBER OF LIQUOR STORES TO
DETERMINE A JURISDICTIONS RETAIL
CANNABIS CONCENTRATION.
SO WITH REGARD TO THE MANDATED --
ONE TO FOUR RATIO AS OUTLINED IN
THE BILL -- THERE'S SIMPLY NO
NEXUS BETWEEN THE CITY'S
PURPORTED ISSUES ON CITIZENS --
MEDICAL CANNABIS ACCESS AND THE
NUMBER OF LIQUOR STORES LOCATED
IN THE COMMUNITY AND SO -- FOR
ALL THESE REASONS WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED ENERGY NO
VOTE.
GOOD MORNING CAMERON SOME WE
HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AS WELL
AS THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO HERE IN OPPOSITION -- QUITE
FRANKLY THIS IS NOT AN ACCESS
BILL ARE REGULATIONS ALLOW FOR
DELIVERY INTO ANY JURISDICTION
CURRENTLY -- AND WE BELIEVE IT
IS A DISTRACTION FROM THE
LICENSING PROCESSES STATE CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH STATE AGENCIES TO
CONTINUALLY REFINE OUR DUAL
LICENSING SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE THIRTY COUNTIES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY ALLOWING
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITY.
HOW WE ARE WORKING HAND IN GLOVE --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A FAIR
AND WELL REGULATED MARKET PLACE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS BILL
FLIES IN THE FACE OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR WE ARE JOURNAL VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT NOW
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
TINO WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
DR ED.
THANK YOU -- WHAT IS THE RATIO
WONDER FOR CALM AND HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED OTHER OPTIONS I GUESS
IS ONE OF MY QUESTIONS AND THEN --
SIXTY FOUR DEALT WITH
RECREATIONAL USE AND NOW WE'RE
SAYING WE'RE THIS IS FOR MEDICAL
USE SO THAT'S ALSO LIKE A
DISCREPANCY FOR ME AND I HAVE
ONE OF MY MUNICIPALITIES -- TO
THIS WOULD HAVE -- AND OF IMPACT
ON SO ANSWER SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS FOR ME.
SURE SURE WE STARTED ON WE BASED
ON LIQUOR LICENSES WE WE CHOSE.
25% BECAUSE WE THOUGHT IT WAS OR
A REASONABLE NUMBER RELATIVE TO
THE NUMBER OF LIQUOR LICENSE TO
JURISDICTION HAD -- WE STARTED
OUT THE BILL -- FOCUSING ON
RECREATIONAL AND MEDICINAL WE
TOOK A MAN'S IN THE COMMITTEE TO
FOCUS MORE ON MEDICINAL.
OKAY WHICH MUCH DOESN'T KNOW
EVERYTHING TO A PROP.
SIXTY FOUR AGAIN.
TO THE TIME FORTUNATE THAT THE
THE CITIES AND THE COUNTIES --
REALLY HAVEN'T FOR FILLED THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS -- TO PROVIDE
GREATER LEGAL ACCESS ON PROP --
SIXTY FOUR WE WE HAVE THE
NUMBERS JUST LOOK AT IT 77% OF
CITIES BAND.
LOCAL STORE FRONTS 89% OF CITIES
BAND MEDICAL NON STORE FROM
RETAILERS THE NUMBERS JUST
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE -- SO IT'S
AGAIN -- SINCE.
WE GOT TO COMMITTEE WE DECIDED
TO THE TO COMMITMENTS.
TO THE BILL SO THAT WE COULD
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS AND
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE FOUND IS --
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE
BOARD SINCE SIXTY FOUR HAVE HAS
PASSED HAVEN'T REALLY HELPED GET
US OUT THE BLACK MARKET THAT WAS
REALLY THE PROMISED THAT THAT
AGAIN.
WAS MY CANNABIS WASN'T AVAILABLE
CAMPUS IS AVAILABLE IS THAT
THERE'S IT'S A HUGE BLACK MARKET
SO WHAT WE WANTED WAS TO
LEGALIZE IT BRING IT OUT OF THE
BLACK MARKET.
IN OF COURSE UNFORTUNATELY
CITIES AND COUNTIES REACTED BY.
HAVING ALMOST A WHOLESALE BAN.
UP ALL SUPPORT THIS TODAY BUT
I'M GONNA.
KEEP WATCHING IT AS IT MOVES
TOWARDS THE FLOOR SWEEPING IT'S
MORE THESE THINGS RESULT AFTER
FOUR ABSOLUTELY AND WE CONTINUE --
TO WANT TO WORK AND DISCUSS WHAT
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO TRY TO FIND
A PATH THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA.
BIGGEST CHAIRMAN AND HE WAS
CHIANG FOR A FOR THIS
LEGISLATION FOLLOWING UP ON MY
COLLEAGUES I STILL.
AM TRYING TO SUSS OUT THE
DIFFERENCE SO THAT THE THE
TRIGGER FOR WEATHER ON A LOCAL
JURISDICTION WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
A LOOK TO COLLECTIVE ACTION.
ON IS WHETHER OR NOT A MAJORITY
VOTED FOR PROP SIXTY FOUR WHAT
WAS A WHICH WAS ABOUT A DAHLE
USE OF CANNABIS.
OF BUT THE LEGISLATION IN ITS
CURRENT FORMATION IS AROUND
MEDICINAL USE AND I'M CONFUSED
ABOUT THAT THAT.
CONTRAST I THINK IT'S I THINK
THAT THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION --
GOING THROUGH A DISCUSSION WITH
THE COMMITTEE I I THINK -- THE
COMMITTEE SENSE WAS THAT HE WAS
BY BETTER TO MAKE THE BILL MORE
NARROW.
AND MAKE IT FRANKLY -- SORT OF
EASIER -- TO TO ILL TO YOU KNOW
WHY A WIDER VARIETY IF YOU KNOW
MEMBERS SO YEAH WE WE DECIDED TO
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION OKAY.
AND WITH REGARD TO SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN I
THINK THE NARROWING ADDITIONALLY
FOR COMMUNITIES ACTUALLY HAVE
TAKEN THIS SORT OF VOTE -- IS
APPROPRIATE -- GIVEN THAT YOUR
BEARD YOUR TIME IS TO SIXTY FOUR
THERE ARE JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE -- LOOKED AT THIS.
BY PRISON POSITIVELY AND
NEGATIVELY -- AND SO EXEMPTING
THEM SEEMS TO MAKE A GOOD DEAL
OF SENSE I DO PUSH BACK ON THE
SUGGESTION THAT.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE ARE
EMBRACING THIS OCCURS IN IN MY
COUNTY THAT ISN'T REALLY THE
CASE -- I I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT
NUMBER OF TIME AHEAD OF OF
CITIES -- IN THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO WE HAVE EIGHTEEN I THINK A
SMALL MINORITY ACTUALLY HAVE ANY
KIND OF AT THE MEET AND ABLY
LEGISLATION ON IT.
THE COUNTY HAS A VERY
RESTRICTIVE -- LEGISLATION
AROUND IT AND SO AS A
CONSEQUENCE ACCESS IS CERTAINLY
CURTAILED BY THINK FOR
JURISDICTIONS LIKE THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO WHO STEPPED UP AND
ACTUALLY PASSED AN ORDINANCE.
EMILY VERY RESTRAINED -- BUT THE
END RESULT IS ONE WHERE THEY'RE
DEALING WITH THE IMPACTS.
OF THE RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS --
WHILE OTHER JURISDICTIONS --
DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT --
AND SO THERE'S AN EQUITY HERE
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT I
THINK ONE OF THE CONCERNS I
WOULD HAVE IS THE NUMBERS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT 25%
FIGURE WHICH IS A BIG CONCERN TO
ME JUST ON THE TOP LINE -- FIRST
OF THE 20% OF GENERAL SALES
PERMIT SO IT'S NOT EVERY
RESTAURANT EVERY BAR EVERY
LIQUOR STORE ON EVERY GENERAL
MERCHANDISE DEPARTMENT STORE
THAT SELLS LIQUOR IT'S JUST
LIQUOR STORES.
THAT KIND OF PERMIT RIGHT TO THE
25%OFF OF THE NUMBER THAT'S
PROBABLY FAR LESS THAN WHAT
PEOPLE THINK CORRECT BY QUARTER
LOOK THINK OF THE LAST QUARTER
LIQUOR STORES IN AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF FILTERS THAT YOU'VE
PUT THIS THROUGH IN ORDER RIDE
IN A FINAL FIGURE SEVEN SPEAKING.
WITH SOME OF THE BILL PROPONENTS
BUT WE SHARED WITH ME IS IT A
CITY LIKE SELANNE BEACH AND MY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THAT HAS OVER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE UP WHAT
HAS FORTY LIQUOR LICENSES UNDER
YOUR BILL IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT ONLY -- ONE CAMPUS RETAIL
LICENSE WOULD BE ISSUED IN A
CITY OF THAT NATURE THAT THAT'S
RIGHT YEAH BECAUSE THE BILL ALSO
SET THE FEELING.
OF ONE LICENSE PER TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
SO WHAT WHICHEVER SMALL AND SO
IT WENT AYE NEGATIVELY THEY'LL
BE NEW STORIES WRITTEN ABOUT
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
ANYONE WHO RUSHES TO SAY 25% OF
IN THE CASES LONG BEACH THE
FORTY LIQUOR LICENSES -- NOT
SUPER GREAT ON MATH BAG EVEN
THAT WHEN I CAN DO -- FOURTEEN
WE TELL LICENSES MEANS TEN
DISPENSARIES OR TEN WE TELL
ESTABLISHMENT BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOUR BILL DOES IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE OF THIS ONE MOST.
COASTAL CITY IT WOULD BE -- ONE
AGAIN INFORMATION PROVIDED ME IS
THAT THE DEL MAR AND EVEN
SMALLER CITY WOULD STILL JUST BE.
ONE THAT'S RIGHT AND IN THAT'S
IN CONTRAST TO THE ZERO THAT
BOTH OF THOSE CITIES CURRENTLY
HAVE WHICH COULD SEE YOUR POINT
ABOUT WHO ACTUALLY IS HAVING
ACCESS THAT'S RIGHT AND I THINK
I THINK MY CITY SAN FRANCISCO'S
FACING SIMILAR -- SITUATION TO
YOUR CITY OF SAN DIEGO WHERE ARE
WE HAVE BEEN SORT OF EARLY
ADOPTERS I'VE MISSED MEDICINAL
AND RECREATIONAL UNFORTUNATELY
THE SURROUNDING CITIES IN THE
BAY AREA HAVEN'T REALLY FOLLOWED
SUIT SO THEN.
IT REALLY ENCOURAGES EVERYBODY
TO COME INTO SAN FRANCISCO JUST
TO PURCHASE CANNABIS AND WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE IS JUST A
SLIGHTLY MORE EVEN DISTRIBUTION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN IN THAT RESONATES FOR ME
AGAIN WAS OF SHARON -- THE CITY
SAN DIEGO THE CITY THE PILL
BEACH I THINK OF TAKING ACTIONS
BUT THAT'S TWO OF THE FIVE
CITIES I REPRESENT OF THE BOUNCE
OF WHICH NOT TAKEN ANY SPECIFIC
ACTION AND WHILE THIS FEELS
AGGRESSIVE -- I RECOGNIZE THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH A VERY
SIGNIFICANT BLACK MARKET AND I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WOULD STAND BY ENABLE OR ASSIST
THE BLACK MARKET TO CONTINUE TO
EXIST -- WHETHER THAT'S THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS THAT
UNDOUBTEDLY HAS IN YOUR DISTRICT
IN MINING DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE OR TO THE SAID THAT IT
UNDERMINES THE WORK OF OF
LEGITIMATE OPERATORS ARE GOING
TO THE REGULATORY PROCESS. TO
ACTUALLY TRYING TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW -- I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE IN THE BUSINESS OF
TRYING TO HELP THAT I'M NOT SURE
IF THIS BILL IS PERFECT IN ITS
CURRENT FORM -- BUT I CERTAINLY
TRUST YOU MISTER TING TO
CONTINUE TO BE A DECENT STEWARD
OF OF THIS KIND OF IDEA CONTINUE
TO FIND IT AGAIN LOOK AT THE
PERCENTAGE IN WONDER -- HOW
UNNECESSARY THAT MIGHT BE -- BUT
THE THE MMC TAKEN TODAY I AM I
THINK OUR STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I WAS WITH BILL TODAY
THEY AND AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY TO
AGAIN REFINED THE PERCENTAGE --
THE OTHER PART IS THE YOU KNOW
MY PERSONAL CONCERN IS THAT IF
WE DON'T SUPPORT.
THE LICENSED -- LICENSED
OPERATORS RIGHT NOW WE ARE
POTENTIALLY PUTTING THEM AT RISK
OF BEING PUT OUT OF BUSINESS AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING WHICH WOULD MAKE IT A
PERMANENT BLACK MARKET WHICH
WOULD REALLY -- MOVE US IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUIRK SILVA
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHRIS -- THANK YOU MISTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING ON THIS
BILL AND I'M GONNA SUPPORT IT
TODAY BUT IT AS WAS MENTIONED
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES -- WHEN
WE REALLY LOOK AT THE DATA WE
SEE QUITE A SPLIT ON NOT ONLY
THE SUPPORT BUT ALSO THE
OPPOSITION?
THAT BEING SAID ORANGE COUNTY.
HAS ALSO CHAU NGUYEN -- VERY
SLOW -- LOOK AT IMPLEMENTING
THIS WITH REALLY ONLY TWO CITIES
COSTA MESA AND SANTA ANA I KNOW
THAT DIDN'T FULLER TEN WHICH IS
THE LARGEST PART OF MY DISTRICT --
THAT -- WE THERE'S BEEN NO STEPS --
TAKING AT THIS POINT AND YET THE
BLACK MARKET IS WORKING.
VERY ACTIVELY WORKING IN BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE -- ON THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY SIDE THE ENFORCEMENT.
IT JUST SEEMS THAT EVERY TIME
YOU ARE.
MOVING INTO A NEW LOCATION IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT THEY'RE POPPING
UP AND IT CAN TAKE SEVERAL
MONTHS FOR THEM TO CLOSE.
DOWN -- OPERATION -- THAT.
AND AGAIN BY THE TIME THEY CLOSE
ONE DOWN YOU SEE ANOTHER -- FOUR
FIVE POP UP SO THAT IT -- THE
CONCERN IS THERE IS THERE USING
THE SYSTEM AND AS A STATE WITH
THIS LEGALIZATION ONE OF THE THE
OPPORTUNITIES WAS THAT WHEN WE
BROUGHT IT INTO THE FOR FRONT
DOOR OUT OF THE BLACK MARKET WE
WOULD START TO SEE.
SOME TYPE OF REVENUE THAT WOULD.
NORMALLY BE USED FOR EDUCATION
BUT MANY OTHER THINGS AND SO
WITH THAT I'M HOPING THAT AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD THAT YOU'LL LOOK AT
THAT THRESH FOR THE REST A SKEWS
ME THRESHOLD SO THAT -- WE CAN
IN FACT GO BACK TO OUR DISTRICTS
AND GIVE THEM THE CONFIDENCE
THAT WERE UNDERSTANDING BOTH
SIDES.
THAT'S RIGHT AND I THINK -- AT
THE RISK OF OVER GENERALIZING
OUT WHILE YOU HAVE TO CITIES IN
YOUR COUNTY THERE ARE ARE
LEGALLY -- SELLING CAMPUS I
WOULD.
OFFER A GAS THAT EVERY SEAT AT
THE YOU CAN GET CAMPUS IN ALL
THE OTHER CITIES IS JUST IN THE
BLACK MARKET.
IN REALLY WHAT THAT HURTS SAUCES
IT MEANS THAT YOU DO NOT FALLING
HEALTH AND SAFETY BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT HEALTH THEY'RE NOT
FOLLOWING WORKPLACE CODES.
THERE ARE NOT FOLLOWING -- THE
TAX LAWS AND CHARGING TAXES SO
THEN THEY CAN CHARGE YOU KNOW X.
PERCENT LAST AND THE LICENSE
DISTRIBUTORS SO AGAIN.
THAT THIS IS VERY MUCH TRYING TO
CREATE AN EVEN PLAYING FIELD AND
AGAIN I THINK AS MY COLLEAGUE
ARE CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO SAID.
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT --
YOU'RE TRYING -- TO LEADER A
CITY WITH A HUGE NUMBER OF THEM
BUT REALLY ASKING EVERY CITY
JUST TO DO THEIR THEIR SMALL
PART AS LONG AS THEY'RE THEY'RE
VOTERS HAVE.
HAVE AGREED WITH PROP.
SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL.
ACCESS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ME ESPECIALLY IN PARTICULAR WITH
MEDICINAL USE.
HAVE MUCH IS ALREADY BEEN SAID
BY MY COLLEAGUES I CONCUR WITH
THEM -- IT APPEARS LIKE THE BILL
IS HEADED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
BASED ON AMENDMENTS YOU'VE TAKEN
ALL I ASK IS CONTINUE TO WORK
ESPECIALLY WITH LEGACIES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND DO THE REFINEMENT THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT -- THAT
YOU'RE WILLING TO DO AND ALL
VOTE TO MOVE FORWARD TODAY BUT
WILL DEFINITELY BE WATCHFUL AS
IT MOVES TOWARD THE FLOOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
CONSUMERS AT THIS TIME AS A
MEMBER TING TO WHICH TO CLOSE
AGAIN JUST ONE THINK THAT THE
COMMITTEE -- YOUR STATIC ME
CHAIR AT THE THE STAFF AND ALL
ALSO THE MEMBERS FOR THE GREAT
QUESTIONS.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR TING AS
WE'VE SAID EARLIER IN THIS
COMMITTEE AS WE HEARD A PREVIOUS
BILL ON TAXATION IF FOR CANNABIS
THIS IS.
ANOTHER PROPOSAL TO HELP SUPPORT
AS I UNDERSTAND FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT THE REGULATED
MARKET AND TO TRY AND GET MORE
OF THE GOOD ACTORS.
GETTING OUT OF THE GRAY AND THE
BLACK MARKET -- AND AGAIN AS WE
STATED BEFORE TOO THIS IS JUST%
ONE APPROACH -- TO TRY TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT BUT AGAIN THE
RECOGNITION AND CONCERNS FROM
SOME MEMBERS WITH RESPECT TO
LOCAL CONTROL OR THE ENFORCEMENT
TOWARDS THE BLACK MARKET -- WE
SHOULD HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO HOW
WE CAN SUPPORT.
OF THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY --
WITHIN ALL THE THE VANTAGE
POINTS THAT WE MIGHT HAVE A WIN
THIS BILL WAS FIRST PRESENTED IN
ITS ORIGINAL FORM I ALSO SHARED
WITH YOU SOME SIGNIFICANT
RESERVATIONS.
THAT I SHARED WITH YOU -- A
PRETTY GREAT RESPECT BACK TO THE
CITY THAT I COME FROM THE CITY
OF CAMPBELL TO WHICH VOTERS
SPOKE VERY RESOUNDINGLY ON THE
ISSUE.
AT HAND HAVING SAID THAT YOU'VE
AGREED TO THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
TRYING TO MAINTAIN ADDITIONAL
LOCAL CONTROLS DON BUT I
APPRECIATED THE RECOGNITION.
OF THIS ISSUE AND LOOK FOR TO
THE CAN TO CONVERSATION HAD SO
THIS DOES IT ENJOYED TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THERE IS A MOTION
IS THEIR SECOND.
MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
SECOND BY DOCTOR EGGMAN ME
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THANK YOU.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW LOW AYE BRO
BLOOM.
JOHN.
GEN NOT VOTING JILL.
CUNNINGHAM DALI.
DALI NOW EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
HI TING.
TING AYE [inaudible]
BUT MY THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
WHEN I MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTY BY
DR QUIRK
[inaudible]
WITH HIM.
AND AGAIN THE DOCTOR QUIRK WILL
PROVIDE -- TESTIMONY UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
OKAY THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
THANK YOU ALSO TO COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR ANALYSIS.
I AB TWELVE THIRTY WOULD --
PROHIBITIVE VETERINARIAN FROM
DECLINE IN ANIMAL EXCEPT FOR
THERAPEUTIC PURPOSES FOR EXAMPLE
TO AMPUTATE AN INJURED CHAU.
LET ME START BY SAYING THAT --
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THERE
ARE MANY GOOD SUGGESTIONS.
OUT ONE OF THEM IN WHICH I WILL
ACCEPT ONE IS NEARING THE SCOPE
OF THE BELL -- FROM ALL ANIMALS
TO DOMESTIC CATS ONLY NOTED
NOTABLY THIS WOULD ALLOW
VETERINARIANS. TO FOR EXAMPLE
CONTINUE REMOVING THE DEW CLAWS
ON DOGS -- SECOND CLARIFYING THE
DEFINITION OF DECLINE BY
ENUMERATING SPECIFIC -- SURGICAL
PROCEDURES AND ALSO CLARIFYING
AND THAT THE VETERINARIAN
MEDICAL BOARD WOULD HAVE A
VARIETY OF DISCRETION IN
DETERMINING WHAT TO DO IF
SOMEONE WERE TO VIOLATE THE BAN.
OF THE SPECIFIC AMENDMENT
LANGUAGE PROVIDING ON PAGE SIX
IN THE ANALYSIS WOULD REPLACE
THE CONTENTS THE BILL WITH AN
INFORMED CONSENT REQUIREMENT.
HOWEVER THIS IS ALREADY A
REQUIREMENT OF THE VETERINARY
ASSOCIATION -- THERE FOR THE
BILL WOULD DO NOTHING -- IN
ADDITION THE PARTICULAR --
DECLARATION THAT'S ASK FOR THERE
IS ACTUALLY OUT OF DATE.
THE AMERICAN VETERINARY SOCIETY
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO BE LOOKING
FOR A NEW -- DECLARATION.
OF INFORMED CONSENT TO REFLECT
MODERN -- RESEARCH THAT'S BEEN
DONE ON THE HARM DONE TO CATS --
SAYS SCRATCHING IS A NORMAL
FELINE BEHAVIOR THAT MAY BE
MANAGED BY PROVIDING SCRATCHING
POLLS TRIMMING CLAUSE.
OR PROVIDING -- SOFT SYNTHETIC
NOW CAPS.
ARE IN DECLINE IS MORE THAN JUST
REMOVING THE NAIL IT'S ACTUALLY
THE AMPUTATION OF THE LAST BONE
OF THE CAPS TOES.
IN HUMANS IS WHO PRIVILEGE OF
AMPUTATING ALL FINGER TIPS AND
OFTEN CHOSE FROM THE FIRST
KNUCKLE.
THEREFORE THE VETERINARIAN
PROFESSION IN MANY COUNTRIES
CONSIDER CACTUS DECLINE
MUTILATION WHEN CARRIED OUT FOR
THE BENEFIT OF AN ANIMAL'S OWNER.
RATHER THAN THE BENEFIT OF AN
ANIMAL.
SHOULD A VETERINARIAN IN IRELAND
FOR EXAMPLE PERFORM THIS
PROCEDURE FOR ANY REASON THE
VETERINARIAN WOULD FACE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF HAVING THEIR
LICENSE REVOKED -- IN A LAND
THAT IT'S ACROSS EUROPE IN THE
U. K. AT CETERA -- THAT THIS IS
BEEN BANNED.
IN NORTH HOLLYWOOD INCHES ME IN
NORTH AMERICA DECLINE IS ALREADY
BANNED IN A CALIFORNIA CITIES
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO SANTA MONICA.
WEST HOLLYWOOD IN CANADA THE
VETERINARY ASSOCIATION OF SIX
PROVINCES HAVE BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS ISSUE.
BY VOTING THAT THEIR MEMBERS
WILL NO LONGER PERFORM DECLINE.
THIS IS BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE
THE DECLAWING CATS IS.
BAD FOR CATS.
IN THE JOURNAL OF FELINE.
MEDICINE AND SURGERY THERE'S A
RECENT ARTICLE BY -- DOCTOR
MORAN -- WHICH IS LOOKED AT
THREE HUNDRED CATS AND LOOKED AT
KAT CITY BEEN DE CLAWED AND CATS
THAT HADN'T.
THOSE CATS THAT HAD BEEN DE
CLAWED WERE MUCH LIKELY TO HAVE
BAD BEHAVIORS.
SUCH AS URINATION OUTSIDE THE
LITTER BOX BECAUSE OF PAIN WHEN
DIGGING.
LOSS OF HAIR TO DO EXCESSIVE
GROOMING THE EQUIVALENT OF
OBSESSIVE COMPULSIVE DISORDER
BACK PAIN.
BITING AND AGGRESSIVENESS --
DOCTOR JUST WILD ON THE FAR LEFT
HERE HAS ADOPTED.
ARE TWO KITTENS THERE WERE TWO
CATS THAT WERE DE CLAWED.
THE FIRST WAS A MALE THAT HAD
BEEN DE CLAWED WENT TO A PUBLIC.
SHELTER BECAUSE OF YOUR
URINATING OUTSIDE THE LITTER BOX.
HAD HE NOT BEEN ADOPTED HE WOULD
HAVE DIED IN A FEW DAYS.
DENNY WAS PULLED FROM THE
SHELTER.
BY DR GENS FAULT.
AND DOCTOR JANICE FAULT TOOK HIM
INTO HIS HOME AND FOUND THAT IF
YOU USE.
A CARDBOARD BOX THAT THE ANIMAL
WOULD URINATE IN THAT AND WAS
ABLE TO KEEP THE ANIMAL FOR MANY
YEARS.
THROUGH ITS NORMAL LIFE.
THE SECOND WAS A FEMALE WHO HAD
BEEN DE CLAWED AS A KITTEN.
THE CAB AS IT GREW OLDER BECAME
ON PREDICTABLY AGGRESSIVE IN
WOULD BITE AT THE SLIGHTEST
PROVOCATION.
WITH THE INTERNET COULD NOT DEAL
WITH CATS MATERIAL CAMPER --
DOCTOR JANICE FALL TOOK THE CAT
INTO ITS OWN HOME.
AND RAISED IT.
BOTH OF THESE CATS HAD BEHAVIORS
THAT ARE KNOWN TO BE FOUND MORE
OFTEN AND DECRIED CLASS HE'S ME.
DECLAWED CATS.
AND BOTH CATS CAME CLOSE TO
BEING KILLED DUTY AND TOLERANCE
OF THESE BEHAVIORS.
IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO BE UP HERE
CALLING FOR AN END TO THIS
PRACTICE WHICH IS MORE LIKELY TO
HURT AN ANIMAL THEN SAVE IT.
GIVEN ALL THAT IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CITIES BANNING DECLINE OF SEEN A
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CATS
RELINQUISH TO SHELTERS SINCE
THEIR BANDS WHEN INTO A FACT
THAT TO DECREASE.
IN THOSE THAT ARE REFERRED TO
SHELTERS.
WELL SOME VETERINARIANS BELIEVE
THAT YOU MEAN HEALTH ISSUES NEW
TEST YET NECESSITATE DECLINE
THIS IS INCORRECT -- WE HAVE IN
FACT TESTIMONY FROM THE HEM
APHELIA COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
BOTTOM LINE HAVE A FEEL HE IS
NOT A REASONS TO CLAW YOUR CAT.
WE HAVE A LETTER FROM A HAM
APHELIA.
SHE'S ME.
HAMMER MYCOLOGICAL ONCOLOGIST
SAYING THAT [inaudible]
HE HAS.
PATIENTS WHO ARE ON BLOOD
THINNERS HE HAS PATIENTS WHO
HAVE.
POOR IMMUNE SYSTEMS AND YET HE
WOULD NEVER.
ASK THE CATS BE CLAWED BECAUSE
IT'S SIMPLY NOT AN ISSUE.
WHEN I'VE TALKED TO THE
VETERINARIANS THEIR MAIN REASON?
FOR ALLOWING THIS IS THE FACT
THAT IT HELPS HUMAN HEALTH FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN FACT HAVE A
PHILLY ACTS OR ON BLOOD THINNERS.
AND IN FACT.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE ACCORDING
TO THE HUMAN DOCTORS.
FURTHERMORE.
IF THE CAT CANNOT SCRATCH IT'S
MORE LIKELY TO BUY THIS LEADS TO
INFECTION -- WHICH CAN'T FAT CAT
SCRATCHES REALLY DO.
THUS THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL DOES NOT RECOMMEND
PEOPLE WITH COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEM SUCH AS HIV DE CLAWED
THEIR CATS.
DOCTORS WHO TREAT THEIR YOUTH
THESE PATIENT POP POPULATIONS
WAITED TO SAY THEY HAVE NEVER
RECOMMENDED THAT THEIR PATIENTS
TO CLAW THEIR CAPS.
NOR SEEN FACE ANY HEALTH
PROBLEMS DUE TO CAT SCRATCHES.
FINALLY.
WE ASKED A DISCIPLINE A
DISABILITY ADVOCATE ORGANIZATION
WHETHER CLAUSE CAN HARM THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DISABLED PERSON AN ARTISTIC
PERSON IN THEIR CAT.
THERE WAS RESPONSE WAS TO
REGISTER FORMAL SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE.
WHAT SOME VETERINARIANS ALREADY
DECLINED O THE CLOCK CATS
OTHERS DO IT RARELY?
OFFER TOO MANY THOUGH DECLINE IS
STILL A ROUTINE PROCEDURE -- WE
HAVE DATA SHOWING THAT UP IN
SOME CASES UP 220% OF CAPTURE
THE CLOT.
I HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THESE MEASURES -- DOCTOR JUST
JAZZ.
JAZZ WORLD IS NOT GOING TO
TESTIFY BECAUSE HE HAS LOST HIS
THROAT BUT I'VE GIVEN YOU IS
BOUGHT.
POINTS DIRECTOR JENNIFER CONRAD
THE FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR THAT.
BOB PROJECT AND BRENDA BARNETT
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF AN
ANIMAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN UP
TO THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WELCOME.
I'M THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER
CONRAD I'M A VETERINARIAN AND I
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW.
THAT THERE'S A REASON THAT WE
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD IT'S A
CRUEL THING TO DO TO ANIMALS I
HAVE REPAIRED THE PAWS OF BIG
CATS AND LITTLE CATS WHO HAVE
BEEN DE CLAWED AND WHEN I GET A
CALL.
FROM THE OWNER WHO HAS DE KLERK
WHO HAS A CAT HE'S NOT USING THE
LITTER BOX OR WHO IS BITING MY
STAFF 1100% OF THE TIME SAYS
WHEN WAS THAT CAT DECLAWED
[inaudible]
I YOU.
VETERINARIANS ARE USING A
SURGERY TO ADDRESS BEHAVIOR
PROBLEM.
IN HUMAN MEDICINE THAT WENT OUT
WITH LOBOTOMY.
INFORMED CONSENT DOES NOTHING
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU GET A NEW APP
ON YOUR PHONE AND YOU SAY I
AGREE NO ONE'S READ THAT IT'S
NOT GOING TO PROTECT CATS.
I RESPECT.
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MATT IS BRENDA BARNETT
I AM THE GENERAL MANAGER OF LA
ANIMAL SERVICES AND I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
BRIEFLY THIS MORNING.
I WANT IS JUST MENTION THAT IN
THE FIVE YEARS BEFORE WE PASSED
THE DEFAULT BAN IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES WE HAD TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO CAPS ADULT CAT OWNER
SURRENDERED. FIVE YEARS AFTER
THE BAND WE HAD HAD FIFTEEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX WE'RE A DATA DRIVEN.
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS A FORTY
THREE POINT 3% DECLINE IN OWNER
SURRENDERS -- ONCE WE WERE NOT
DECLINE CATS IN THE CITY.
I ALSO WANTED TO JUST MENTION
THE CHALLENGE AND THE CONCERNS
ABOUT HAVING CATS THAT ARE NOT
DIG CALLED WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
I HAVE A NINE YEAR OLD SEVERELY
AUTISTIC GRANDSON HE HAS NEVER
NOT HAD A CAT IN HIS HAND AND
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN DE CLAWED.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WOULD DO
WITHOUT AS KITTENS.
NOW I THINK -- THE BEHAVIOR
PROBLEMS THAT I'VE SAME FROM
FRIENDS.
FROM PEOPLE WHO HAVE SURRENDERED
THEIR CATS URINATING OUTSIDE THE
LITTER BOX IT'S A TERRIBLE
PROBLEM TO HAVE IT'S ONE I HAD A
FRIEND WHO HAD A CAT WHO'D BEEN
DEFAULT.
DO ANYTHING SHE COULD DO IS
EVERY FEW YEARS SELL HER CONDUCT
TO THEY COULD RIP OUT THE CARPET
AND MOVED TO A NEW CONDUCT SHE
WAS THAT COMMITTED TO OUR CAT
NOT VERY MANY PEOPLE ARE.
THE OTHER THING IS THE BITING NO
ONE WANTS A CAT HE JUST BITES.
THIS IS AN IN HUMANE THING TO DO
TO CATS AND I HOPE YOU WILL
SUPPORT STOPPING THIS PRACTICE
AND FOR US IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
THE CATS IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
GARY COOPER WORKING WITH THE
POWER PROJECT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE SIMPLY NAME
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DOCTORS
HERE WEST COOLEY DIRECTOR OF
RADIOLOGY FOR THE POP PROJECT
TWENTY FIVE YEAR MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING MYSELF
AND MANY MEMBERS WHO DISAGREE.
WITH OUR ASSOCIATION STANCE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DR BARBARA HODGES REPRESENTING
THE HUMANE SOCIETY VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES THANK YOU.
HEATHER STRAIGHTER CALIFORNIA
STATE REGISTERED VETERINARY
TECHNICIAN ON BEHALF OF HUMANE
SOCIETY VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GAIL LETTER WERE MEMBER OF MANY.
ANIMAL RIGHTS AND ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION SUCH AS THE HUMANE
SOCIETY THE POP PROJECT IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMALS AN ALLEY CAT
ALLIES YOU NAME IT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BAN ON THE
DECLINE OF CATS.
NICHOLAS SACKETT SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN
SUPPORT.
LAURA BRIDGMAN NUMBER HAVEN'T
FENCE OF ANIMALS IN SUPPORT.
JOHN LEONARD CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD WE ALLOW THE THE
DECLINE OF CAPTAIN SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES MISSION IS
BEACON SUPPORT.
SEE NOTICE NO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WHEN THIS IS AN OPPOSITION FREE
KINDLY MAKE SOME ROOM FOR WHEN
THIS IS AN OPPOSITION?
AND AGAIN UP TO THREE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY IN TOTAL FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
WELCOME AGAIN AFTER THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MIGHT DEAL REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION -- WE REMAIN
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE
OF WITH ME HERE IS DOCTOR CAN
PLOW SKI IF YOU HAVE ANY MEDICAL
QUESTIONS WHEN I FINISH HERE.
THIS IS BEEN A LONG STANDING
ISSUE FOR VETERINARIANS AND TO
BE HONEST IT'S NEVER REALLY BEEN
ABOUT THE SURGERY ITSELF BUT THE
ISSUE OF PRECEDENT.
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD PUT
SOMETHING IN THE VETERINARY
PRACTICE ACT -- AND CALL IT AN
UNLAWFUL PROCEDURE AND THEN WE
ASK A WHERE DOES IT END THERE
ARE SOME SMALL GROUPS -- THAT
WISH TO BAN A RABIES
VACCINATIONS THERE ARE SOME
OTHER GROUPS THAT WOULD -- BAND
SPAYING AND NEUTERING SO AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER THE PROCEDURES
DONE FAR LESS TODAY THAN IT WAS
EVEN FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
AS A NUMBER OF VETERINARIANS
HAVE TOLD US WE DIDN'T GO TO ALL
THOSE YEARS OF LAW SCHOOL TO
HARM ANIMALS -- WE THINK THAT --
PUTTING INFORMED CONSENT -- IN
THE MEASURE WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT -- TO DIET
DOCTOR QUIRK OF THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND THE
AMERICAN VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HAVE SOME GUIDELINES
BUT ARE THERE NO REQUIREMENTS
SOME VETERINARIANS USE THOSE --
BUT WE THINK BY PUTTING IT INTO
LAW AND THEN PUTTING IN THE
CLIENT'S FILE -- WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT STEP THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JUST AS
THE FROM AN EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD WE REGULATE THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF
VETERINARIANS IN THE NATION AND
OUR MISSION IS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND ANIMALS.
BY REGULATING LICENSING
LICENSEES PROMOTING PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS AND DILIGENTLY AND
FORCING THE BY NAME AND MEDICINE.
PRACTICE ACT.
AND IS ABLE SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN MEETING THE VENDOR
MEDICAL BOARD AND THE PUBLIC
CONDUCTED A LENGTHY DELIBERATION
REGARDING THE PROVISIONS I'VE
BEEN CONCERNS WITH AB.
TWELVE THIRTY RESPECTFULLY THE
BOARD IS TAKEN IN OPPOSITION. TO
AB TWELVE THIRTY THE BOARD IS
CURRENTLY ABLE AND DOES TAKE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST
VETERINARIANS FOR NEGLIGENT AND
INCOMPETENT HACKS.
SHOULD SOMETHING GO WRONG DURING
THE PROCEDURE AN ANIMAL IS HARM
THE BOARD'S CURRENT ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS GRANTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE ALREADY PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT PROTECTIONS FOR
ANIMAL PATIENTS IN THEIR OWNERS.
AS STATED IN OUR LETTER THE
BOARD MEMBERS IN GENERAL AGREE
THAT DECLINE SHOULD NOT BE A
PROCEDURE PERFORMED WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION OF THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE ANIMAL PATIENT.
HOWEVER THAT DETERMINATION IS
BEST LEFT TO THE VETERINARY AND
THE ANIMAL OWNER.
IN ADDITION CONCERNS WERE RAISED
THAT PROHIBITING THE CALL
PROCEDURES WOULD NEGATIVELY
AFFECT.
THE ABILITY OF CAST TO EITHER
STAY IN EXISTING HOMES OR BE
ADOPTED INTO A NEW HOME.
CONCERN HAS WAS ALSO REYES
REGARDING BACK ALLEY PROCEDURES
WERE WHERE ANIMAL OWNERS WILL
ATTEMPT TO DO CALL THE ANIMALS
THEMSELVES.
WELL THE BOARD IS NOT DISCUSS
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO THE
NOW SAYS I DO BELIEVE THE
ADDRESS ALL THE CONCERNS RAISED
ANTICIPATED FOR SUPPORTING THEM
TO THE GO THROUGH. TEN SECONDS
LEFT.
HM -- SO MY EXPERIENCE -- IS
THAT THESE BECAUSE CATS CAN LIVE
WITH IT EXCELLENT LIFE AND THERE
WAS A SURVEY OF TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE OWNERS AND I'M
SORRY I CAN'T NAME INFORMATION
PLEASE SORRY I'M SURE WATER
HOUSE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
BETTER MEDICAL BOARD LOCATE AND
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION.
AND SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION VERY
MUCH OUR TIME IS UP FOR THE
THREE MINUTES OF TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION SO NOW GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
I DO NOT SEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM KEY MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME AFTER COURT DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE -- YES -- SO WHAT
WE'VE HEARD TODAY IS A SLIPPERY
SLOPE ARGUMENT.
ON THE OTHER HAND WHAT I HAVE.
SO MOST KNOWN HERE.
NOT WHAT I HAVE IS A MEDICAL
STUDY.
IN THE JOURNAL OF FELINE
MEDICINE AND SURGERY.
LOOKING AT THREE HUNDRED CATS
SHOWING THE ADVERSE IMPACTS
[inaudible]
FURTHER.
WELL YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
VETERINARIAN HERE THAT THIS IS A
WAY TO KEEP CATS IN THEIR HOME --
THIS IS NOT A WAY TO KEEP THEM
IN THEIR HOME AS YOU HEARD FROM
MY WITNESS.
THEY'RE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO STAY
IN THEIR HOMES IF THEY'RE NOT DE
CLAWED WE FIND THIS -- IN THE
CITIES AND WHERE DECLINE HAS
BEEN OUTLAWED [inaudible]
SO.
THE OTHER THING IS A SLIPPERY
SLOPE ARGUMENT IF WE DO THIS AND
I GOT A BAND VACCINATIONS THE
ANSWERS NOW -- WE'RE ALWAYS
PRESENTED WITH THE IDEA OF A
SLIPPERY SLOPE BUT IN FACT.
WE HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS WE
HAVE TO DRAW LINES WE DO THIS
ALL THE TIME.
AS JOB [inaudible]
LEGISLATORS.
I'M PRESENTING THAT THIS HARMS
CATS IT IS NOT NECESSARY FOR
PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE MEDICAL ISSUES AND IT
DOES NOT STATE K. HELP CAN'T
STAY IN THE HOME?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR QUIRK
WE ARE NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION IS
THERE A MOTION TO HEAR.
OF THIS BILL.
THE MOTION ON THE BILL PRESENTED
BEFORE US.
SEEING THAT THERE IS NO MOTION.
THANK YOU ONE TO MY NEXT BILL
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
QUIRK.
FUNNY HOW EVERYONE CLEARED OUT.
AND THIS IS ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL --
FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE HOPEFULLY TO
BE MET STILL BE -- ENOUGH
MEMBERS -- TO LEFT TO GIVE ME A
MOTION ON THIS.
ONE I THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE
WILL ALLOW KITTENS TO BE MADE
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE FOR
ADOPTION. TWO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAVING THE THREE DAY HOLD
PERIOD.
CURRENT LAWS ALLOWS FOR THE
IMMEDIATE EUTHANASIA OF UNCLEAN
KITTENS AT AND SHELTER WITHOUT
THEIR MOTHER. ONE REASON FOR
THIS IS THE KITTENS ARE HIGHLY
VULNERABLE TO CONTAGIOUS
DISEASES DUE TO THEIR IMMATURE
IMMUNE SYSTEMS AND CAN EASILY
CONTRACT AN ILLNESS.
THIS TICKET WILL TAKE ADDITIONAL
TIME ATTENTION AND RESOURCES
CARE FOR AND BECOME A DRAIN ON
THE SHELTER.
IF KITTENS CAN BE REMOVED FROM
THE SHELTER TO A HOME WITH
GREATER CAPACITY TO MANAGE THE
HIGHER MAINTENANCE NEEDS.
THEY HAVE A MUCH GREATER CHANCE
OF A POSITIVE OUTCOME.
AND I WILL SAY THAT I'VE HAD
FRIENDS DOING THIS YOU CAN DO
THIS IF YOU'RE PART OF A LOCAL
NONPROFIT.
LIKE A ANIMAL PROTECTION --
ANIMAL WELFARE ORGANIZATION WHAT
YOU CAN'T DO AND WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW IS FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE.
JUST VOLUNTEERS TO DO IT.
SO THAT'S THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS BILL WITH ME TODAY ISSUES
AND RAKES WITH THE ASPCA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THAT.
BOOK RIGHT THANK YOU ALL THE ALL
THE BRIEF THAN A SUSAN RIGS WITH
THE ASPCA THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AND ON THE ONLY THING THAT
I WOULD REALLY ADDS TO YOU --
THESE IMPLEMENT MEMBERS --
POINTS IS THAT YOU OFTENTIMES
THESE KITTENS ARE COMING FROM
LITERALLY THE BUSHES OR
SOMEONE'S BACKYARD THERE ARE
PART OF A CAT COLONY FERAL.
CAT COLONIES AND THESE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WELL
MEANING MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THAT
THEY'RE BRINGING THEM IN AND
BOXES AND WOULD BE WILLING TO
TAKE THE BURDEN OFF OF THE
SHELTERS IF THEY WERE ALLOWED TO
TO TAKE THEM HOME AND BOTTLE
FEED THEM.
AND THAT WOULD BE A BENEFIT BOTH
FOR THAT COMMUNITY MEMBER AS
WELL AS THAT THE KITTEN.
THANK YOU AND I PAST YEAR -- I
THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THE
NOTICES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE WILL NOW ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND DOCTOR QUIRK YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
AS FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU.
RESEARCHER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE MOTIONS TO
PASS LOW [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
BRO.
I CHEN AYE.
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE.
MEDINA. THIRTY NINE THAT A BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SIX BILLS LEFT
SO LET US -- GO THROUGH -- BOOK
WELL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR BY SIMPLY ONE
PETRIE-NORRIS.
AGAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ASSEMBLY BILL. TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
AT THIS BILL EXPANDS ACCESS TO
BIRTH CONTROL BAKER FIND SOME
VAGUE HEALTH.
TELEHEALTH Là.
BIRTH CONTROL ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
CHOOSE IF AND WHEN TO START A
FAMILY SAFE AND EFFECTIVE FAMILY
PLANNING HAS HAD A PROFOUND AND
POSITIVE IMPACT ON WOMEN'S LIVES.
BUT DESPITE THIS THERE ARE STILL
THOSE WHO WORK TIRELESSLY.
TO INCREASE BARRIERS TO BIRTH
CONTROL AND IS POLICY MAKERS WE
MUST WORK TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
BIRTH CONTROL INCLUDING
REPRODUCTIVE TELEHEALTH SERVICES
RIGHT NOW IN ORDER FOR A WOMAN
TO ORDER BIRTH CONTROL VIA A
SMARTPHONE APP SHE MISSED FIRST
SCHEDULE A VIDEO CONFERENCE.
THIS IS PROVEN TO BE A BARRIER
THAT IS MEDICALLY AND NECESSARY
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OUR SPONSOR
ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY 50% OF ITS
PATIENTS THAT WOULD HAVE USED
THIS TELEHEALTH SERVICE.
FAILED TO FULFILL THESE
QUALIFICATIONS AND COULD NOT
ACCESS NEEDED BIRTH CONTROL THIS
ISSUE OF COURSE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS LOW
INCOME WOMEN AND RESIDENTS OF
MORE PEARL COMMUNITIES.
AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR WILL SIMPLY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IN ALL
COMMUNITIES.
AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR WILL UPDATE
OUR COACH REFLECTOR CHANGING
TECHNOLOGY AND ENABLE WOMEN TO
ACCESS BIRTH CONTROL HOWEVER SHE
SEES THAT.
I AM REALLY PLEASED TODAY TO
INTRODUCE OUR SUPPORTER AND
SPONSOR TO TESTIFY MOLLY ROBSON
FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVER EVER IF
YOU WISH TO PRESENT THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MOLLY RIPS AND I'M A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
SEVEN AFFILIATES WHO.
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND PATIENTS IN THE
STATE THREE HUNDRED AND A HEALTH
CENTERS.
I ONE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING UP AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
TODAY -- WE ARE SPONSORING THIS
BILL TO PROVIDE CLARITY IN THE
LAW RELATED TO TELL HEALTH AND
PROVIDING BIRTH CONTROL THROUGH
AN ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH MODEL.
DESPITE THE BEST MEN'S IN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH THERE'S
STILL AN UNMET NEED FOR BIRTH
CONTROL IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
PHYSICAL HEALTH CENTERS BUT
BECAUSE OF BARRIERS LIKE
TRANSPORTATION -- PERSONAL
THINGS ID IS GOING TO THE DOCTOR
THE WORK SCHEDULES AND JUST
DAILY LIFE LIKELY TECHNOLOGY HAS
CREATED ANOTHER DOOR TO THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
AND AS AN AVENUE THAT PROVIDERS
ARE USING TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
AND ARE TRULY REACH PATIENTS
WHERE THEY ARE.
RECOGNIZING THIS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CREATED AN APP P.
PETER ACT. TO PROVIDE HORMONAL
BIRTH CONTROL -- VIçT IN THE
APPLICATION.
BOB LAUNCHED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND SAW OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PATIENTS ON AVERAGE A MONTH
HOWEVER DUE TO AMBIGUITY IN THE
LAWS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN PP
DIRECT BEGAN REQUIRING
SYNCHRONOUS VIDEO CONFERENCE
BETWEEN PATIENT AND CLINICIAN.
THIS IS AN OBLIGATION THAT'S NOT
REQUIRED IN FIFTEEN OTHER STATES
THAT USE PP DIRECT AND MEDICAL
EXPERTS LIKE THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY AND THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH.
HAVE DIEM TO THIS -- SYNCHRONOUS
VIDEO NOT MEDICALLY NECESSARY
NOR DOES IT PROVIDE ANY CLINICAL
VALUE.
AS YOU CAN SEE THIS OUT NEEDS
PATIENTS WHERE THEY ARE AND AS
THE MEMBER AT THE AUTHOR MENTION
IT WAS A DISRUPTION IN CARE TO
FORCE ASKING CORNICE.
REQUIREMENT [inaudible]
I YEAH THIS APPLE OUT PP DIRECT
TO PROVIDE -- TO MEET AND MANY
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY UNABLE TO
ACCESS CARE AND HEALTH CENTER I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT EIGHTY VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEE
NOTICES OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS
COMES FROM KEY MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME SEE NO QUESTIONS COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS LOW HIGH
LOW I BROKE.
BROUGH NOT VOTING BLOOM.
JOHN.
GEN OFFERING.
TO CUNNINGHAM DALY EGGMAN FONG
GIPSON GLORIA GRAYSON HOLDEN
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN TO MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK SILVA TING.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AGAIN MEMBERS WE HAVE A
PLEASANTLY -- FIVE BILLS LEFT --
WITH INTO WE SEE ANY OTHER
AUTHOR I HAVE TWO BILLS EVERY
TIME HE ASKED THE SERGEANTS TO
CALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WE
LIKE.
TO ADJOURN IN AN APPROPRIATE
FASHION. TO TURN THIS OVER TO
OUR VICE CHAIR.
FILE I'M.
TWELVE THE CHAIR HAS FILE ITEM.
TWELVE AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE AND
FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB THIRTEEN
TWELVE MISS CHURCH A PREFERENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER I
CHAIR THIS IS FILE ITEM OR
TWELVE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL IS
SEVEN NINETY NINE MOVE THE BILL --
THIS IS INTENDED TO ENCOURAGE
THE ACCU PICTURES ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION A
SECOND AND WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
REMINDER THIS HAS A SUPPORT
SUPPORT FROM BOTH SIDES THE A
TWELVE UP TO THREE MINUTES --
THANK YOU. FOR CHIU ALLOW AND
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBER.
AUDIBLE COMMITTEE MEMBER.
MY NAME IS KIM AND CHAN.
I'M A VICE CHAIR.
OF THE ACUPUNCTURE POINTS.
AND WITH ME TO DAY IS
[inaudible]
FRANCISCO CAME AS FEDERAL
BOB MEMBER.
AND BEN.
BY TIA AS OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
A COUPON TO PORT APPRECIATE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
CHAIR ALLOW AND COMMITTEE MEMBER.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS STAFF. TO
PROTECTION THE POVERTY.
AND THE KIND OF FORTY YEAH I
COULD COME TO POINT.
IS FORTY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
FOR THE DAVID QUACKENBUSH
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE
TRADITIONAL MEDICINE ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO SHOW WHAT THIS IS.
MY NAME IS SCOTT PHILLIPS AND
I'M A CAL AT A BOARD MEMBER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS RELIGIOUS ISN'T SUPPORT
SAYING NON WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOT BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHICH AND ASK
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER CHAIR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AS QUICKLY AS
FOR ABOUT -- JUST TO CLARIFY YOU
ARE ACCEPTING NEW MEMBERS YES
THANK YOU SO WITH THAT IT'S TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
IT IS AND SEVEN NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
THOUGH I BRO BUT I BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA BUT IN AYE MULLIN
OBERNOLTE QUIRK SILVA TING.
AS SEVEN VOTES WILL KEEP THE
ROLLOVER PERHAPS MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS FEATURE
YOUR NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE A. B.. THIRTEEN
TWELVE THIRTEEN TWELVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS.
TO FOCUS ON THE CALLED
CONSULTANTS ACT WHICH REQUIRES
THAT.
COLLEGE CONSULTANTS REGISTER
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SECOND.
I MISS BEGAN A SECOND I MISTER
GRATION WITNESSES EXPORT.
THAT.
GIVE ME GOOD AFTERNOON THE END
TO THE READ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS.
ON US MANY OF THE PRIVATE
CONSULTANTS ARE GOOD BUT BROKE
CONSULTANTS OFTEN IMPEDE THE
WORK OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS MAKES
A GREAT IDEA WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE U. SIMILAR TO
MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU NATIONAL AND
ASSISTANCE PARK SHE NINE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FORGET ITS MEMBERS A
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE AS CHAIR GOING TO
CLOSE.
PRIVATE. FOR THE MOTION AND
SECOND.
EXCEPT IN THE MOMENTS YES THANK
YOU SO WITH THAT -- THE MOTIONS
TO PASS FOR PROCREATION IS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THAT INTO A MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS LOW I
THOUGHT I BROKE.
MY BLOOM.
CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES TO
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN TEN BY DOCTOR WOULD.
DOCTOR WOULD YOUR BILL THAT IS
BEING PRESENTED BEFORE US ENJOYS
A TO PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH
COMMITTEE MEN'S PLEASE FEEL FREE
PERCENT WHATEVER READY.
THANK YOU.
I'LL BE BRIEF.
WHICH I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL.
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT REGARDING
THE WHAT SUBSTITUTION OF THE
WORD RATIFY.
IN NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
VOTERS APPROVED PROP SIXTY FOUR
WHICH LEGALIZE A PURCHASE A
CONSUMPTION OF RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS [inaudible]
UNDER -- WELL THAT I HATE M. A.
C. M. A. YOU SEE OUR ESSAY.
THE LICENSING AND REGULATION OF
THE CANNABIS ACTIVITIES IS
SUBJECT TO LOCAL AUTHORIZATION
BEFORE A LICENSING AUTHORITY MAY
PROVE A STATE A LICENSE
APPLICATION.
IS CURRENTLY GREAT UNCERTAINTY
UNDER INTO UNDO HOW AN APPLICANT
ON TRIBAL LAND WOULD RECEIVE
LOCAL AUTHORIZATION FOR A STATE
LICENSE WITH OUT AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
A TRIBE.
AS A RESULT OF THIS AND SO
UNCERTAINTY AND THEIR UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIP.
THE COUNTY OF DON'T KNOW WORK
AND THE UP VALLEY RANCHERIA
ENTERED INTO A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING REGARDING THE
TAXATION AND REGULATION OF A
CANNABIS CULTIVATION OPERATION
INSIDE THE OUT.
HELP VALLEY RANCHERIA.
ALTHOUGH THE MO YOU ADDRESSES
LOCAL AUTHORIZATION RECOGNITION
RECOGNITION OF TRIBAL REGULATORY
THER AUTHORITY UNCERTAINTY UNDER
EXISTING LAW AND THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK CONSERVE AS A BARRIER.
FOR THE TRIBES TENET. TO ATTEND
A STATE CANNABIS CULTIVATION
LICENSE RECTIFY THE ON TRIBAL
LAND.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY ONE IS A
NARROW BILL THAT WOULD SIMPLY
CODIFY THE MO YOU BETWEEN THE
ELF VALLEY RANCHERIA IN THE
COUNTY OF DON'T NOR.
WOULD ESTABLISH LOCAL
AUTHORIZATION FOR A CANNABIS
RELATED ACTIVITY ON THE ELK
VALLEY RANCHERIA ADDITIONALLY --
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE LICENSEE
TO COMPLY WITH ALL REQUIREMENTS
OF BUT CRECER RECURSIVE.
INCLUDING AMONG OTHER THINGS
COMPLY WITH ALL SEQUEL
REQUIREMENTS COLLECTION
REMITTANCE OF STATE STATE SALES
TAXES OUR STATE TAXES AND
COMPLIANCE AUDITS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEE NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COULD YOU MEMBERS AT THIS
BEEN IN MOTION AND A SECOND
DOCTOR WOULD YOU WISH TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THREE SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTEEN TEN MOTIONS
DEPOSITS AMENDED LOW HI LOW HI
BRO BRO I BLOOM.
THEM I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY EGGMAN FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
I IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN?
OBERNOLTE QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
HI TING.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WOULD
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. FIVE ELEVEN FORTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WE PASSED A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TOOLS FOR GETTING
MONEY INTO THE HANDS OF OF OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING.
THANK YOU UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF
THINGS WE HAVE FOUND THAT UP
225% OF THE I. T. C. PAY OUTS
GOES TO TAX PREPARERS.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT ASK
THE TAX PREPARERS. TO MAKE CLEAR
UP FRONT WHAT THOSE COSTS ARE.
AND SO THAT CONSUMERS CAN MAKE.
A REAL CHOICE THERE ARE PLENTY
OF OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE DIVIDER
PROGRAMS WHERE.
OUR CONSTITUENTS CAN GET FREE
TAX PREPARATION SERVICES AND NOT
HAVE TO PAY THE FEES WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GO INTO
THOSE TRANSACTIONS KNOWING
WHAT'S AT STAKE BECAUSE WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS MAKE SURE THOSE
THE ITC PAYMENTS GO INTO THE
POCKETS OF THE FAMILIES WHO.
NEED IT THE MOST AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ITEMS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SOMEONE
OR STONE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M SOLANO RICE AND ON
BEHALF OF PROSPERITY NOW I
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
FORTY INTRODUCED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE.
THIS BILL I CREATE STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
TAXPAYERS IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURING THAT LOW
INCOME WORKING TAXPAYERS RECEIVE
THE FULL BENEFITS.
OF BOTH THE CALIFORNIA AND THE
FEDERAL EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
IN A TIME WHEN OUR STATE IS
LOOKING TO EXPAND THE SUPPORT OF
FINANCIAL SECURITY FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE.
WE SHOULD ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T
RISK HAVING TAX REFUNDS ARE
ROUTED BY HIGH COST OR PREDATORY
PAID TAX PREPARATION SERVICES.
I IN CALIFORNIA IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT AS A CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE
THANK AT TAXPAYERS.
PAID TAX PREPARERS RAKED IN
ABOUT SEVEN SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS JUST LAST
YEAR.
I HAD THE CLEAR DISCLOSURES
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL WILL GIVE
TAXPAYERS IN CALIFORNIA REAL
CHOICE BY HIGHLIGHTING IN PLAIN
LANGUAGE WRITTEN IN ENGLISH
SPANISH CHINESE TAGALOG
VIETNAMESE AND KOREAN.
THAT THEY CAN HAVE THEIR TO
RETURN PREPARED BY A PAID
PREPARE KNOW EXACTLY HOW MUCH
THEY'LL PAY AND COSTS AND FEES
RIGHT AWAY.
SOMETHING ALREADY DONE BY H. AND
R. BLOCK ONE OF THE LARGEST TAX
PREPARATION OUTLETS OUTLETS
CHAINS OR THAT THEY CAN TURN TO
A LOCAL VITA PROGRAM.
WELL THEY'LL HAVE THEIR RETURN
PREPARED ACCURATELY AND ENTIRELY
FOR FREE.
AND ACTING CLEAR DISCLOSURE
REGULATIONS ON TAX PREPARATION
WILL STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
TAX PREPARER REGULATIONS WHILE
ENSURING THE STATE'S.
INVESTMENT TOWARD BUILDING
FINANCIAL SECURITY WEALTH AND
PROSPERITY FOR ALL FAMILIES AND
NOT PAID TAX REPAIRS I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR.
OF AB ELEVEN FORTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME
TO THE MICROPHONE FOR IT WHEN
THIS IS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SIMPLY NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
NOW YOU LEASE ON THE WELL WHAT
THE UNITED WAY SO CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEE NONTRADITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NOW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU WISH TO COME
AND SPEAK IN OPPOSITION FEEL
FREE TO COME TO THE TABLE AND
CAN PROVIDE UP TO THREE MINUTES.
IN TOTAL FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS KAREN DIVINI I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF TAX
CONSULTANTS.
WERE IN OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL.
THE CALIFORNIA TAX PREPARERS ARE
ALREADY SUBJECT TO SOME OF THE
STRICTEST.
REGULATIONS IN THE STATE -- THE
DISCLOSURE STATEMENT THAT IS
BEYOND REQUESTED IN FIVE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
PUT SOME ON UNFAIR BURDEN ON TAX
PREPARERS.
AND THIS COSTS WOULD PROBABLY BE
PASSED ON TO THE CLIENT -- WHY
MOST OF OUR TAX PREPARERS HAVE
FEES POSTED?
ARE AVAILABLE.
A LOT OF TIMES IT'S AN
IMPOSSIBLE. TO TELL THEM EXACTLY
HOW MUCH THE TAX RETURN.
IS GOING TO COST BECAUSE WE
NEVER KNOW WHAT SURPRISES MIGHT
COME UP.
SOMEBODY COMES IN AND HAS
EVERYTHING ITEMIZED TOTALED
CLEAN.
NO PROBLEM.
WE HAVE HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION
OTHER PEOPLE COME IN WITH BOXES
OR BAGS.
AND WE HAVE TO WALK FURTHER
THROUGH IT.
SO SAYING A CERTAIN FORM OR WILL
COST EX NUMBER OF DOLLARS ALL
DEPENDS ON THE PREPARATION THAT
GOES ALONG WITH IT.
I AM ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT
HERE.
OF FROM THE COMMITTEE.
TO COME BEHIND THE OUR SUPPORT
THE GHOST PREPARES.
AND GET THEM OUT OF OUR BUSINESS
THEY DO MORE DAMAGE TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND TO OUR BUSINESS THEY DON'T
FOLLOW THE LAWS.
AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO FOLLOW
THIS THIS.
ONE I AM A TAX PREPARER IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
INTENTIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM COULD
BE MEMBERS.
SEEN NONE THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND MISTER DON'T DO WISH TO
CLOSE I ASK FOR YOUR EITHER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF SOMEONE
OR STONE -- THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND SO -- WE
WILL -- KINDLY -- TAKE A LOOK
HERE TO INSURE THAT WE CAN CALL
THE ROLL SO CREE SECTOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB ELEVEN FORTY MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI BUT
I PRO.
BONO BLOOM.
WHEN MY CHEN?
GEN NOW [inaudible]
TO COMING UP [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FONG ON NOW GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
WORKS OF AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS ABLE TO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMAN STONE MEMBERS WE
HAVE TO FINAL BILLS LEFT AGAIN
MEMBERS WE HAVE TWO BILLS LAST
BEFORE BEING BE COMMITTEE SO THE
REMAINING MEMBERS.
MIGHT KIND THEY COME HERE SO WE
CAN.
HAVE A VOTE ON THESE BILLS NEXT
UP THEN IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REVIEW.
AGAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I THANK
YOU. FOR THE TIME TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR THE
CALIFORNIA NURSING INITIATIVE
WHICH WILL EXPAND THE NURSING
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD ALSO CONSOLE LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF TO
HELPED IMPROVE.
THE BILL AND I ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AS PUT FORTH
IN THE ANALYSIS OF THANK YOU.
AS I'M SURE YOU MANY OF YOU ARE
AWARE CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE OF
NURSES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY HEALTH
IMPACT 85% OF HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA REPORTED DEMAND. FOR
NURSES BEING GREATLY OKAY BEING
GREATER THAN THE SUPPLY.
THE SAME REPORT HIGHLIGHTS THE
CALIFORNIA HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
BEHIND THE NET NATIONAL AVERAGE
OF NURSING PER NURSES PER CAPITA.
THIS HIGH DEMAND OF NURSES IS
LIKELY TO BE FURTHER INTENSIFIED
BY THE DECREASING NUMBER OF
UNINSURED PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A RESULT OF EXPANDING ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE AS WELL AS THE
HIGH GROWTH RATE OF SENIOR
POPULATION WE ALL KNOW IT IS A
SILVER TSUNAMI -- THE PEER
REVIEW JOURNAL AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF MEDICAL QUALITY RECENTLY
REPORTED.
THE NURSING SHORTAGE IS EXPECTED
TO CONTINUE TO GROW BY TWENTY
THIRTY THE REPORT ESTIMATES A
SHORTAGE OF OVER A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND NURSES.
AT THE SAME TIME OF OF HIGH
DEMAND FOR NURSES ANY PROJECTED
NURSING WORKFORCE DISPARITY.
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
HAS EXTREMELY LIMITED ENROLLMENT
ON NURSING PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS A RESULT STUDENTS SEEKING A
MOMENT IN THE NURSING PROGRAM
ARE FORCED TO WAIT FOR
UNPREDICTABLE AMOUNTS OF TIMES
ON WAIT LIST OR PROGRAMS ARE
FORCED.
TO DENY THE ENROLLMENT ALL
TOGETHER.
NOT ONLY DOES THIS DISCOURAGE
STUDENTS FROM EVEN APPLYING TO
NURSING SCHOOLS IT ENCOURAGES
STUDENTS TO LOOK OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES.
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
REASONS WHY IT IS SO CRITICAL TO
ACT NOW AND ENSURE CALIFORNIA IS
TAKING EVERY STEP TO EXPAND THE
NURSING WORKFORCE.
AND AB THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR IS A
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION.
THIS BILL WILL EXEMPT BEER ARE
AN APPROVED NURSING PROGRAMS
THAT MAINTAIN A HIGH PASS RATE
ON THE STATE LICENSING EXAM AND
ARE PART PROBLEM OUT PAGA MATT.
I CAN'T SEE THE WORD.
PROGRAMS ARE ACCREDITED BY IN
NURSING ACCREDITING AGENCY FROM
ADDITIONAL B. R. AND REGULATIONS
AND OVERSIGHT INCLUDING
ENROLLMENT CAPS AND FACULTY
APPROVAL.
THE ABILITY TO USE UP 250% OF
SIMULATION BASED LEARNING AND
THE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN NURSING
PROGRAMS AND CLIENT OF CLINICAL
FACILITIES.
WITH ME TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM NURSING
PROGRAMS TO FURTHER HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL EXPERTISE TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- WE HAVE A NICOLE HAS
SOMEBODY ROBIN NELSON.
OR OWN ROBIN AND A DOCTOR GEN
JONES SCHNECK.
AND TO A GEORGE MILLER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NO MORE THAN THREE
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR TESTIMONY
ON SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN LOW VICE CHAIRMAN BRO
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M DOCTOR JAN JOHN CHIANG DEAN
AN ACADEMIC VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE COLLEGE OF HEALTH
PROFESSIONS AT WESTERN GOVERNORS
UNIVERSITY AND I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR WESTERN
GOVERNORS UNIVERSITY OR WGU WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN BY NINETEEN US GOVERNOR'S
WITH A MISSION TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY AFFORDABLE.
HIGHER EDUCATION.
WG WAS REGIONALLY ACCREDITED NON
PROFIT UNIVRSITY SERVING
STRANDED LEARNERS.
WORKING ADULTS WITH SOME
EDUCATION BUT NO DEGREE.
WE OFFER BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S
DEGREES IN BUSINESS I. T.
TEACHING AND HEALTH CARE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THREE
LARGE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
EMPLOYERS AND THE ROBERT WOOD
JOHNSON FOUNDATION.
PARTNERED WITH W. G. YOU TO
DEVELOP A PRE LICENSURE BACHELOR
OF SCIENCE IN NURSING DEGREE.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN AN EFFORT
TO REDUCE THE STATE'S GROWING
NURSING SHORTAGE.
OVER THIS PAST DECADE WE'VE
GRADUATED OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY B. S. AND NURSES FAR BELOW
OUR CAPACITY.
DUE TO REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS.
LAST YEAR FOR EXAMPLE WG WAS
ONLY PERMITTED TO ADMIT FORTY
NEW STUDENTS JUST 2% OF ALL
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS.
OUR PRE LICENSURE OF OUR PRE
LICENSURE GRADUATE 61% ARE FROM
ETHNIC ETHNICALLY DIVERSE
POPULATIONS. 44% ARE MEN AND THE
AVERAGE AGE IS THIRTY FIVE YEARS
OLD.
OUR FIRST TIME LICENSING EXAM
PASS RATES THE AND CLICK SEE
EXAMINE CALIFORNIA'S 97%.
AS COMPARED WITH THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE FOR LIKE PROGRAMS THAT
92%.
SO TUITION AND FEES FOR OUR PRE
LICENSURE BSN PROGRAM IS LESS
THAN THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TOTAL.
W. CHOOSE ABILITY TO FULFILL OUR
MISSION SIR CALIFORNIANS
STRANDED LEARNERS.
AND ALLEVIATE THE STATE'S
NURSING SHORTAGE HAS BEEN
DRASTICALLY HINDER DUE TO THE
DUPLICATIVE ONEROUS AND EVEN
PUNITIVE.
REGULATORY CONSTRAINTS AROUND
EMPLOYED IN ENROLLMENT FACULTY
AND CLINICAL SIDE APPROVAL BY
THE B. R. IN ONE MINUTE LEFT.
IN CLOSING WGU WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
CHAIRMAN LOW AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICOLE SRB
I AM A GRADUATING SENIOR AT WEST
COAST UNIVERSITY AND I THINK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR MY FAMILY
IMMIGRATED FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
I WAS TEN YEARS OLD WHEN I
BECAME A UNITED STATES CITIZEN.
THE DAY I BECAME AN AMERICAN WAS
AN INCREDIBLE DAY YET AT TEN
YEARS OLD I WAS TOO YOUNG TO
HAVE TRULY UNDERSTOOD.
THE GRAVITY OF THAT MOMENT OR
EVERYTHING MY PARENTS HAD
SACRIFICE IN ORDER TO GRANT ME
FULL FREEDOM AND OPPORTUNITY.
AS YEARS PASSED I BEGAN TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BEING AN
AMERICAN MEANT THAT MY RACE MY
GENDER MY RELIGION MY
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS NONE OF
THESE THINGS SHOULD PLACE A
BARRIER OVER MY ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE SUCCESS.
YET THESE FUNDAMENTAL TRUTHS
WERE CHALLENGED WHEN I BEGAN
PURSUING MY DREAM OF BECOMING A
REGISTERED NURSE.
I SIMULTANEOUSLY HELP THREE
SEPARATE MINIMUM WAGE JOBS WHILE
TRYING MY BEST TO NAVIGATE THE
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM LOCAL
PUBLIC COLLEGES WERE SEVERELY
IMPACTED IN FOR YEARS I SAT ON
WAITING LISTS ARE OFFERED
IRRELEVANT COURSES.
IN ORDER TO STAY REGISTERED AS A
STUDENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT
CONCLUDES THAT THREE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAME AN AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO.
MAP BACK REPRESENTING CAPS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN ADDITION A WHEN THIS
IS IMPORTANT I LIKE TO CALL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WOULD
WITNESSES LIKE IN OPPOSITION
WISHING TO SPEAK.
A KILEY COME UP TO THE TABLE
HERE AND WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR
PROVIDE UP TO THREE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN TOTAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DIANE
HAS TO LACI ON THE DEAN OF
HEALTH SCIENCES AND HUMAN
SERVICES AT SADDLEBACK COLLEGE
IN MISSION VIEJO CALIFORNIA.
NURSING PROGRAMS EDUCATE OVER
FIFTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS EDUCATE OVER 50% OF ALL
PRE LICENSURE REGISTERED NURSES
IN CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE REGISTERED
NURSING PROGRAMS OFFER SOCIAL
MOBILITY TO UNDERSERVED SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS VETERANS AND SECOND
CHRIS STUDENTS WITHOUT THE
BURDEN OF CRUSHING EDUCATION
RELATED DEBT.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR WILL
RESULT IN A REDUCTION IN THE
QUALITY OF NURSING EDUCATION AND
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND REDUCE
OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE A LOW
COST PATHWAY. TO THE PROFESSION
OF REGISTERED NURSING THUS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FOUR PROPOSESTO UTILIZE
REGIONAL AND NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION AS A PROXY FOR
BEER AND REGULATION.
REGULATION AN ACCREDITATION ARE
VERY DIFFERENT THINGS BEER AND
REGULATIONS ARE ENFORCEABLE SET
MINIMUM STANDARDS AND CRITERIA
THAT MUST BE MET.
THESE REGULATIONS INCLUDE
MINIMAL FACULTY AND CURRICULUM
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS A
COLLEGIAL PROCESS TO ENSURE
ECKEL DISTRIBUTION OF LIMITED
BUT ESSENTIAL CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS. TO REPLACE YOUR IN
REGULATION WITH ACCREDITATION
REMOVES PATIENT PROTECTIONS AND
PUTS PATIENTS AT RISK.
THIS LEGISLATION IS SPONSORED BY
INSTITUTIONS THAT SEEK TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT WITHOUT BEER
AND REGULATION.
AS A RESULT OF THE RAPID GROWTH
OF TWELVE NEW PRE LICENSURE
PROGRAMS IN ORANGE COUNTY.
MANY WELL ESTABLISHED IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS MANY WELL
ESTABLISHED HIGH PERFORMING
NATIONALLY CREDITED COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO DECREASE ENROLLMENT.
TWO YEARS AGO ALL FORMS COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE NOTIFIED
ABLE TO HAVE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
OF THE PRIMARY PEDIATRIC
FACILITY IN ORANGE COUNTY.
I WAS NOTED THAT IT WAS NOTED AT
THIS TIME THAT A RELATIVELY NEW
RAPIDLY GROWING PRIVATE NURSING
PROGRAM MADE A DONATION TO THE
PEDIATRIC FACILITY OF MORE THAN
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
AND HAD COINCIDENTLY THREE TIMES
MORE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS IN THE
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES COMBINED.
FORTUNATELY THANKS TO BE OUR AND
INTERVENTION COMPROMISES WERE
MADE BETWEEN THE PEDIATRIC
FACILITY IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ALTHOUGH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DECREASE
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS BY 40%.
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS WERE
PRESERVED WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
BEER AND ADVOCACY WHICH WAS
ESSENTIAL IN REACHING A
COMPROMISE WITHOUT THEIR
INTERVENTION A LOW COST PATHWAY
TO THE REGISTERED NURSING
PREVENTION.
PROFESSION WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
PRESERVED IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR POSES A
THREAT TO THE LONG TERM.
SUSTAINABILITY OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE THIRTY
SECONDS LEFT.
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
CURTIS.
AFTERNOON CURSE L<c.cyan>G WITH THE</c>
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
CNA AS OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FOUR IN THE AMENDMENTS I'LL JUST
SUM IT UP BY SAYING SEE NAY
SUPPOSED TO IN ADDITION TO WHAT
TIME TO SET.
SEEN AS OPPOSED TO THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WOULD INCREASE
SIMULATION -- UP 250% OF THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF CLINICAL HOURS
RATHER THAN EXISTING LAWS CAP ON
THE NUMBER OF HOURS OF ALLOWABLE
SIMULATION IN A PARTICULAR
COURSE.
THIS ABOUT THE MEANS THAT 100%
OF AN INDIVIDUAL COURSE COULD BE
SIMULATION RATHER THAN DIRECT
PATIENT CARE EXPERIENCE AS LONG
AS NO MORE THAN 50% OF THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF CLINICAL HOURS WITH
SIMULATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME INTO MY FROM NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THANK YOU CHIRLA MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK MENDOZA
WITH SCA YOU CALIFORNIA WE'RE AT
A CONCERNS POSITION AND
APPRECIATE THE SPONSORS
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US ON
THE LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID NEVIN
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER SHARON MEMBERS RHYME
MACLAINE YOUTH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AGAIN CALIFORNIA TESTIFY ON
CALIFORNIA SEVENTY TWO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS BEHALF A IN
OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS ALSO WEBSTER ON
BEHALF OF THE COAST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT RANCHO SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE
IN OPPOSITION.
IN MY MAJID FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE CHANCES OFFICE
WHILE WE DO OPPOSE THIS BILL
TODAY WE APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS
IN THE AMENDMENTS.
WE ARE STILL REVIEWING THIS
AMENDMENTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IF
THE PRIMERS FOR TODAY THANK YOU.
HELEN ROSS SELDON SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND REPRESENTING THE STATE
WORKERS WERE WORKING WITH
THROUGH THE STATE COUNCIL BUT AT
THIS POINT WE OPPOSE WE A VERY
DEEP CONCERNS OVER THE STILL.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LINDA'S
AREN'T REPRESENTED THE
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATION OF A
SOCIAL GREENER AFTER GAY NURSING
IN OPPOSITION.
TELL ME HARRIS REFUSING
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING REPRESENTING MORE THAN
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
REGISTERED NURSES AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION.
AND HE'S READY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY WE
HAVE NO OFFICIAL POSITION AT
THIS TIME WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ANALYZE THE BILL AND AMENDMENTS
AS PRESENTED WE THINK THE AUTHOR.
FOR HER WORKING WE WILL CONTINUE
WORK WITH HER IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU I HAVE OF COMMON AND
ONE QUESTIONEIGHT I BELIEVE
PROBABLY FOR THE OPPOSITION --
IT OCCURS TO ME THAT THERE IS A
SERIOUS NURSING SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA -- IT ALSO OCCURS TO
ME OFFICERS JUST ON A PERSONAL
ANECDOTE MY MOM WENT THROUGH A
AND ARE IN PROGRAM OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WITH BACK TO
WORK IN HER FIFTIES -- SHE HAD
WAITED TIRE YEAR BECAUSE OF AN
ARTIFICIAL LIMITATION ON THE
NUMBER OF SPOTS TO SIT FOR A
YEAR WAITING FOR THE SPOTS TO
OPEN UP THE OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SO.
I KNOW FROM THAT AND THEN AS
PRICE SEVEN EIGHT YEARS AGO
MAYBE TEN BUT I AND I KNOW FROM
THAT THAT THE THESE PROGRAMS ARE
DEFINITELY IMPACTED.
IN WE HAVE A NURSING SHORTAGE.
I HEAR THE CONCERNS ABOUT.
OF THE LACK OF OVERSIGHT OR
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT.
BUT AS I UNDERSTAND THIS BILL
IT'S LIMITED TO TO PROGRAMS THAT
CAN STILL SHOW AN 80% PASS RATE
ON THE ON THE BOARDS.
SO COULD YOU ADDRESS WHY THAT.
THAT -- THAT DOES DOES NOT
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERN AND THESE
PEOPLE STILL HAVE TO TAKE THE
NATIONAL TESTS AND THEY STILL UP
THIS. TO PASS 80% IN ORDER FOR
THEIR PROGRAMS. TO TO REMAIN
VALID UNDER THIS BILL
[inaudible] TO ADDRESS. TO
ADDRESS THE PASS RATE OF THE
PASSWORD IS ONLY PART OF THE
CALL THE COMPETENCY EVALUATION.
WHICH IS A THAT I GOT TWO PART
OF COURSE WE'RE CONCERNED
ESPECIALLY WITH THE SIMULATION
AND HANDS ON PATIENT CARE
EXPERIENCE IS THAT WOULD BE CUT
BACK BY INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
TIME IN SIMULATION RELATIVE TO
ACTUAL PATIENT CARE EXPERIENCES.
AS WELL AS A LIMITATION ON THE
B. R. AND REGULATIONS THAT ARE
IN PLACE -- TO REGULATE.
THE ARM.
THE QUALITY OF THE EDUCATIONAL
PROCESS MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
FOR CURRICULUM MINIMUM FACULTY
QUALIFICATIONS AND TO HELP WITH
SEEK CLINICAL DISPLACEMENT
ISSUES THAT EXIST.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE NURSING SHORTAGE
THIS BILL IS BASED ON A SO
CALLED NOR SOME NURSING SHORTAGE --
BUT THE REPORT THE PROPONENTS
RELY ON IS NOT CONSISTENT WITH
ANY OTHER STUDY THAT HAS LOOKED
AT CALIFORNIA'S NURSING
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
USE UCF CALL YOU SEE S. F. HAS
CALLED THIS STUDY IN OUT LIAR
INSTEAD AT UCSF HAS FOUND A
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY NURSES
GRADUATING FROM NURSING PROGRAMS
AND SURPLUSES IN LA REGION WHICH
INCLUDES ORANGE AND VENTURA
COUNTIES.
AND THE SACRAMENTO AND INLAND
EMPIRE -- REGIONS SO ONE OF THE
PRIMARY JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THIS
BILL DOESN'T EVEN EXIST WHICH IS
THE SO CALLED NURSING SHORTAGE.
THE CHAIRS INTELLIGENCE CAN ASK
IF THE THE SUPPORTING WITNESSES
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS EITHER.
THE COMMENTS IN RESPONSE.
WELL I WILL JUST ADDRESS I SAID
ON AGING ON LONG TERM CARE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE OR
RIDGES IN LA COUNTY IN THE MORE.
AFFLUENT OR DANCE COUNTIES BUT
YESTERDAY'S AGING LONG TERM CARE --
MEETING ADDRESSED THE ISSUE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH WORK FORCE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I
APPRECIATE THAT.
BECAUSE I'M FROM LA COUNTY AT
THAT WE HAVE AN OR BRIDGE IN LA
COUNTY HOWEVER I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE WHOLE ENTIRE STATE AND THIS
DOESN'T ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT
ARE -- IN THE RURAL AREAS AND I
DO REPRESENT DALY COUNTY HOWEVER
I AM ALSO A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO
WE CAN'T PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH
WHICH AREAS.
HAVE MORE AND THE ONES THAT
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH WILL TOO BAD
FOR THEM FOR ME I WANT TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE ESPECIALLY
WITH THE SILVER TSUNAMI THAT'S
COMING -- THEY'RE ALL THERE ARE
OLD PEOPLE IN THE VALLEY TO AND
THEY NEED CARE OUR LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES HAVE A SHORTAGE
AND SO IF WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT STATISTICS -- AND THERE'S
AN ODD SHORTAGE IN PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AS WELL AND JUST
FURTHER WE DON'T CAP THE AMOUNT
OF TEACHERS THAT GO TO SCHOOL
ATTORNEYS WE DON'T CAP THE
AMOUNT OF ANY OTHER PROFESSIONS.
AND I DON'T SEE WHY WE WOULD CAP
A THIS CRITICAL -- COMPONENT OF
OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE SO
THAT'S MY OPINION BUT IN TERMS
OF THE THAT TECHNICAL ISSUES
GEORGE DO YOU WANT.
TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
YEAH ONE ONE I'D DON'T THINK WE
DISAGREE WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT SIMULATION IS ONE PORTION
AND AND THE THE EXAM IS ONE
PORTION AND AND YOU GOT A LOOK
AT THE BODY AS A WHOLE I ALSO
DON'T THINK THAT YOU GET IN THE
WE ALSO AGREE THAT.
IF A COMMUNITY COLLEGE SEATS ARE
AVAILABLE THAT IS THE LOWEST
COST OPTION AND WE'RE NOT THAT
THAT IS IN FACT THE CASE IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SEATS ARE
AVAILABLE THAT'S A GREAT OPTION
ESPECIALLY IF YOU WANT TO GET IN
INTO YOUR EIGHTY AND IF YOU WANT
TO GO BEYOND.
THAT OR WHAT HAVE YOU THERE ARE
OTHER OPTIONS IN IN IT IS AN
ISSUE AND THE AND THE THE THE
CLINICAL SLOTS ARE AN ISSUE.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO OPEN UP THE
FLOODGATES HERE.
WE ARE TRYING TO WEAVE I THINK
THE COMMITTEE IS PUT IN SOME
GOOD AMENDMENTS.
WITH THAT COMMITTEE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS ABOUT MAKING
CONTRIBUTIONS TO HOSPITALS AS IT
WAS ALLEGED.
OR MENTIONED I SHOULD SAY A
MOMENT AGO.
TO PUT A PROHIBITION IN PLACE.
THE COMMITTEE PUT IN A COHORT
DEFAULT RATE WHICHIS ACTUALLY
LESS THAN HALF OF WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO BE ABLE TO BE ELIGIBLE.
FOR ACCOUNT NANCY ACTUALLY HAVE
TO PERFORM IT TWICE THE LEVEL OF
AN INSTITUTION QUALIFYING FOR
CAL GRANTS SO I THINK THE
COMMITTEE IS DONE A LOT. TO IT
TOO TO TAKE THE BILL AND
ACTUALLY TAKE IT AND MAKE IT A
BETTER BILL TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU THEN DENTAL WAS AS WE
INTRODUCED IT.
AND I THINK THAT.
THE THE SPONSORS WANT TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION I HAD A I
HAD A REALLY GOOD MEETING WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SEIU LAST
THURSDAY WAS VERY ENCOURAGING I
THINK WE AGREED THAT WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK MOVING FORWARD.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE
HERE WANTS WE DO NOT HAVE THIS.
MANIFEST DESTINY YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA GRAB ALL OF THE SLOTS AND
AND THAT SHOULDN'T BE THE CASE
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE IMPORTANT.
IN MY FATHER'S A GREAT ANYWAY
DOES MATTER [inaudible]
IT'S IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AS A
MEMBER FONG.
AT JUST THE FOLLOWING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM IS --
THAT QUESTIONS I'VE MAYBE IT'S
DIRECTED TO THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL AS I REPRESENTS A CENTRAL
VALLEY OCCURRING COUNTY WE
CLEARLY HAVE WAITING LISTS IN
OUR COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
AND WE ALSO WE DEFINITELY DO
HAVE A NURSING SHORTAGE -- IN IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND SO -- IN
TERMS OF ADDRESSING THAT HOW
BORING THIS BILL WHICH I I DON'T
WANT SUPPORT TODAY BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE NEGOTIATED.
AT TELL THEM AND BE IMPROVED
UPON HOW HOW WOULD DO WE GET
MORE NURSES IN THE SUCH ABOUT.
THE BIG CAP THAT YOU REFERRED TO
IS IT WAS REALLY NOT THE NUMBER
OF NURSES THAT CAN BE EDUCATED
BUT SEE A NUMBER OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS THAT EXIST IN THE
COMMUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
EDUCATION THAT'S NECESSARY FOR
THE HOURS AND OF A CLINICAL
INSTRUCTION THAT ARE REQUIRED
AND EDUCATIONAL.
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE ARE
NEEDED IN ORDER TO MEET THE
OBJECTIVES OF THE NURSING
PROGRAM.
SO WHEN GROWTH IS CENTERED IN
THE CENTRAL AREA SPECIFIC AREA
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH CARE
AGENCIES ARE OVER RUN WITH
REQUEST TO SUPPORT NURSING
STUDENTS TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
SO THE CAP EXIST IN THE CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS WHEN A NEW PROGRAM
COMES IN AND CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
ARE FULL OR CAPPED AND HAVE NO
MORE ROOM SOMEONE ASKED TO LEAVE.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE ROOM AND
HISTORICALLY IT'S BEEN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
ARE DISPLACED BY THE GROWING
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE GROWN WITHOUT
REGULATION AND VERY RAPIDLY.
IF I MAY I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THE THE SCHOOLS THE SPONSORS --
ARE ADDING A MORE SCHOOLS THESE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR AM I MISTAKEN.
YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE WAS A
LOT OF QUESTION WAS HOW ARE WE
GOING TO ADDRESS.
I DO KNOW THE WESTERN GOVERNORS
UNIVERSITY IS ACTIVELY LOOKING
AT PARTNERSHIPS IN THE VALLEY I
KNOW THAT THEY ARE.
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
CORRECTIONAL HOSPITAL AND I
BELIEVE IT IS STOCKTON ABOUT
PARTNERING WITH THEM ON BEING
ABLE TO DO CLINICAL ROTATIONS.
SAID THEY ARE VERY MUCH --
THINK THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING TO
WORK IN.
THE PARTNERSHIP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL IN AREAS THAT.
THERE ARE -- MORE ACUTE
SHORTAGES YOU THINK I CAN ANSWER
THAT YES OR SOMEWHERE FONG JR
AND I'M AND I'M I I I'M NOT MY
QUESTIONS AS VISITING SPECIFIC
SCHOOLS -- MY MY QUESTION IS
JUST IN IN TERMS OF THERE IS A
NEED -- I THINK OUR HOSPITALS OF
CERTAINLY ARE LOOKING -- TO TO
HIRE MORE NURSES WITH THEIR NOW
FORCED TO BRING -- NURSES FROM
OVERSEAS -- NOW ON A TRAVEL
NURSES AS WELL AND SO THEY MADE.
FROM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THERE'S
A A CLEAR I MEAN -- PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND HEALTH OUTCOMES ARE
ARE ARE BEING IMPACTED RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF OUR LACK OF A NURSES
COMING THAT SUCH ABOUT.
THE BARRING ANY OTHER AREA --
LATE SO IN CALIFORNIA --
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- SO AND IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO ADDRESS A
SPECIFIC NEED IN MY COMMUNITY --
I I WAS JUST CURIOUS IN TERMS OF
HOW WE ADDRESS THAT BARRING.
PUTTING WINTERS IS IN THE
PIPELINE.
IT WAS IT WAS IT BUT JUST AS THE
S. M. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SEMI FONG WOULD JUST --
GOING TO THE ANY OTHER MEMBER
ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUIRK SILVA --
YES -- TO THE AUTHOR I'M SORRY
DID NOT HAVE A CONVERSATION
BEFORE AS I'M SUBBING TODAY BUT
THIS CONVERSATION AS FAR AS THE
COMMENTS WERE MADE.
AS FAR AS THE PLACEMENTS AND
SOMETIMES. ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
NOTED THAT THERE WAS A
CONTRIBUTION.
AND THEN THERE WAS A SCENARIO
THAT DEVELOPED -- BETWEEN ALL OF
A SUDDEN ONE OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DIDN'T NOW THE
PLACEMENT -- THAT THEY ARE
USUALLY EXPECTED SO THAT THEIR
STUDENTS COULD GET THE ACTUAL
PRACTICE -- AND THAT ACTUALLY
HAS OCCURRED -- AS I'VE HAD.
IN MY LOCAL DISTRICT A CYPRESS
COLLEGE WHICH IS WELL KNOWN FOR
THEIR NURSING PROGRAM THE
DIRECTOR -- SPEAK TO ME ABOUT
HOW.
THEY HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON THEIR
PROGRAM WHEN THEY CAN'T GET THE
PLACEMENT AFTER THE STUDENTS ARE.
DOING THEIR BASIC WORK AND NOW
THEY NEED TO BE PLACED ONE OF
THE OTHER ISSUES IS WE HAVE A
PRIVATE COLLEGE THAT IS WITHIN
THE SAME.
RADIUS AND IT IN AND IT APPEARED
THAT THOSE STUDENTS WERE BEING
TAKEN AHEAD OF THE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS SO -- WITHOUT
GIVING TOO MUCH MORE DETAIL
ABOUT THAT IT IS A BIG CONCERN
AS I KNOW IN HERE OFTEN THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE WAITING THEY MAY
EVEN ATTEND ONE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THEN -- TAKE COURSE
WORK THERE I HAVE FULLER CHEN
COLLEGE OF AND THEN TRANSFERRED
TO THE OTHER ONE BUT THEY'RE
STILL WAITING SO AT THIS POINT
I'M GOING TO BE A NON VOTE JUST
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION BUT I DEFINITELY
WANT TO SIT DOWN AND FIND OUT.
MORE ABOUT THIS AS THEIR IT
SEEMS TO BE MIXED INFORMATION OF
DO WE HAVE NURSES MOVING THROUGH
THE PIPE LINE OR ARE THERE.
I CONTINUE TO HEAR ABOUT IT AS
GETTING NURSES FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES AND SO FORTH SO I'D
LIKE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT IT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME [inaudible]
FOR AND THE THE AUTHOR SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO JEWISH TO
CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
THIS IS SIMPLY ABOUT ACCESS I'M
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE A PRODUCT OF
EAST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE MYSELF
AND SO I BELIEVE IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EDUCATION BUT
I ALSO BELIEVE IN.
ACCESS FOR FOLKS THAT DON'T HAVE --
THE LUXURY OF WAITING -- IN MY
PARTICULAR AREA ESPECIALLY IN
EAST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE WAITING
ANOTHER YEAR JUST MEANS WAITING
ANOTHER YEAR TO START A CAREER
THAT THAT NOT ONLY WILL HELP THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT ACT
HEALTH ACCESS BUT ALSO.
AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE GRADUATE
I WAS ABLE TO GET TO WORK
IMMEDIATELY AND SO EXPANDING
ACCESS TO THESEPROGRAMS WILL
HELP AND AGAIN SITTING IN LAW --
AGING AND LONG TERM CARE GAVE ME
THE THE THE SNAPSHOT ABOUT NON
LA COUNTY FOLKS THAT THERE IS A
SHORTAGE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND AGAIN I REPRESENT -- THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN
LA COUNTY BUT I'M ALSO
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTATIVE IN MY
JOB I SEE AS I SEE IT IS -- TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO ALL OF THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE ALL
CONTRACT TOGETHER -- AND SO WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS SOMEONE RUBIO THIS DOES
ENJOYED TO PASS RECOMMENDATION I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE GOING TO BE
CONTINUED.
WITH RESPECT TO FOCUS ON THE
QUALITY CONTROLS IN THE CRITICAL
DISPLACEMENT ASH AT THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW THOUGH I
BROKE BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY
EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON?
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA NOW.
TING TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS THIRTEEN BOTH
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU REST MEMBERS WE ARE ON
A FINAL BILL.
AND THIS IS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY
FIVE SO THE MEANTIME IT AGAIN IF --
MEMBERS ANYONE ELSE'S LISTENING
TO KILEY CALL ARE BEING P.
MEMBERS TO COMMITTEES A SO WE
CAN FINISH AND CONCLUDE AND
ADJOURNED SO HAVING SAID THAT
AGAIN MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN AB [inaudible]
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE VERSUS.
FIRST LET ME EXCEPT THE ARE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE YOUR WORK ON
THE ISSUE WHEN CALIFORNIA VOTED
TO LEGALIZE CANNABIS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN UNDER PROP.
SIXTY FOUR THEY ALLOWED CITIES
THE ABILITY TO LICENSE
BUSINESSES FOR THE CONSUMPTION
OF CANNABIS SUCH AS LOUNGES OR
CAFES.
AND WHILE THERE'S A GREAT DEAL
OF INTEREST IN THESE BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE THERE IS NO
CONSUMPTION LICENSE AT THE STATE
LEVEL PRESENTLY.
LOUNGES ARE CANNABIS BUSINESSES
THAT ALLOW FOR THE ON SITE
CONSUMPTION OF CANNABIS
CURRENTLY BUSINESSES THAT'S THAT --
RECEIVE A LOCAL CONSUMPTION
LICENSE MUST OBTAIN A STATE
ADULT USE CANNABIS RETAIL
LICENSE AND CONFORM TO THOSE
REGULATIONS HOWEVER THESE
REGULATIONS ARE GEARED TOWARDS
RETAIL CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
AND SPECIFICALLY THEY DO NOT
ALLOW NON CANNABIS PRODUCTS TO
BE SOLD WHICH MEANS THAT A
CANNABIS LOUNGE CANNOT SELL.
NON CANNABIS FOOD AND BEVERAGES
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
THE ISSUE WERE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH HERE CREATING A SEPARATE
LICENSE AT THE STATE LEVEL FOR
CANNABIS CONSUMPTION LOUNGES
WITH ACCOMPANYING RULES AND
REGULATIONS ALIGNED WITH THOSE
BUSINESSES.
IS NOT NECESSARY SO THAT THEY
CAN OPERATE EFFECTIVELY.
CANNABIS CONSUMPTION LOUNGES MAY
SOON BECOME AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THE NIGHT LIFE HOSPITALITY AND
TOURISM ECONOMIES IN THE CITIES
THAT AUTHORIZED THEM.
THUS CREATING APPROPRIATE
REGULATIONS FOR THESE BUSINESSES
IS NECESSARY AND SPECIFICALLY.
THIS BILL WILL CONFORM STATE
POLICY WITH LOCAL REGULATIONS
THAT ARE RELATED TO THESE
EMERGING HOSPITALITY VENUES.
HOWEVER IT SHOULD BE MADE CLEAR
THAT A. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE
LEAVES IT UP TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT TO ALLOW THESE LOUNGES IN
THE FIRST PLACE IN THEIR CITY AS
THEY CURRENTLY CAN DO.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL'S JOHN LEONARD WITH THE
CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UP TO THREE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN LEONARD
AND I'M WITH THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD.
PURSUANT TO PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOR THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD
ELECTED TO GRANT LICENSES FOR
CONSUMPTION LOUNGES.
AT THAT TIME IT WAS ANTICIPATED
THAT CONSUMPTION LOUNGES WOULD
OBTAIN RETAIL CANNABIS LICENSES
FROM THE STATE BUT WOULD ONLY
SELL PRODUCTS FOR ON SITE
CONSUMPTION.
WHEN THE FREDDIE AND WHEN THE
CITY FIRST STARTED WRITING IT'S
CANNABIS ORDINANCE DRAFT STATE
REGULATIONS LLOWED FOR THE SALE
OF NON CANNABIS PRODUCTS?
WHICH COULD INCLUDE FOOD AND
BEVERAGES.
WITH THIS IN MIND THE CITY
ENVISIONED THAT CANNABIS LOUNGES
WOULD BE ABLE TO SERVE NON
CANNABIS FOOD AND BEVERAGES
ALONG WITH CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
HOWEVER WHEN FINAL CANNABIS
REGULATIONS WERE RELEASED IN
JANUARY.
THIS PROVISION HAD BEEN CHANGED
AND ON CANNABIS PRODUCTS WERE NO
LONGER ALLOWED.
THE PROHIBITION ON THE SALE OF
NON CANNABIS PRODUCTS MAKES
SENSE FOR RETAIL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
IT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE FOR
CONSUMPTION LOUNGE TO BE
PROHIBITED FROM SELLING FOOD.
NINE CANNABIS FOOD AND BEVERAGES
ARE AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT TO
WEST HOLLYWOOD'S CONSUMPTION
LOUNGES BECAUSE THESE LOUNGES
WILL BE HIGH QUALITY HOSPITALITY
BUSINESSES.
AS MORE CITIES CONSIDER ISSUING
CONSUMPTION LOUNGE LICENSES IT
ALSO MAKES SENSE TO HAVE
SPECIFIC STATE REGULATIONS
REGARDING THEM INSTEAD OF SIMPLY
USING.
STATE RETAIL REGULATIONS SINCE
THE BUSINESS MODELS FOR THESE
TWO BUSINESSES ARE DIFFERENT.
WITH THIS IN MIND AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY FIVE WOULD CREATE A NEW
LICENSE TYPE AT THE STATE LEVEL
FOR CONSUMPTION LOUNGES.
ANALYZE THE BUREAU CANNABIS TOOK
CONTROL TO CREATE REGULATIONS
FOR THIS LICENSE TYPE.
DURING THE TIME THOSE
REGULATIONS ARE BEING DRAFTED AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE ALSO ALLOWS
THE BUREAU TO ISSUE A RETAIL
LICENSE.
THE CONSUMPTION LOUNGE
DESIGNATION TO CANNABIS LOUNGES
THAT ARE READY TO OPEN.
THESE BUSINESSES WOULD BE A
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO ADHERE TO
ALL STATE RETAIL REGULATIONS
WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS.
INCLUDING BEING ALLOWED TO
PREPARE AND SELL NON CANNABIS
FOOD AND BEVERAGES FOR ON SITE
CONSUMPTION.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THESE
BUSINESSES TO OPERATE AS
ENVISIONED WHILE THE FINAL
REGULATIONS ARE DRAFTED IN
CLOSING.
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR CURRENTLY
ALLOWS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
PERMIT CANNABIS CONSUMPTION
BUSINESSES IF THEY DESIRE.
TO BUT RECENTLY ADOPTED STATE
REGULATIONS DO NOT ALLOW THOSE
BUSINESSES TO PREPARE AND SELL
NON CANNABIS FOOD AND BEVERAGES
FOR THEIR FOR ON SITE
CONSUMPTION.
WHICH IS IMPORTANT COMPONENT TO
THEIR BUSINESS MODELS AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE ALLOWS THOSE
BUSINESSES TO PREPARE AND SERVE
FOOD AND ALSO ALLOWS THE BEER TO
BEGIN THE PROCESS.
OF CREATING REGULATIONS TAILORED
TO THE GROWING CANNABIS
CONSUMPTION INDUSTRY WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO WIN ASSISTANCE SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEE
KNOW WHEN THIS IS OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS COMES FROM COULD YOU
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE DUCK MISTER BLOOM
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I KNOW I PRO
BLOOM.
AYE BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHAN NOW JIM CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW DALY EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG FONG NOW GIPSON?
GIPSON AYE GLORIA [inaudible]
GORE I GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
THANK IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
WHEN I OBERNOLTE?
OBERNOLTE NOW QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS A LIVE IN BOTH WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS WE
HAVE CONCLUDED WITH ALL BILL
PRESENTATIONS.
AND WE'RE NOW GOING TO FILE
ORDER.
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS -- BUT WE
WILL FIRST MAKE MENTION THAT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY HAS BEEN
TOLD BY THE AUTHOR.
SO BACK TO FOLLOW ORDER WILL GO
INFO ORDER.
I WILL BEGIN WITH CONSENT.
AB THREE A. B. FIVE FOUR FOUR A.
B. FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN AB
FIFTEEN NINETEEN EVERY FIFTEEN
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIFTY TWENTY TWO EVERY FIFTEEN
TWENTY THREE ALL THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS.
IT BE FIFTEEN FIFTY THREE DO
PASS AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE
TO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
JILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CONSENT.
CUNNINGHAM HIGH GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY. THIRTY AYE
MEDINA.
BUT IN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
TING AYE.
BLOOM BUT MY NINETEEN ZERO THAT
IS OUT AND THEN WE WILL GO INTO
FILE ORDER WHICH IS FILE NUMBER.
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO AB THIRTEEN FORTY MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
GROW NOW BLOOM.
BUT MY CUNNINGHAM.
CAN YOU BY DOLLY.
GIPSON.
GIPSON HI GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
PARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE ACTING.
TING AYE. FIFTEEN TO TO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO ASSEMBLY
BILL AT THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN.
ANY THIRTEEN FORTY ONE MOTIONS
YOU PAST APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
BRO I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE. TWENTY TWO ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL. THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE BY DOCTOR EGGMAN WE
NEED A MOTION.
THE MOTION AND SECOND.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW AYE
BRO.
BRO NOW BLOOM [inaudible]
MY CHEN [inaudible] TO
CUNNINGHAM.
CAN I AM I DALY.
EGGMAN.
AGAIN I FONG.
I'M NOT GOING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN -- WHEN I
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY AYE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I'M OVERLOOKING OBERNOLTE
NOW QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
TING AYE. FOURTEEN TO TO THE
BILL WITHOUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WE NEED A
MOTION.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS LOW.
I KNOW I BROKE BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN [inaudible] TO
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN -- WHEN I
MCCARTY?
MCCARTY MEDINA.
BUT IN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING TING AYE.
SEVENTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE MOTIONS
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS BROWN.
WE'RE NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I..
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING TING AYE.
FIFTEEN TO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN COME LONGER DUFF
THIS DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
GIVEN THE TESTIMONY OF THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES.
AB TWO FORTY ONE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
FOR NOT VOTING BLOOM.
HI JILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING GIPSON.
AND I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING
[inaudible]
TING I THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE WHICH IS AB TWO
EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA THIS DOES ENJOY A CHAIR
FOR CONDITION OF HI.
AND SUPPORT GIVEN THE TESTIMONY
TO COMMIT TO WORKING ON THE
REMAINING PROVISIONS AS STATED
IN COMMITTEE.
AB TWO EIGHTY SIX MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
I MEAN I GIPSON.
GIVES A AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN -- WHEN
UPLOADING MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
TING AYE. SEVENTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TEN ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR ZERO
SEVEN BY.
SUMMER SANTIAGO.
AB FOUR ZERO SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
BUT MY TO CUNNINGHAM.
AB FOUR ZERO SEVEN MEASURES DO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP MY EGGMAN [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
HI.
GIPSON.
GIPSON GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
CRYSTAL I TING TING AYE.
NINETEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
I FOLLOW NUMBER TWELVE AB SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE BY LOW.
AB SOME SEVEN NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
BUT MY TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE IRWIN -- AND I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE ABILITY AYE
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
TING AYE. EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY BY SOME ERROR BRO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY MOTIONS YOU
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
BLOOM NOT VOTING. TO CUNNINGHAM.
COMING OUT I GLORIA.
GLORIA NOT VOTING GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AVERTING.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA NOT VOTING.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
COURSE OF A NOT VOTING TING.
TING TING TING UP ON ELEVEN
ELEVEN TO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN IS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT TWENTY TWO
BY SEVENTY WOMAN IRWIN DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AB EIGHT TWENTY TWO MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED HER PREPARATIONS
BLOOM [inaudible]
MY TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. FONG.
FONG I GLORIA [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON AYE.
HOLDEN.
HOLD AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE OBERNOLTE ABILITY AYE.
EIGHTEEN TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME IN
MEMBER LEVINE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
DO PASSED OUT THAT DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
WHEN I [inaudible]
TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE FONG FONG I
GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
AB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS MCCARTY.
THE CARD MCCARTY I MULLIN.
MON I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
MEDINA. THIRTY NINE EIGHTEEN TWO
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB TEN EIGHTEEN
BY SOMEONE OR FRAZIER DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AB TEN EIGHTEEN MOTIONS TO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS BLOOM.
BUT MY CHILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP BY EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GLORIA.
GORE I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING TING
[inaudible]
THING I EIGHTEEN TWO ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
ELEVEN FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
ANY OF THEM FORTY MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW DOLLY
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
WHEN I GIPSON?
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. THIRTEEN TO FIVE THAT
BILL IS OUT.
MOVING ON THEN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE SIXTY FOUR BY
SOMEONE PETRIE-NORRIS.
AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR MOTIONS YOU
MUST APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
TO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE DOLLY.
EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG?
PHONE NOT WEARING [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
IRWIN -- WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
WHAT I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
QUIRK SILVA?
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING. FOURTEEN
IS THERE THAT BILL IS OUT FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN TWELVE LOW.
AB THIRTEEN TWELVE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM.
BUT MY TO CUNNINGHAM.
CAN I AM NOT VOTING DALY EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG?
FROM NOT WEARING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE A RULES YOU
KNOW TING. FOURTEEN TO ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WITH THE MEN'S.
ANY THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX MOTIONS
TO PASS AS A MANAGER OF
OPERATIONS BRO.
BROWN NOW [inaudible]
TO FONG.
FONG NOW.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
THERE WERE NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NOW [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
I AM NOW. 1-226- THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN REVEAL.
I DO PASS I CONDITION WITH THE
METS.
ANY THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR MOTIONS
TO PASS AS A MANAGER OF
OPERATIONS BRO.
BRO I TO DOLLY [inaudible]
GLORIA.
COREY I GRAYSON.
AND I IRWIN.
AB -- THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR WHEN
NOT VOTING.
THIS SIXTEEN TO ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY FOUR FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
WE NEED A MOTION IT'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY MOTIONS YOU
FOSTER PREPARATIONS LOW HI THE
I. BRO.
BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN [inaudible] TO
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GORE I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE REALTY AYE
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING. FIFTEEN TO
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
NOW MOVING ON TO FOLLOW AT
NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN THIS IS AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM.
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
BRO NOW [inaudible] TO DOLLY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON OFFERING [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW. 1-126- THE BILL IS
OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBERS.
THE SEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY
FIVE HI ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT
THIS HAS A AYE RECOMMENDATION.
ANY FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE MOTIONS
TO PASS BLOOM.
BUT MY CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CAN I AM I DALY EGGMAN.
I MEAN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON NOT VOTING.
GLORIA.
KALRA AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN -- WHEN I
MCCARTY?
MCCARTY AYE.
MULLIN.
WELL I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE TING.
TING AYE [inaudible] TWO I
EIGHTEEN TWO ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT [inaudible]
SOME CONTEND.
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE
AB SEVENTEEN TEN BY DOCTOR WOULD
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB SEVENTEEN TEN MUST MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED JOE. TWO I
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY EGGMAN.
WHEN I GIPSON?
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
MCCARTY [inaudible]
I MULLIN.
MULLIN MY ABILITY OBERNOLTE AYE.
TING.
TING AYE. NINETEEN TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
MEMBERS THAT COMPLETES -- THE
FULL FILE FOR TODAY -- WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES FOR
NATIONAL MEMBERS.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR CAN IDEA
VOTE CHANGE [inaudible]
WHAT CHANGES?
I FORGOT HOW THEY DO THAT GOING
TO VOTE CHANGE AT THE END.
OKAY GO UP THERE
.
TO AB TWENTY SIX QUIRK SILVA
YESTER NOW [inaudible]
THE THE SO.
AB TWO EIGHTY SIX BONTA FINAL
VOTE
.
SIXTEEN TO ONE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX QUIRK SILVA YESTER NOW.
OF A TOTAL IS
.
ELEVEN TO SEVEN AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FOUR GLORIA I TO NOT
VOTING
.
AB THIRTEEN SIX FOUR FOR A
FIFTEEN TO ONE WE ARE ADJOURNED